PROPOSITION 33. THE AGENDA IS
POSTED ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
THE HEARING WILL PROCEED IN THE
FOLLOWING WAY. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WILL BE GIVEN AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE BRIEF
OPENING REMARKS. WE WILL THEN
HEAR FROM BRIAN UHLER FROM
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WILL
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO ASK MR.
UHLER QUESTIONS. THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WILL WALK US
THROUGH THE INITIATIVE. THEY ARE
NOT IN A POSITION TO GIVE AN
OPINION ON THE INITIATIVE, BUT
RATHER CAN DESCRIBE THE
INITIATIVE, INCLUDING THE FISCAL
IMPACTS. WE WILL THEN HEAR FROM
A PANEL OF FOUR ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
INITIATIVE, AND AFTER THAT,
WE'LL HEAR FROM A PANEL OF FOUR
ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE INITIATIVE.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK QUESTIONS OF
BOTH PANELS. WE WILL THEN MOVE
TO PUBLIC COMMENTS. PUBLIC MAY
STATE THEIR NAME, THEIR
AFFILIATION, THEIR PLACE OF
RESIDENCE, AND WHETHER THEY ARE
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO THE
INITIATIVE. I WANT TO BE CLEAR
THAT THIS IS A POLICY COMMITTEE
HEARING, AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE ABOUT, IS WE'RE
GOING TO BE ABOUT THE POLICY AS
IS CONTAINED WITHIN THE LANGUAGE
OF PROPOSITION 33. AND THE COST
TO HAWKINS. CURRENT LAW. AND
THAT AND OTHER THINGS THAT ARE
SQUARELY WITHIN THE JURISDICTION
OF THIS COMMITTEE. ANY ANYONE
WISH TO MAKE OPENING STATEMENT?
NO. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THIS THIS CONVERSATION, THIS
DISCUSSION, JUST TO PUT A FRAME
AROUND IT. THIS IS AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING. FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO ARE WATCHING. WE WILL
NOT VOTE. WE WILL NOT TAKE A
POSITION. INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS MAY
TAKE A POSITION ON WHATEVER
PROPOSITIONS THEY MAY CHOOSE TO,
BUT THE COMMITTEE WILL NOT TAKE
A POSITION ON THIS PROPOSITION.
YOU MAY ALSO SUBMIT WRITTEN
COMMENTS IF YOU LIKE. IF YOU GO
TO THE STATE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE, YOU'LL SEE
THAT THERE'S A PORTAL TO SUBMIT
WRITTEN COMMENTS. ONCE AGAIN, I
KNOW THIS IS A SURPRISE TO MANY
FOLKS, BUT ALL OF US ON THE
COMMITTEE CAN ACTUALLY READ. SO
HAVING SAID THAT, LET ME FIRST
INTRODUCE DEPUTY LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST UHLER TO GIVE AN
OVERVIEW. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR ROTH, FOR BEING HERE AS
WELL. SENATOR ROTH, DID YOU WANT
TO MAKE ANY OPENING COMMENT? ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU SIR. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. I'M BRIAN
MUELLER WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE, AND I'M HERE
TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF PROP
33 AND ALSO SUMMARIZE OUR
OFFICE'S ANALYSIS OF THE FISCAL
EFFECTS OF THE MEASURE. BEFORE I
GO INTO MY PRESENTATION, I JUST
WANTED TO REITERATE THE CHAIR'S
COMMENTS THAT OUR STATUTORY TASK
AS IT RELATES TO BALLOT
MEASURES, LIMITS OUR ANALYSIS TO
ONLY CONSIDERING THE FISCAL
ELEMENTS OF THE MEASURE, AND
EXPLICITLY PREVENTS US FROM
TALKING ABOUT THE POLICY MERITS
OF THE PROPOSED CHANGE. AND
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT OF A
DIFFERENT ROLE. OR IT IS A
DIFFERENT ROLE THAN YOU'RE USED
TO OF US TAKING IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS WHERE WE DO WEIGH IN
BOTH ON THE POLICY AND FISCAL
CONSIDERATIONS OF PROPOSALS. SO
TO MOVE INTO THE PRESENTATION,
PROP 33 IS A ESSENTIALLY A
QUESTION ABOUT THE SCOPE OF
AUTHORITY THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
IN CALIFORNIA HAVE TO ENACT RENT
CONTROL POLICIES. STATE LAW
CURRENTLY ALLOWS CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO ENACT LOCAL RENT
CONTROL, BUT WITHIN CERTAIN
LIMITATIONS. AROUND 30
MUNICIPALITIES IN THE STATE HAVE
SOME FORM OF RENT CONTROL. NOW,
AND THOSE ARE WITHIN THE LIMITS
OF STATE LAW, WHICH ARE SET OUT
IN THE COSTA-HAWKINS RENTAL
HOUSING ACT. THAT ACT CREATES
THREE PRIMARY LIMITATIONS. THE
FIRST IS THAT LOCAL RENT CONTROL
LAWS CANNOT APPLY TO ANY SINGLE
FAMILY HOUSING. THE SECOND IS
THAT IT CAN ONLY APPLY TO OLDER
HOUSING STOCK. IT CAN'T APPLY TO
ANYTHING BUILT AFTER FEBRUARY
1ST, 1995, AND THE FINAL
LIMITATION IS THAT A LOCAL RENT
CONTROL LAWS MUST ALLOW FOR
SO-CALLED VACANCY DECONTROL, AND
THIS MEANS THAT THEY CAN'T TELL
A LANDLORD HOW MUCH THEY CAN
INCREASE RENT. WHEN THE NEW
RENTER IS MOVING IN. THEY'RE
LIMITED ONLY TO RESTRICTING RENT
INCREASES FOR EXISTING TENANTS.
SO SIMPLY PUT, PROP 33 WOULD
REPEAL COSTA-HAWKINS IN ITS
ENTIRETY. SO THIS WOULD MEAN
THERE WOULD NO LONGER BE ANY
STATE LIMITATIONS ON THE TYPE
AND SCOPE OF RENT CONTROL THAT
CITIES AND COUNTIES IN THE STATE
COULD ENACT. THE MEASURE ITSELF
WOULDN'T MAKE ANY CHANGES TO
LOCAL RENT CONTROL RULES. THOSE
CHANGES WOULD MOSTLY BE
DEPENDENT ON FUTURE ACTIONS OF
LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS AND
LOCAL VOTERS. THAT BEING SAID,
WE THINK BASED ON HISTORICAL
EXPERIENCE, IT'S LIKELY THAT
SOME LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WOULD
EXPAND THE SCOPE OF LOCAL RENT
CONTROL TO AT LEAST SOME EXTENT
OVER TIME. SO THAT LEADS TO OUR
ANALYSIS OF THE MEASURES FISCAL
EFFECTS. ECONOMIC RESEARCH
SUGGESTS THAT AN EXPANSION OF
LOCAL RENT CONTROL WOULD HAVE A
COLLECTION OF POTENTIAL ECONOMIC
EFFECTS. WE CAN'T, YOU KNOW,
GIVE A CERTAIN QUANTIFICATION OF
THOSE EFFECTS BECAUSE MUCH OF IT
DEPENDS ON HOW MANY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TAKE ACTION IN
RESPONSE TO 33. WHAT'S THE SCOPE
OF THOSE CHANGES? BUT WE CAN
DISCUSS IN GENERAL KIND OF
QUALITATIVELY WHAT THOSE
POTENTIAL EFFECTS MAY BE. AND
I'LL HIGHLIGHT FOUR OF THEM. TWO
OF THEM APPLY TO RENTERS AND TWO
APPLY TO RENTAL PROPERTIES. THE
FIRST FOR RENTERS IS THAT SOME
COULD FACE A CHANGE IN THE COST
THEY PAY FOR RENT. ON THE ONE
HAND, SOME RENTERS, SPECIFICALLY
THOSE WHO LIVE IN RENTALS THAT
ARE NEWLY COVERED BY AN EXPANDED
RENT CONTROL RULE, LIKELY WOULD
PAY LESS FOR RENT THAN THEY
OTHERWISE WOULD. ON THE OTHER
HAND, OTHER RENTERS COULD END UP
PAYING MORE FOR RENT. AN EXAMPLE
THIS COULD BE A RENTER THAT IS
LIVING IN A NEIGHBORING
MUNICIPALITY TO A ONE THAT JUST
EXPANDED RENT CONTROL, BUT WHERE
THERE IS NOT A RENT CONTROL IN
THE MUNICIPALITY THAT THEY'RE
LIVING. THE SECOND POTENTIAL
EFFECT ON RENTERS IS THAT THEY
WOULD TEND TO MOVE LESS OFTEN,
AND THIS CAN BE FOR A FEW
REASONS. ONE IS SOME RENTERS MAY
BE LESS LIKELY TO ESSENTIALLY BE
SORT OF FORCED TO MOVE BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T AFFORD A RENT
INCREASE. ALSO, YOU COULD HAVE
SOME RENTERS WHO SIMPLY CHOOSE
NOT TO MOVE BECAUSE THEY ARE
RECEIVING A GOOD DEAL ON THEIR
RENT CONTROLLED APARTMENT AND DO
NOT WANT TO PAY MORE TO MOVE TO
A NEW RENTAL. SO THOSE ARE KIND
OF THE EFFECTS. THE Kò EFFECTS
ON RENTERS MOVING TO RENTAL
PROPERTIES THEMSELVES. THE FIRST
Kò EFFECT IS A LIKELY REDUCTION
IN THE SUPPLY OF RENTAL HOUSING,
AND THERE'S A FEW POTENTIAL
MECHANISMS FOR THIS. THE ONE FOR
WHICH THERE'S THE MOST EVIDENCE
IS THAT LANDLORDS WOULD SOME
LANDLORDS WOULD ESSENTIALLY GET
OUT OF THE BUSINESS OF BEING A
LANDLORD. THEY WOULD SELL THE
RENTAL TO SOMEONE, AN OWNER WHO
WOULD LIVE THERE. THEY WOULD
CONVERT IT TO A CONDO, ETC. THIS
WOULD REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
RENTALS THAT ARE AVAILABLE FOR
RENTERS. THE FINAL EFFECT IS
THAT RENTAL HOUSING WOULD LIKELY
BECOME LESS PROFITABLE, AND THIS
WOULD REDUCE THE AMOUNT THAT
POTENTIAL LANDLORDS ARE WILLING
TO PAY FOR RENTAL PROPERTIES,
REDUCING THE VALUE OF THOSE
PROPERTIES. SO NARROWING IN FROM
THESE ECONOMIC EFFECTS, WE CAN
TALK ABOUT A FEW KIND OF
SPECIFIC EFFECTS THAT THE
MEASURE COULD HAVE ON THE
FINANCES OF STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. AND I'LL HIGHLIGHT
TWO Kò KIND OF FISCAL EFFECTS.
THE FIRST AND MOST SIGNIFICANT
IS A LIKELY REDUCTION IN
PROPERTY TAX REVENUES FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND SCHOOLS. AND
THIS KIND OF FLOWS DIRECTLY FROM
THE ECONOMIC IMPACT. I MENTIONED
A MINUTE AGO ABOUT A REDUCTION
IN THE VALUE OF RENTAL
PROPERTIES. WE THINK THAT THAT
REDUCTION IN PROPERTY TAXES OVER
TIME COULD REACH AT LEAST TENS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS PER YEAR.
THE OTHER FISCAL EFFECT IS A
LIKELY INCREASE IN
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO CARRY OUT
EXPANDED RENT CONTROL RULES.
THOSE COSTS COULD BE IN THE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS A YEAR, UP
TO TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS,
AND TRADITIONALLY THOSE COSTS
ARE PAID BY FEES THAT ARE LEVIED
ON LANDLORDS. SO WITH THAT, I
WILL BE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT. OVERVIEW. MEMBERS.
QUESTIONS. YES, SENATOR RUSSELL,
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR REPORT. WHEN YOU SAID
THAT THERE WOULD, IN TERMS OF
THE FISCAL IMPACT ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS OR ANYWHERE IN THE
STATE, LIKE THEY WOULD BE LESS
PROFITABLE, LANDLORDS WOULD SELL
PROPERTIES. WHAT DO YOU BASING
THAT ON? AND DID YOU BASE IT ON
ACTUALLY LOOKING AT A PARTICULAR
CITY OR THE CITIES WHOSE THE
QUARTER OF CALIFORNIANS WHO LIVE
IN THOSE COMMUNITIES WITH RENT
CONTROL. SO OTHERWISE, IT SOUNDS
LIKE YOU JUST SORT OF THROWING
IT ALL OUT. MILLIONS, TENS OF
MILLIONS. YES. THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION BECAUSE
I NEGLECTED TO MENTION THIS IN
MY COMMENTS, WHICH I WHICH I DID
MEAN TO COVER. OUR ANALYSIS.
FOCUSES ON EFFECTS THAT THERE IS
SOME RIGOROUS EMPIRICAL EVIDENCE
SUPPORTING. SO OBVIOUSLY THERE'S
A NUMBER OF POTENTIAL EFFECTS
THAT YOU COULD MAKE, SORT OF
THEORETICAL OR HYPOTHETICAL
ARGUMENTS IN FAVOR OF. WE
LIMITED OUR SCOPE TO WHERE THERE
IS ESSENTIALLY ACADEMIC RESEARCH
LOOKING AT HISTORICAL EXPERIENCE
IN PLACES WHERE RENT CONTROL IS
PUT IN PLACE AND WHAT EFFECTS
CAN BE MEASURED. A LOT OF THAT
RESEARCH IS NOT CALIFORNIA
SPECIFIC. SOME OF IT IS FROM
AROUND THE COUNTRY. SOME OF IT
IS FROM AROUND THE WORLD. BUT
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF STUDIES
LOOKING AT THESE SORT OF VARIOUS
EFFECTS AND THE FOUR THAT I
LISTED ARE ONES WHERE THE, THE
SIGNIFICANT MAJORITY OF THOSE
STUDIES HAVE FOUND THAT EFFECT
TO BE THE CASE. AND SO THAT'S,
THAT'S SORT OF THE BASIS FOR THE
EFFECTS THAT WE CALL OUT AND
WHICH ONES WE DO AND WHICH ONES
WE DON'T TALK ABOUT IN OUR
ANALYSIS. AND THEN JUST ONE MORE
QUESTION. IN TERMS OF THE
INCREASE IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT
FINANCIALLY, HAVING TO PUT OUT
MORE FOR THE DIFFERENT REASONS
THAT YOU CITED, DID YOU LOOK AT
WHAT THE GOVERNMENTS COULD SAVE?
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS COULD SAVE AS
A RESULT OF HAVING, YOU KNOW,
LIKE THE ISSUE OF HOMELESSNESS
OR, YOU KNOW, THE COST TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT? NOW, ON THOSE ON
THOSE ISSUES THAT COULD BE
IMPACTED BY PEOPLE PAYING LESS
FOR THEIR RENT. YEAH. SO THOSE
ARE DEFINITELY FACTORS THAT WE
CONSIDERED. I THINK THAT, YOU
KNOW, AS I MENTIONED, JUST A
SECOND AGO WITH WHAT, YOU KNOW,
ECONOMIC EFFECTS, WE DECIDED TO
HIGHLIGHT IN OUR ANALYSIS, I
THINK SOME OF THOSE THOSE OTHER
QUESTIONS, AGAIN, POTENTIAL
EFFECTS ON HOMELESSNESS OR
DEMAND FOR SOCIAL SERVICES OR
THINGS LIKE THAT ARE AREAS WHERE
OUR OUR REVIEW OF THE RESEARCH
HAS NOT PROVIDED ENOUGH OF AN
EVIDENTIARY BASE FOR US TO FEEL
LIKE WE COULD MAKE A CLEAR
STATEMENT ON THE EFFECTS ON
THOSE KINDS OF COSTS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. THE ONE THAT WE DO
HIGHLIGHT, KIND OF THE COST TO
ADMINISTER THESE IS SORT OF A
THERE'S SORT OF A DIRECT NEXUS
THERE. SO I THINK WE FEEL
COMFORTABLE CALLING THAT OUT AS
A POTENTIAL COST. OKAY. THAT'S
IT FOR ME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
SENATOR RUSSO. OTHER QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT. MR. MUELLER, THANK
YOU SO MUCH. LET'S BRING UP THE
FIRST PANEL. JUST BY WAY OF
HOUSEKEEPING. EACH PANEL WILL
HAVE 40 MINUTES, WHICH IF YOU
BREAK IT DOWN BY WITNESSES, THAT
MEANS THAT EACH WITNESS WOULD
HAVE TEN MINUTES. YOU'RE NOT
REQUIRED TO ACTUALLY TAKE TEN
MINUTES. IF YOU CAN GET YOUR
POINT ACROSS IN LESS THAN TEN
MINUTES, WE WOULD WE WOULD
WELCOME THAT. SO THE FIRST PANEL
CONSISTS OF GO AHEAD AND WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE UNLIKE OUR NORMAL
FORMAT, PANELISTS CAN COME
FORWARD AND GO AHEAD AND SIT AT
THE TABLE. SO THE FIRST PANEL
WILL COME FORWARD. IT'S SHANTI
SINGH LEGISLATIVE AND
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR FOR
TENANTS TOGETHER OUT OF BRAZIL,
CO-PRESIDENT OF UNITE HERE,
LOCAL 11 MICHELLE GUTIERREZ,
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION, AND SUSIE SHANNON,
DIRECTOR OF HOUSING IS A HUMAN
RIGHT. THE DIVISION OF AIDS
HEALTH CARE FOUNDATION. ALL
RIGHT. LET'S GO AHEAD AND DO IT
IN THE ORDER IN WHICH I'VE
ANNOUNCED. SO FIRST, SHANTI
SINGH, IS THIS WORKING? OH,
PERFECT. YEP. I THINK THEY'RE
ALL WORKING. I ALWAYS GET
NERVOUS. THANK YOU TO CHAIR
UMBERG COMMITTEE STAFF AND
MEMBERS FOR INVITING ME HERE
TODAY. MY NAME IS SHANTI SINGH
AND I AM THE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR TENANTS. TOGETHER,
WE'RE A CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE
COALITION FOR TENANTS RIGHTS. I
MYSELF HAVE BEEN A TENANT OF
RENT CONTROLLED HOUSING FOR
ALMOST A DECADE, LIVING WITH
LONG TERM NEIGHBORS ON FIXED
INCOMES AND NEW NEIGHBORS WHO
ALSO NEED ECONOMIC STABILITY.
OUR 60 MEMBER ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS THE STATE ARE LED BY
TENANTS LIVING IN ALL TYPES OF
HOUSING, AND SINCE OUR FOUNDING
IN 2008, WE'VE SUPPORTED MANY
LOCAL CAMPAIGNS FOR TENANT
PROTECTIONS, INCLUDING RENT
CONTROL IN EVERY PART OF THE
STATE, AS WELL AS STATE LEVEL
INITIATIVES TO REPEAL OR AMEND
COSTA-HAWKINS. OUR COALITION IS
UNANIMOUS IN OUR SUPPORT FOR
PROP 33. FIRST OFF, THE BAT,
ALTHOUGH I THINK LEO JUST DID A
WONDERFUL JOB CRITICAL TO
CLARIFY WHAT PROP 33 DOES AND
DOESN'T DO. IT DOES TWO THINGS.
IT DELETES THE LANGUAGE OF
COSTA-HAWKINS FROM STATE LAW,
AND IT PUTS THE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR DECIDING RENT STABILIZATION
POLICY BACK INTO THE HANDS OF
CITY AND COUNTY OFFICIALS AND
THE VOTERS THEMSELVES. IT DOES
NOT AFFECT IN ANY WAY THE LAND
USE AUTHORITY OF LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS OR STATE
GOVERNMENTS, WHAT WE CALL RENT
CONTROL IN THE US TODAY AND IN
CALIFORNIA IS SECOND GENERATION
RENT CONTROL, WHICH AFFECTS
INCREASES IN RENTS. IT ALLOWS
LANDLORDS TO SET BASE RENTS ON
NEW PROPERTIES TO WHATEVER THE
MARKET WILL BEAR. DECADES OF
CASE LAW HAVE TESTED THIS IN OUR
COURTS, ALLOWING LANDLORDS TO
ADJUST ABOVE RENT CONTROL WHEN
THEY NEED TO MAKE MAJOR AND
CRITICAL IMPROVEMENTS, AND
GUARANTEEING THEM A FAIR RETURN
ON THEIR INVESTMENT. SO RENT
CONTROL SIMPLY PREVENTS MASSIVE
WINDFALL GAINS AND PUTS MONEY
BACK INTO RENTERS POCKETS TO
SPEND ON THEIR FAMILIES AND
CIRCULATE THOSE DOLLARS BACK
INTO THE COMMUNITIES AND SMALL
BUSINESSES NEAR WHERE THEY LIVE.
IN THE PAST THREE YEARS ALONE,
WE HAVE GONE FROM ABOUT 20 TO
ABOUT 30. SO TEN CALIFORNIA
JURISDICTIONS HAVE PASSED THEIR
OWN RENT CONTROL LAWS SINCE
COVID STARTED. FOR THE VERY
FIRST TIME, THREE HAVE
STRENGTHENED THEIR RENT CONTROL
LAWS ON TOP OF THAT, WE SEE NEW
CITIES GOING TO THEIR VOTERS AND
CITY COUNCILS EVERY YEAR. RENT
CONTROL HAS NOW BEEN INITIATED
IN CITIES IN ORANGE, VENTURA,
KERN, MARIN AND MONTEREY
COUNTIES FOR THE FIRST TIME
EVER, AND A NUMBER OF THOSE
INITIATIVES HAVE PASSED. WE SEE
THAT CALIFORNIANS ARE
INCREASINGLY TURNING TO RENT
CONTROL. AS ONE OF ONE OF
SEVERAL CRITICAL TOOLS TO
MITIGATE DISPLACEMENT, PREVENT
HOMELESSNESS, AND PUT DOLLARS
BACK IN THE POCKETS OF TENANTS,
ALL WHILE GUARANTEEING A FAIR
AND PROFITABLE RETURN. THIS ALSO
MEANS THAT MORE AND MORE
CALIFORNIANS ARE BUMPING INTO
THE ARBITRARY AND POORLY
DESIGNED LIMITS THAT
COSTA-HAWKINS HAS PLACED ON THEM,
AND MORE CALIFORNIANS WILL
CONTINUE TO BUMP INTO THOSE
LIMITS IN THE FUTURE. AS RENT
CONTROL EXPANDS. WE BELIEVE THAT
THE STATUS QUO THAT
COSTA-HAWKINS HAS CREATED IS
UNTENABLE FOR CALIFORNIA'S 17
MILLION TENANTS, INCLUDING THOSE
WHO DO NOT CURRENTLY BENEFIT
FROM RENT CONTROL BUT COULD VERY
MUCH DO SO IN THE FUTURE. IT IS
A 1994 LAW THAT IS NOT EQUIPPED
TO RESPOND TO THE CHALLENGES THE
CALIFORNIA OF 2024 FACES. THAT
SAME YEAR, 1994, THE STATE OF
MASSACHUSETTS BANNED ALL RENT
CONTROL, REPEALING SEVERAL LOCAL
ORDINANCES. THERE WAS NO MASSIVE
FLOURISHING OF SUPPLY OR HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION ENABLED BY DOING
THAT. TO MAKE MATTERS WORSE,
STUDIES ABOUT MASSACHUSETTS
SHOWED THAT NOT ONLY DID THE
STATEWIDE BAN RAISE RENTS AND
REDUCE TENANT STABILITY, BUT IT
ALSO RAISED RENTS IN HOMES IN
THE SAME AREAS THAT WERE NOT
SUBJECT TO RENT CONTROLS IN THE
FIRST PLACE. MANY OF THE TALKING
POINTS THAT WE'VE SEEN ABOUT
RENT CONTROL WOEFULLY
MISINTERPRET THE RESULTS OF
AVAILABLE EMPIRICAL RESEARCH,
WHICH INDICATE CLEARLY THAT
LOOPHOLES AROUND RENT CONTROL
CREATE ADVERSE EFFECTS ON
SUPPLY, WHILE RENT CONTROL
ITSELF SIMPLY STABILIZES
COMMUNITIES. AND AS WE OFTEN PUT
IT, THAT IS LIKE BLAMING A
FIREFIGHTER FOR THE EXISTENCE OF
A FIRE. IN CITIES WHERE
COSTA-HAWKINS BANS RENT CONTROL
AFTER THE LATE 1970S OR EARLY
1980S. SO SAN FRANCISCO,
OAKLAND, LOS ANGELES. WE'VE
HEARD FROM DISABLED TENANTS ON
FIXED INCOMES WHO ARE UNABLE TO
ACCESS ADA COMPLIANT RENT
CONTROLLED HOUSING BECAUSE VERY
LITTLE ACCESSIBLE HOUSING WAS
BUILT BEFORE THE NOW 45 YEAR OLD
CUT OFF DATE. IN OTHER CITIES
WHERE COSTA-HAWKINS ALLOWS RENT
CONTROL TO BE IMPLEMENTED UP TO
HOUSING BUILT BEFORE 1995 BUT
NOT SINGLE FAMILY HOMES, WE'VE
SEEN MISINFORMATION TARGETING
VOTERS WHO RENT HOMES THAT CAN'T
BE COVERED BY RENT CONTROL
BECAUSE OF COSTA-HAWKINS, TO
DISCOURAGE THEM FROM SUPPORTING
RENT CONTROL AT ALL, AND THIS
PARTICULAR CHALLENGE HAS BEEN
GROWING EVER SINCE. THE 2008
HOUSING CRISIS LED TO LARGE
SCALE INVESTORS PURCHASING TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF FORECLOSED
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES AND IMPOSING
UNSUSTAINABLE OVERNIGHT RENT
INCREASES AND OFTEN BOGUS FEES
ON THEIR TENANTS. IT WAS JUST A
LAWSUIT ABOUT THIS FROM THE AG.
WE HAVE SEEN LAWSUITS FILED BY
TENANTS IN RENT CONTROLLED
HOUSING REPORTING HARASSMENT IN
DIFFICULT CONDITIONS BECAUSE
MANY CORPORATE ACTORS WHO ARE
BUYING UP RENT CONTROLLED
HOUSING BECAUSE IT'S STILL
PROFITABLE, HAVE WEAPONIZED
COSTA-HAWKINS IN AN ATTEMPT TO
FORCE TENANTS OUT TO RESET BASE
RENTS TO MARKET OR FLIP UNITS
VIA MISUSES OF THE ELLIS ACT
THAT ARE BEYOND THE INTENDED
PURPOSE OF THAT LAW. WHEN WE AS
IMPACTED TENANTS ARE TOLD THAT
THE LOSS OF OUR VERY HOMES TO
SPECULATIVE CONVERSION IS
SOMEHOW THE FAULT OF THE
PROTECTION THAT KEPT US IN OUR
HOMES IN THE FIRST PLACE, WE ARE
COMPELLED TO REJECT THAT
FRAMING, KNOWING FULL WELL THAT
THE RESEARCH POINTS OUT QUITE
CLEARLY THAT SPECULATIVE
LOOPHOLES ARE THE CULPRIT AS
WELL. MOST CALIFORNIA CITIES, WE
BELIEVE, WANT TO ACHIEVE HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY, EVEN WHEN THEY
CHOOSE DIFFERENT PATHS TO GET
THERE. MOST CALIFORNIA CITIES
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY HAVE URGENT
STATE MANDATES TO DO SO, THAT
NONE OF US OR THEM, CAN IGNORE
MANDATES THAT INCLUDE
SIGNIFICANT EXPANSION OF THE
PART OF THE HOUSING STOCK THAT
IS SPECIFICALLY AVAILABLE TO LOW
AND MIDDLE INCOME PEOPLE WHOSE
WAGES CANNOT HOPE TO COVER
MARKET RENTS. WE ARE PRESENTLY
LOSING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ACCESSIBLE TO MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO CANNOT AFFORD
MARKET RATES OR HOME OWNERSHIP
FAR FASTER THAN WE CAN FUND AND
BUILD IT, BECAUSE WE'RE ALLOWING
PERVERSE INCENTIVES CREATED BY
LAWS LIKE OUTDATED LAWS LIKE
COSTA-HAWKINS TO PERSIST. I
INVITE THE COMMITTEE AND THE
PUBLIC TO CONSIDER THAT THE
DEVASTATION OF THIS CRITICAL
SEGMENT OF THE HOUSING MARKET
IS, AS URGENT AS SUPPLY CRISIS
AS ANY OTHER. RENT CONTROL HAS
BEEN A BULWARK AGAINST AN EVEN
MORE ACUTE CRISIS IN THE CITIES.
IN WHICH IT HAS BEEN ENACTED,
EVEN IN ITS LIMITED FORM. WHICH
IS WHY MORE AND MORE
CALIFORNIANS ARE PURSUING IT IN
PLACES THAT IT HASN'T BEEN
PURSUED BEFORE, AND WHY IT HAS
EVEN NOW BECOME A POLICY ISSUE
IN OUR UPCOMING PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION. I WILL JUST CONCLUDE
WITH SOME WORDS FROM J.W. MASON,
INCREDIBLE ECONOMIST WHO'S PART
OF A GROWING GROUP OF ECONOMISTS
CALLING AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL FOR
A REVISITING OF RENT CONTROL
POLICY, MUCH IN THE SAME WAY
THAT WE'VE REVISITED OUR PRIOR
ORTHODOXY ON MINIMUM WAGE LAWS.
HE SAYS THERE IS A SOCIAL
INTEREST IN INCOME, DIVERSITY
AND STABLE NEIGHBORHOODS IN THE
ABSENCE OF RENT CONTROL OR OTHER
MEASURES TO CONTROL HOUSING
COSTS, AN AREA THAT SEES RISING
PRODUCTIVITY OR IMPROVED
AMENITIES MAY SEE A SHARP RISE
IN RENTS AND BECOME AFFORDABLE
ONLY FOR HIGHER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. BESIDES THE
QUESTIONS OF EQUITY THAT THIS
RAISES, THERE ARE ECONOMIC COSTS
HERE AS IT BECOMES DIFFICULT FOR
PEOPLE HOLDING LOWER PAID JOBS
TO LIVE WITHIN COMMUTING
DISTANCE, AN AREA THAT BECOMES
MORE HOMOGENEOUS MAY ALSO LOSE
THE SOCIAL AND CULTURAL DYNAMISM
THAT CAUSE THE IMPROVEMENT IN
THE FIRST PLACE. SIMILARLY, THE
EVIDENCE SEEMS CLEAR THAT IN THE
ABSENCE OF RENT REGULATION,
TURNOVER AMONG TENANTS WILL BE
HIGHER, LEADING TO LESS STABLE
COMMUNITIES AND DISCOURAGING
INVESTMENT BY RENTERS IN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS. THE ABSENCE OF
RENT REGULATION MAY ALSO CREATE
POLITICAL OBSTACLES TO EFFORTS
TO INCREASE HOUSING SUPPLY,
ATTRACT NEW EMPLOYERS, OR
OTHERWISE IMPROVE URBAN AREAS.
SINCE CURRENT RESIDENTS
CORRECTLY PERCEIVE THAT THE
RESULT OF ANY IMPROVEMENT MAY BE
HIGHER. RENTS AND DISPLACEMENT.
RENT REGULATION REMOVES THESE
CONFLICTS BETWEEN THE SOCIAL
INTEREST IN THRIVING HIGH WAGE
CITIES AND THE INTERESTS OF
CURRENT RESIDENTS. THIS MAKES IT
AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF ANY
BROADER URBAN DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM. WE BELIEVE IN TAKING A
BOTH AND APPROACH TO HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION AND TENANT
PROTECTION, AND NEARLY EVERY
DOMAIN EXPERT WORKING ON THE
FRONTLINES OF DISPLACEMENT AND
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA NOT
JUST TENANT ADVOCATES, BUT
INCLUDING MANY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PRODUCERS, BUILDERS AND
PROVIDERS. JOIN US IN SUPPORTING
PROP 33 FOR THIS REASON. THANK
YOU AGAIN VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT. LET'S GO WITH
MISS BRICENO. NEXT. GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. CHAIR UMBERG AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR HEARING
OUR VOICES ON BEHALF OF UNITE
HERE LOCAL 11 REPRESENTING
32,000 HOTEL AND FOOD SERVICE
WORKERS IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND ARIZONA. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
PROPOSITION 33. LOCAL 11
REPRESENTS HOSPITALITY WORKERS
WHO ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY RENT
BURDEN AND PAY WELL OVER 30% OF
THEIR MONTHLY INCOME TOWARDS
RENT. IN THIS STATE. WE HAVE
PUSHED WE HAVE MEMBERS WHO HAVE
BEEN PUSHED OUT OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES, THE COMMUNITIES
THAT THEY'VE BUILT, THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY'VE RAISED,
THEIR CHILDREN, THE COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE THEY'VE CALLED HOME
FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME
BECAUSE OF THE RENT GOUGING. AND
PEOPLE HAVE TO COMMUTE 2 OR 3
HOURS SOMETIMES TO MAKE THEIR
WAY TO WORK. THEY'RE FORCED TO
LIVE IN RVS OR COUCH SURF JUST
TO GET BY. PROPOSITION 33 WOULD
ALLOW COMMUNITIES TO DETERMINE
RENT STABILIZATION POLICIES THAT
FIT THEIR COMMUNITY BEST. AND,
YOU KNOW, IF THERE'S ANY
ADJUSTMENTS THAT THEY DEEM
NECESSARY AT ALL. RENT CONTROL
TAKES MANY FORMS, AND IT DEPENDS
ON WHAT LOCAL COMMUNITIES ARE
DEALING WITH. WE KNOW THAT
HOUSING IS ESSENTIAL, THAT
HOUSING IS A HUMAN RIGHT, AS
DECLARED BY THE UNITED NATIONS
DECLARATION OF HUMAN RIGHTS THAT
WAS PASSED IN DECEMBER 10TH OF
1948, AND ARTICLE 25 STATES THAT
EVERYONE HAS A RIGHT TO A DECENT
STANDARD OF LIVING, INCLUDING
FOOD, CLOTHING, HOUSING, HOUSING
AND MEDICAL CARE AND SOCIAL
SERVICES, AND WE HERE HAVE A
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS. IN
FACT, THERE ARE MORE RENT
BURDENED PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
THAN ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE
COUNTRY. AS YOU KNOW, INCREASES
IN WAGES HAVE DEFINITELY NOT
KEPT UP WITH WITH THE RISE IN
RENTS AND MANY PEOPLE ARE SEEING
THEIR QUALITY OF LIFE
DETERIORATE AS A RESULT. WE SEE
A STARTING TEACHER OR A POLICE
OFFICER OR EVEN A FIREFIGHTER
THAT IS PAYING AT LEAST HALF OF
THEIR WAGES IN ORDER TO RENT,
AND THAT IS IN, IN, THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA FOR MANY LOW WAGE
WORKERS LIKE HOTEL WORKERS OR
CAREGIVERS, SOMETIMES IT COULD
BE 100% OF THEIR WAGES TO RENT.
AND, YOU KNOW, ALL THE WHILE
THAT CORPORATE LANDLORDS ARE
DRIVING UP RENTS WITH REALLY NO
END IN SIGHT. THERE'S MORE
GENTRIFICATION, TENANT
DISPLACEMENT AND MORE EVICTIONS.
THE SITUATION HAS BECOME SO DIRE
THAT OUR WORKERS ARE STRESSED
EVERY SINGLE MONTH, JUST TO
FIGURE OUT IF THEY CAN PAY THEIR
RENT. AND WE BELIEVE LOCAL 11
HAS AN OBLIGATION NOT ONLY TO
UNIONIZED WORKERS IN THE HOTEL
INDUSTRY, BUT ALSO NONUNION
WORKERS ACROSS THE STATE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE HELPING PASS
PROPOSITION 33. I HAVE AN
EXAMPLE OF BRENDA MENDOZA, WHO
WHO LIVED IN LOS ANGELES
KOREATOWN, JUST TEN MINUTE DRIVE
FROM HER UPSCALE J.W. MARRIOTT
HOTEL. SHE HAD BEEN WORKING
THERE FOR 14 YEARS, BUT SHE GOT
PRICED OUT OF HER DOWNTOWN AREA
WHERE SHE GREW UP, AND NOW SHE
TRAVELS ALMOST 100 MILES TO
APPLE VALLEY AND SHE COMMUTES.
HER COMMUTE IS ABOUT 2 OR 3
HOURS. THIS TAKES A TOLL IN HER
BODY. IN HER MIND, THE TIME THAT
SHE SPENDS WITH HER FAMILY, THE
GAS THAT SHE SPENDS, AND IT'S
REALLY HARD TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
68% OF CALIFORNIA'S GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS ARE DIRECTLY
RELATED TO INDIVIDUAL CARS AND
TRUCKS. EMISSION. AND, YOU KNOW,
AND THAT'S PART OF WHY, YOU
KNOW, WE CARE FOR OUR
ENVIRONMENT. AND THAT'S PART OF
WHY WE'RE HERE TO TALK ABOUT
PROPOSITION 33. WE WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO MEET OUR GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS GOALS BY 2045. IF WE
DON'T ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
SKYROCKETING RENTS, HOUSING
COSTS AND EVICTIONS, AND THE
RESULTING DISPLACEMENT HAS
CAUSED TREMENDOUS SUFFERING. AS
I SAID, I HAVE ANOTHER EXAMPLE
OF LETICIA ORTEGA DE CEBALLOS,
WHO SLEEPS IN HER CAR. SO SHE
CAN PAY HER HOUSE. THAT'S MORE
THAN 100 MILES AWAY. AGAIN,
ANOTHER PERSON, SHE HAS TWO JOBS
CLEANING HALLWAYS AND LOBBIES AT
HOTELS, AND SHE ONLY GETS TO GO
HOME THREE DAYS A WEEK TO SEE
HER. HER FAMILY. WORKING
FAMILIES DESERVE BETTER AND WE
FEEL THAT WE CAN'T IGNORE THIS.
WE ARE TAKING PART IN, YOU KNOW,
THE PEOPLE HAVE SAID, WELL, YOU
KNOW, HAVE YOU WERE YOU FOCUSED
ON THIS IN PRIOR YEARS? WELL,
MAYBE NOT TO THE EXTENT THAT WE
ARE TODAY BECAUSE WE ARE HEARING
MORE AND MORE FROM OUR MEMBERS,
MORE THAN EVER HOW RENT BURDENED
THEY ARE. SO IN NOVEMBER, YOU
LOCAL 11 WANTS TO DO ITS PART BY
SUPPORTING PROPOSITION 33 AND
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO OUR
VOICES. THANK YOU, MISS BRICENO.
ALL RIGHT, MISS GUTIERREZ,
VOEPEL. THANK YOU, CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, FOR HOLDING
THIS HEARING TODAY. MY NAME IS
MICHELLE GUTIERREZ. I'VE BEEN A
REGISTERED NURSE FOR ABOUT 26,
27 YEARS, AND I'M A PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION, WHICH REPRESENTS
OVER 100,000 NURSES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA FOR DECADES, OUR
UNION HAS PROUDLY SUPPORTED
MEASURES THAT WOULD ENSURE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR OUR
PATIENTS, INCLUDING ROBUST RENT
CONTROLS LAWS AND THE REPEAL OF
THE COSTA-HAWKINS RENTAL HOUSING
ACT. TODAY, I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE LINK BETWEEN HIGH RENTS,
HOUSING INSTABILITY AND POOR
HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. AS NURSES, WE SEE
HOW THE LACK OF QUALITY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND HOUSING
INSTABILITY CAN NEGATIVELY
IMPACT THE HEALTH OF WORKING
FAMILIES IN OUR COMMUNITIES. AND
AS SOMEBODY WHO HAS WORKED IN
ADULT PRIMARY CARE FOR ABOUT
2627 YEARS, I HAVE SEEN, I HAVE
SEEN ACROSS THE LIFESPAN HOW
DEVASTATING THESE EFFECTS ARE.
AND THE PRIORITY SHOULD REALLY
BE ON STABILIZING THE HEALTH AND
WELFARE OF CALIFORNIANS AND NOT
STABILIZING THE RENT. YOU SHOULD
SEE HOW WHEN WE LOOK IN OUR
PATIENT'S EYES AND THEIR
CHILDREN AND THEIR YOUNG ADULTS
AND THEIR MOTHERS AND FATHERS
AND THEIR GRANDPARENTS, THEY
CAN'T EVEN STAY HOME BECAUSE
THEY HAVE TO WORK TWO JOBS. IT
IS COMPLETELY DEVASTATING AS A
NURSE TO WITNESS THIS HAPPEN DAY
IN AND DAY OUT. AND OVER THE
2627 YEARS I'VE BEEN A NURSE,
IT'S JUST GOTTEN A LOT WORSE.
ABOUT 44% OF CALIFORNIA
HOUSEHOLDS ARE RENTERS, AND THE
AVERAGE RENTER SPENDS OVER HALF
THEIR INCOME ON RENT. ABOUT 1
MILLION RENTERS IN CALIFORNIA
ARE BEHIND ON RENT, AND ONCE
AGAIN, OUR PATIENTS TELL US OUR
PATIENTS TELL US THESE
DEVASTATING SITUATIONS, AND
THEY'RE ALWAYS ALMOST A PAYCHECK
AWAY FROM BEING UNHOUSED WITH
THEIR CHILDREN. BUT WHEN RENTS
INCREASE, OUR PATIENTS HEALTH
SUFFERS LARGER AND LARGER
PORTIONS OF PAYCHECKS ARE GOING
TOWARDS RENT, LEAVING LESS MONEY
FOR HEALTH CARE AS RENT RISES
UNCONTROLLABLY. FAMILIES CANNOT
AFFORD TO SEE THE DOCTOR WHEN
THEY ARE SICK OR GO TO THE
DENTIST FOR A TOOTH ACHE. THEY
ARE LESS LIKELY TO BE ABLE TO
MANAGE CHRONIC ILLNESSES OR GET
PREVENTIVE CARE WHEN RENTS ARE
TOO HIGH. PARENTS STRUGGLE TO
AFFORD NUTRITIOUS FOOD FOR THEIR
CHILDREN. THIS IS WHY NURSES
STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH WORKING
FAMILIES WHO ADVOCATE FOR RENT
STABILITY AND STRONGER LOCAL
RENT CONTROL LAWS, EXPANDING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AUTHORITY TO
ENACT RENT CONTROL MEASURES ON
ALL RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY IS AN
IMPORTANT PIECE IN THE PUZZLE TO
ENSURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
HAVE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
RENT CONTROL LAWS ARE POWERFUL
TOOLS THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENT CAN
USE TO STOP RENT GOUGING AND TO
STOP LANDLORDS FROM DISPLACING
LOW INCOME PEOPLE FROM THEIR
HOMES THROUGH RENT INCREASES. TO
STRENGTHEN RENT STABILITY AND
EVICTION PROTECTION LAWS. IN OUR
COMMUNITIES, CALIFORNIA MUST
REPEAL THE COSTA-HAWKINS AND ITS
LIMITS ON LOCAL RENT CONTROL
LAWS. FOR DECADES, LANDLORDS
HAVE USED COSTA-HAWKINS RENT
CONTROL EXEMPTIONS TO PRICE OUT
TENANTS AND TO CIRCUMVENT LOCAL
EVICTION PROTECTION LAWS.
INSTEAD OF EVICTING TENANTS,
LANDLORDS INCREASE RENT TO FORCE
LOW INCOME TENANTS. NURSES
SUPPORT THE REPEAL TO REPEAL
COSTA-HAWKINS AND SUPPORT
PROPOSITION 33. BECAUSE NO
FAMILY SHOULD HAVE TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN PAYING FOR HEALTH CARE
OR KEEPING A ROOF OVER THEIR
HEADS, I HAVE SEEN PATIENTS WHO
WON'T GO TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, EVEN IF
THEY'RE HAVING A HEART ATTACK OR
STROKE, BECAUSE THEY CANNOT
AFFORD TO PAY THEIR CO-PAY,
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO PAY THE
RENT. SO THEY'RE HAVING TO
CHOOSE TO BE HOUSED OR TO SAVE
THEIR LIFE. THAT'S
UNCONSCIONABLE. RENT INSTABILITY
HAS ITSELF BECOME A HEALTH
HAZARD FOR COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE. WHEN OUR PATIENTS
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT RENT
SKYROCKETING WITHOUT WARNING,
THEIR HEALTH SUFFERS YEAR AFTER
YEAR, WORKING FAMILIES STRESS
OVER WHETHER THEIR LANDLORD WILL
RAISE RENTS TO UNAFFORDABLE
LEVELS. UNAFFORDABLE HOUSING
MAKES WORKING FAMILIES SICKER IN
MULTIPLE WAYS. THE LINK BETWEEN
UNAFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
NEGATIVE HEALTH OUTCOMES
COMPOUNDS UPON ITSELF. THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH HAS TAKEN A NUMBER
OF SURVEYS THAT DEMONSTRATED THE
LINK BETWEEN HIGH RENTS AND
HOUSING INSTABILITY AND NEGATIVE
HEALTH OUTCOMES. THEY FOUND THAT
PEOPLE WHO HAVE TROUBLE PAYING
THEIR RENT REPORT HAVING
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE UNHEALTHY
DAYS, EITHER PHYSICALLY OR
MENTALLY, WHEN COMPARED TO THOSE
WHO DID NOT REPORT HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY PROBLEMS. OVER ONE
THIRD OF ADULTS IN LOS ANGELES
REPORTED THAT WHEN RENTS WERE
UNAFFORDABLE, THEY COULD NOT
AFFORD TO SEE A DOCTOR FOR A
HEALTH PROBLEM. AND WE KNOW THAT
LACK OF STABLE, QUALITY AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CAN
NEGATIVELY IMPACT OUR MENTAL
HEALTH. IT CAN LEAD TO OUR
PSYCHOLOGICAL STRESS AND
DEPRESSION FOR FAMILIES,
PARTICULARLY FOR OUR CHILDREN. A
2021 POLICY LINKED SURVEY OF
RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS
FOUND THAT 83% OF THEIR CLIENTS
REPORTED MENTAL HEALTH CONCERNS.
THIS, TOO, I SEE EVERY DAY TO
STOP THE NEGATIVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES FROM RENT AND HOUSING
STABILITY. OUR CITIES AND
COUNTIES NEED TO HAVE THE FULL
RANGE OF TOOLS AVAILABLE TO
STABILIZE RENT. RESEARCHERS AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CONDUCTED A
LITERATURE REVIEW ON RENT
REGULATION STUDIES IN 2018.
NEARLY EVERY ACADEMIC STUDY THEY
LOOKED AT FOUND THAT RENT
STABILIZATION INCREASES HOUSING
STABILITY FOR RESIDENTS IN RENT
CONTROLLED UNITS. THEY ALSO
FOUND THAT HOUSING STABILITY IS
ASSOCIATED WITH SOCIAL, MENTAL,
AND PHYSICAL HEALTH, AS WELL AS
BETTER EDUCATION OUTCOMES.
IMPORTANTLY, RENT CONTROL
REGULATION IS MORE LIKELY TO
BENEFIT LOWER INCOME PEOPLE AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR WHO ARE MORE
LIKELY TO HAVE HOUSING
INSTABILITY, FACE EVICTION, OR
FORCED TO RELOCATE DUE TO COST.
THE USC PAPER ALSO FINDS THAT,
ON BALANCE, RENT REGULATION DOES
NOT IMPACT NEW HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION. BUT IN CONTRAST,
THE AUTHORS REPORT THAT WHEN
RENT REGULATIONS ALLOW LANDLORDS
TO CONVERT HOUSING UNITS INTO
RENT CONTROL, EXEMPT UNITS,
THOSE UNITS ARE TAKEN OFF THE
RENTAL MARKET. THIS IS PRECISELY
WHAT COSTA-HAWKINS DOES. WHILE
NURSES SUPPORT PROTECTIONS FOR
TENANTS LIKE EVICTION
PROTECTIONS AS WELL AS OTHER
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROGRAMS,
RENT CONTROL REMAINS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL THAT WILL HELP
STABILIZE HOUSING FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA. FOR CNA
NURSES, RENT STABILIZATION AND
HOUSING STABILIZATION HELP
ENSURE THAT WE CAN BUILD HEALTHY
AND SOCIOECONOMICALLY DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES FOR GENERATIONS TO
COME. THIS IS WHY OUR UNION
SUPPORTS PROPOSITION 33 AND WHY
WE SUPPORT TO END ARBITRARY
LIMITS OF LOCAL RENT CONTROL
LAWS. WHY MUST LOCAL GOVERNMENT?
WHY MUST WE MUST GIVE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THE FLEXIBILITY TO
CRAFT RENT CONTROL TOOLS IN WAYS
THAT FIT THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. THIS WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT ALL OF OUR PATIENTS,
PARTICULARLY LOW INCOME FAMILIES
OF COLOR, ARE NOT PRICED OUT. I
HOPE YOU HEARD ME FOR ALL OF THE
SAKE OF ALL OF OUR PATIENTS.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
PRESIDENT. ALL RIGHT. NEXT, MISS
SUSIE SHANNON, DIRECTOR OF
HOUSING AS A HUMAN RIGHT FROM
AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION.
THANK YOU. HI. THANK YOU. I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR HAVING
THIS HEARING AND FOR INVITING ME
TO SPEAK. I'M SUSIE SHANNON, I'M
THE POLICY DIRECTOR FOR HOUSING
AS A HUMAN RIGHT. AND ALSO THE
CAMPAIGN MANAGER FOR PROPOSITION
33. PROPOSITION 33 IS ONLY 23
WORDS. IT'S VERY EASY TO
UNDERSTAND. IT SAYS THE STATE
MAY NOT LIMIT THE RIGHT OF ANY
CITY, COUNTY OR CITY AND COUNTY
TO MAINTAIN AN ACT OR EXPAND
RESIDENTIAL RENT CONTROL. IT
BASICALLY ALLOWS LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO EXPAND RENT
CONTROL AND REPEALS.
COSTA-HAWKINS COSTA-HAWKINS
PASSED IN 1995, AND THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
TRIED FOR YEARS TO GET SOMETHING
SIMILAR PASSED TO QUELL TENANT
ORGANIZING AROUND RENT CONTROL
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. THEY WERE
FINALLY SUCCESSFUL IN 1995. THEY
WON THE LEGISLATURE BY ONLY ONE
VOTE, AND COSTA-HAWKINS WAS
SIGNED INTO LAW BY A REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR BEFORE 1995 AND
COSTA-HAWKINS PASSAGE RENTS WERE
DOWN AND HOMELESSNESS WAS DOWN.
CONSTRUCTION WAS BOOMING IN THE
1980S AND EARLY 1990S. WE KNOW
WHAT CALIFORNIA LOOKS LIKE
WITHOUT COSTA-HAWKINS ON JANUARY
28TH, 1994, DEBORAH VRANA FROM
THE LA TIMES WROTE, DEVELOPERS
BUILDING UP MOMENTUM. IT'S NO
80S TYPE BOOM, BUT SIGNIFICANT
NUMBERS OF NEW HOMES AND RETAIL
CENTERS ARE IN THE WORKS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY. FOR 1994, ONE YEAR
LATER, COSTA-HAWKINS WAS PASSED
PROP 33 AND RENT CONTROL DOES
NOT HAVE AN IMPACT ON NEW
CONSTRUCTION. THIS IS
SUBSTANTIATED BY STUDY AFTER
STUDY THAT SHOWS RENT CONTROL
HAS NO IMPACT ON NEW
CONSTRUCTION. A USC STUDY FROM
2018 STATES, AND I QUOTE
EVIDENCE SUGGESTS THERE IS
LITTLE NEGATIVE IMPACT ON NEW
CONSTRUCTION, A BERKELEY STUDY
STATES CLAIMS THAT RENT CONTROL
HAS NEGATIVE EFFECTS ON
DEVELOPMENT OF NEW HOUSING, ARE
GENERALLY NOT SUPPORTED BY
RESEARCH, AND IN 2023, 32
ECONOMISTS FROM RUTGERS
UNIVERSITY, UC SANTA BARBARA,
MIT, THE UNIVERSITY OF
MASSACHUSETTS, COLUMBIA
UNIVERSITY, AND MANY MORE WROTE
A LETTER TO PRESIDENT BIDEN
ASKING HIM TO ENACT NATIONAL
RENT CONTROL, WHICH OF COURSE HE
SUPPORTS A 5% RENT CAP, ALONG
WITH VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA
HARRIS. BUT THEY WROTE IN THEIR
PAPER, THERE IS SUBSTANTIAL
EMPIRICAL EVIDENCE THAT RENT
REGULATION POLICIES DO NOT LIMIT
NEW CONSTRUCTION, NOR THE
OVERALL SUPPLY OF HOUSING. AND
THEN THE SALIENT POINT IN
ADDITION TO THAT, WHEN RENT
CONTROL WAS REPEALED IN
MASSACHUSETTS, THERE WAS NO
CORRESPONDING INCREASE IN
HOUSING SUPPLY. COSTA-HAWKINS,
HOWEVER, HAS BEEN USED BY
CORPORATE LANDLORDS TO STOP
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IN 2004,
AFTER THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
PASSED AN INCLUSIONARY ZONING
LAW REQUIRING A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE OF UNITS BE
AFFORDABLE, BILLIONAIRE JEFFREY
PALMER SUED THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES, SAYING THAT HIS UNITS
IN HIS 350 UNIT BUILDING DIDN'T
NEED TO BE AFFORDABLE BECAUSE OF
COSTA-HAWKINS. THE COURTS AGREED
WITH HIM. THE JUDGE WROTE,
FORCING PALMER TO PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS AT
REGULATED RENTS IN ORDER TO
OBTAIN PROJECT APPROVAL IS
CLEARLY HOSTILE TO THE RIGHT
AFFORDED UNDER THE COSTA-HAWKINS
ACT TO ESTABLISH THE INITIAL
RENTAL RATE FOR A DWELLING UNIT.
SO BETWEEN 2000 AND 9 AND THAT
COURT DECISION, UNTIL THE
LEGISLATURE WAS ABLE TO FIX THIS
WITH A LAW THAT WENT INTO EFFECT
IN JANUARY OF 2018, IT WAS
PASSED IN NOVEMBER 2017 FOR
EIGHT YEARS, WE COULDN'T GET
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN ANY OF OUR
NEW BUILDINGS. SO WHERE ARE WE
TODAY? IN CALIFORNIA, RENTS ARE
UP AND HOMELESSNESS IS UP. THERE
ARE MORE PEOPLE RENT BURDENED IN
CALIFORNIA THAN ANYWHERE IN THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY. THIS LEGISLATURE
REALLY NEEDS TO FOCUS ON THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE MORE PEOPLE
RENT BURDENED NOW ANYWHERE IN
THE UNITED STATES, OVER HALF OF
THE 17 MILLION RENTERS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE PAYING OVER 30%
OF THEIR INCOME IN RENT. WE CAN
TALK ABOUT STUDIES ALL DAY. IT
DOESN'T CHANGE THE FACT THAT THE
COST FOR A TWO BEDROOM
APARTMENT, AS OF SEPTEMBER 2024,
IN LOS ANGELES, IS $3,742 A
MONTH. NOW, CAN A SENIOR ON A
FIXED INCOME AFFORD THAT? NØ.
CAN YOUR STARBUCKS BARISTA
AFFORD THAT? NO. CAN OUR HOTEL
WORKERS AFFORD THAT? NO. CAN A
LOT OF PATIENTS AFFORD THAT? NO.
PEOPLE ARE ABANDONING PUBLIC
SCHOOLS TO GET AWAY BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T AFFORD THE RENT. I MY
DAUGHTER GOES TO A PUBLIC
SCHOOL. I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW
MANY FAMILIES HAVE LEFT FOR
OTHER STATES BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
AFFORD IT HERE, OR THEY KNOW
THAT THEIR CHILDREN WON'T BE
ABLE TO STAY HERE AND THEY MAY
NEVER SEE THEIR GRANDCHILDREN
BECAUSE THEY WON'T BE ABLE TO
STAY HERE. THIS IS SEPARATING
FAMILIES. IN ADDITION, A ZILLOW
STUDY SHOWED THAT FOR EVERY 5%
INCREASE IN IN RENT, 2000 MORE
PEOPLE BECOME HOMELESS. WE HAVE
MORE PEOPLE HOMELESS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA NOW THAN
ANYWHERE IN THE COUNTRY. IT JUST
WENT UP AGAIN A COUPLE OF MONTHS
AGO TO 186,000 PEOPLE. NOW WHO
ARE HOMELESS. I HAVE WORKED WITH
OUR UNHOUSED COMMUNITY SINCE
2005. I HAVE NEVER, EVER GOTTEN
ANYONE FROM THE STREETS OR
SOMEONE LIVING IN A CAR, OR
SOMEONE COUCH SURFING WITH THEIR
FAMILY INTO A MARKET RATE UNIT,
AND I GUARANTEE YOU THAT THEY'RE
NOT GETTING INTO A $3,700 A
MONTH, TWO BEDROOM APARTMENT. SO
SOMETHING'S GOT TO GIVE HERE.
COSTA-HAWKINS IS AN EXPERIMENT
FOR CALIFORNIA THAT HAS FAILED.
PEOPLE HAVE SAID TIME AND TIME
AGAIN, AND I KNOW THAT ALL OF
YOU HAVE HEARD FROM YOUR
CONSTITUENTS. THEY CANNOT AFFORD
TO LIVE HERE ANYMORE. OUR
CORPORATE LANDLORDS HAVE HAD
THEIR WAY WITH CALIFORNIA FOR A
VERY LONG TIME. THE GOVERNMENT
NEEDS TO FIX THIS. THE PEOPLE
NEED TO FIX THIS. CORPORATE
LANDLORDS ARE DOING THEIR JOB IN
AMASSING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
PROFIT. REALLY TRILLIONS? I
DON'T EVEN SAY THAT BECAUSE
PEOPLE DON'T BELIEVE IT. SO I
JUST SAY BILLIONS. AND THEY'RE
NOW USING THAT TO CONFUSE
RENTERS AND TO SAY THAT RENT
CONTROL SOMEHOW ISN'T IN THEIR
INTEREST. MY FAMILY WHEN I WAS
YOUNGER WAS UNHOUSED. WE GOT
INTO A RENT CONTROLLED APARTMENT
THAT HELPED MY FAMILY. WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS AND OUR COUNTY
SUPERVISORS HAVE THE RIGHT. THE
ABILITY, ANOTHER TOOL IN THEIR
TOOLBOX, WHATEVER WE WANT TO
CALL IT, TO HELP THEIR
CONSTITUENTS. I'M JUST PLEADING
WITH YOU TO PLEASE, YOU KNOW,
SUPPORT PROPOSITION 33. IT WILL
BE ON YOUR NOVEMBER BALLOT AS
INDIVIDUALS AND TO PLEASE DO
SOMETHING IN THE LEGISLATURE.
I'M HOPING THAT THIS PASSES FOR
THE SAKE OF MY DAUGHTER AND THE
NEXT GENERATION. YOU KNOW,
THERE'S LIKE A GEN Z FOR PROP 33
GROUP NOW BECAUSE THEY'RE
LOOKING AT WHERE THEY CAN WORK.
MY DAUGHTER IS GOING TO BE GOING
OFF TO COLLEGE IN A YEAR AND A
HALF. AND YOU KNOW WHAT SHE'S
LOOKING AT, WHAT SHE'S GOING TO
HAVE TO PAY IN RENT IF SHE GOES
TO UC SANTA CRUZ, IF SHE GOES
SOMEWHERE, YOU KNOW, ANYWHERE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR COLLEGE, WE
SHOULD NOT BE PUTTING THIS
BURDEN ON THE NEXT GENERATION.
SO I WILL LEAVE IT AT THAT. I
WILL TELL YOU, TOO, THAT THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY
SUPPORTS THIS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFIT HOUSING THAT
REPRESENTS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BUILDERS. ALMOST EVERY TENANT
GROUP UP AND DOWN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. YOU'VE HEARD FROM
TENANTS TOGETHER HOUSING NOW,
ACE BURBANK, TENANTS UNION, SAN
FRANCISCO TENANTS UNION, ALL
PLEADING WITH YOU GUYS TO PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS AND LET'S HAVE A
CALIFORNIA THAT ACTUALLY CARES
ABOUT ITS RENTERS. I'M ALSO THE
COUNTIES OF L.A. COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO HAS ENDORSED THIS.
CONGRESSWOMAN MAXINE WATERS, WHO
USED TO BE THE HEAD OF THE
FINANCIAL SERVICES COMMITTEE,
JIMMY GÓMEZ, WHO STARTED THE
CONGRESSIONAL RENTERS CAUCUS,
SUPPORTS THIS MANY, MANY OF YOUR
LEGISLATORS SUPPORT THIS. YOU
KNOW, PRESIDENT BIDEN AND KAMALA
HARRIS CAME OUT FOR A 5%
NATIONAL CAP ON RENT BECAUSE
THEY SEE THAT THIS IS A NATIONAL
ISSUE NOW THAT PEOPLE CAN'T
AFFORD TO LIVE ANY LONGER IN
THESE APARTMENTS. AND THEN ONCE
YOU EVEN GET INTO AN APARTMENT
TO LOOK AT THESE LIKE EXORBITANT
RENT INCREASES, AND THEN NOT TO
BE ABLE TO APPEAL TO YOUR LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIAL, I THINK IS
UNCONSCIONABLE. SO I COULD GO ON
AND ON, BUT I'LL JUST LEAVE IT
THERE. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU SHANNON. APPRECIATE
IT. QUESTIONS BY PANEL MEMBERS.
SENATOR RUSSELL. YES. GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. THANK YOU
FOR ALL OF YOU FOR THE WORK THAT
YOU DO EVERY DAY. IN ADDITION,
FOR BEING HERE AND SPEAKING TO
US, I HAVE A I LIVE IN A
COMMUNITY CALLED EL SERENO, AND
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF STATE OWNED
PROPERTIES THAT WE'RE FINALLY
ABLE TO GET, YOU KNOW, HOUSING
TO BE BUILT OR REHABILITATED FOR
AT AN AFFORDABLE RATE, THAT THE
CONDITION THAT IT HAS TO BE
AFFORDABLE. SO HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY PARTNERED UP WITH THE
STATE. THEY GOT 13 PROPERTIES
AND THEY'RE FIXING THEM UP AND
OPEN THE WAITLIST FOR A LOTTERY.
AND 650 PEOPLE PUT THEIR NAMES
IN ON THAT LIST. SO I'M SURE WE
ALL HAVE EVERYBODY IN THE ROOM
HAS EXAMPLES OF THE NEED FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN ADDITION
TO MARKET RATE. I DON'T I
WOULDN'T I DO NOT OPPOSE MARKET
RATE. BUT I THINK THE EMPHASIS
HAS TO BE ON AFFORDABLE. SO LET
ME ASK YOU THIS. THE IF YOU HAVE
SPECIFIC INFORMATION OR
EXAMPLES, BUT ESPECIALLY
SPECIFIC INFORMATION ON THE
OPPOSITION ARGUMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE, YOU CAN PICK THE ONES
THAT YOU WANT, THAT YOU THINK
ARE THE MOST IMPORTANT ONES TO
COUNTER HERE. BUT WHAT WOULD
WHAT WOULD YOUR RESPONSE BE TO
THE TWO MOST IMPORTANT ARGUMENTS
BEING MADE BY THE OPPOSITION,
SENATOR RUSSELL, IS THAT ARE YOU
ADDRESSING IT TO ONE OF THE
PANEL OR EACH OF THE PANEL
MEMBERS, OR WHY DON'T I LIMIT IT
TO TWO PEOPLE IN RESPONSE FROM
THE PANEL? SO WHICHEVER TWO WISH
TO SPEAK UP FIRST? OKAY, SO
THERE ARE, I THINK, TWO MAIN
CLAIMS. ONE IS THAT IT WILL
IMPEDE NEW CONSTRUCTION, WHICH I
ADDRESS IN MY TESTIMONY, BECAUSE
WHEN YOU HAVE UC BERKELEY AND UC
STUDY AND THEN 32 RECOGNIZED
ECONOMISTS FROM ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES ALL SAYING THERE'S
A SUBSTANTIAL EMPIRICAL EVIDENCE
THAT RENT REGULATION POLICIES DO
NOT LIMIT NEW CONSTRUCTION OR
THE OVERALL SUPPLY OF HOUSING,
AND THAT WHEN RENT CONTROL WAS
REPEALED IN MASSACHUSETTS, THERE
WAS NO CORRESPONDING INCREASE IN
HOUSING SUPPLY. WHAT THAT TELLS
YOU IS THERE IS NO CONSENSUS
AMONG ECONOMISTS THAT RENT
CONTROL IMPACTS NEW HOUSING. BY
THE WAY, WE HAVE HAD RENT
CONTROL SINCE 1919, IN THIS
COUNTRY. ARE WE REALLY SAYING
THAT THAT'S IMPEDED CONSTRUCTION
IN OUR COUNTRY SINCE 1919? I
MEAN, IT'S I MEAN, FOR ME IT'S
LUDICROUS. BUT I'VE BEEN
FOLLOWING THESE ISSUES. THE
SECOND IS THAT IT HURTS RENTERS
AND IT OBVIOUSLY DOESN'T TENANT
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS, YOU KNOW,
THEIR ENTIRE MISSION IS ABOUT
HELPING TENANTS. AND THEY'RE
SUPPORTING PROP 33. OUR
CONGRESSIONAL REPRESENTATIVES
WHO SUPPORT TENANTS ARE
SUPPORTING PROP 33. OUR STATE
LEGISLATORS WHO ARE SUPPORTING
TENANTS ARE ALSO SUPPORTING PROP
33. WE KNOW THAT RENT CONTROL
ACTUALLY HELPS TENANTS, WHICH IS
WHY TENANT ADVOCATES AND THE
ELECTED OFFICIALS THAT SUPPORT
TENANTS ARE SUPPORTING
PROPOSITION 33. I, I CAN'T
IMAGINE HOW CORPORATE LANDLORDS
WHO ARE AMASSING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OFF OF RENT AND ARE
BASICALLY DOING THEIR JOB, WHICH
IS TO GET AS MUCH PROFIT AS THEY
CAN, CAN SPEAK FOR WHAT'S RIGHT
FOR TENANTS. THE VERY TENANTS
THAT THEY'RE PRICE GOUGING, THE
VERY TENANTS THAT THEY'RE PRICE
FIXING WITH, YOU KNOW, REALPAGE
IS A PLATFORM WHERE LANDLORDS
ARE PRICE FIXING. THEY HAVE BEEN
CALLED OUT EVEN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HAS GONE IN AND
RAIDED HEADQUARTERS OF CORPORATE
LANDLORDS BECAUSE OF REALPAGE.
I'M NOT SURE EXACTLY WHAT THIS
HAS TO DO WITH THE BENEFITS OR
THE DETRIMENTS OF COST TO
HAWKINS. WELL, WELL, SHE ASKED
ME ABOUT THE TWO MAIN ARGUMENTS,
AND SO NUMBER ONE, IT DOESN'T
HURT RENTERS. NUMBER ONE, IT
DOESN'T AFFECT NEW DEVELOPMENT.
IT ACTUALLY HELPS RENTERS, WHICH
IS WHY WE'RE ALL SUPPORTING IT.
OKAY. THANK YOU. DID ANYONE ELSE
WANT TO GO OR DID YOU WANT TO.
YEAH. I'LL BE I'LL BE QUICK TO
SPECIFIC. I MEAN IF IT'S KIND OF
SIMILAR BUT A LITTLE BIT A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT TO WHAT
SUZY SAID. BUT YEAH, IN TERMS OF
THE SUPPLY ARGUMENT, I MEAN, I'M,
I'M SOMETIMES DOUBLY, DOUBLY
AFFECTED BY THIS ARGUMENT AS A
RENT CONTROL TENANT AND SOMEONE
WITH AN ECONOMICS DEGREE WHERE
LIKE, THERE'S SORT OF A
MISREPRESENTATION OF WHAT THE
RESEARCH ACTUALLY SAYS. RIGHT?
AND PARTICULARLY LIKE I ALREADY
TOUCHED ON THIS IN MY TESTIMONY,
SO I'LL KEEP IT QUICK. BUT JUST
WANT TO REEMPHASIZE YOU KNOW,
THE IDEA THAT, FOR EXAMPLE, IF I
AS A RENT CONTROL TENANT, AM
HARASSED OUT OF MY HOME, WHICH I
HAVE, WE WORK WITH TENANTS IN
RENT CONTROLLED HOUSING WHO HAVE
BEEN HARASSED OUT OF THEIR HOMES
IN ORDER TO RESET RENTS TO
MARKET OR CONVERT TO CONDOS. IF
I, YOU KNOW, IF I IF A
SPECULATOR WEAPONIZES THE ELLIS
ACT, WHICH WAS MEANT TO EXIT THE
MARKET. RIGHT. BUT HAS ACTUALLY
BEEN USED FOR PURPOSES WELL
BEYOND THAT, RIGHT. IF I AM
KICKED OUT OF MY HOME BECAUSE OF
THAT, THEN THAT THAT IS WHAT
PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT WHEN
THEY'RE SAYING THERE'S A SUPPLY
REDUCTION, BUT THERE ISN'T
ACTUALLY A REDUCTION IN THE
ACTUAL SUPPLY OF HOUSING. IF MY
HOME HAS BEEN CONVERTED INTO A
CONDO AND I HAVE NOWHERE TO GO,
RIGHT, THAT'S WHAT WHEN YOU HEAR
ALL OF THESE CRITIQUES, IF YOU
READ THE PAPERS, EVEN THE PAPERS
THAT SEEM CRITICAL OF RENT
CONTROL IN SOME WAY, THAT'S
ACTUALLY WHAT THEY'RE
DESCRIBING. THEY'RE DESCRIBING
THE LOOPHOLES AROUND IT. THEY
ARE NOT DESCRIBING THE BENEFITS
OF THE POLICY ITSELF. AND TO USE
THAT AS AN ARGUMENT, I THINK, TO
NOT CONFER THAT BENEFIT TO MORE
PEOPLE, ESPECIALLY WHEN WE HAVE
PLENTY OF PROOF IN CALIFORNIA
THAT RENT CONTROL HOUSING
REMAINS A VERY PROFITABLE AND
LUCRATIVE INVESTMENT, I THINK IS
REALLY DISINGENUOUS. SO OKAY.
THAT'S THAT. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. OTHER QUESTIONS. WHOOPS.
SENATOR BARRASSO, THANK YOU.
JUST ONE MORE. NOT EXACTLY SURE.
THE QUESTION I'M ASKING, BUT I
READ THIS MORNING IN THE L.A.
TIMES ABOUT DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST MORE THAN 200 CALIFORNIA
LANDLORDS AND THEIR
REPRESENTATIVES ON SECTION
EIGHT. DISCRIMINATION IS THERE
ANY IMPACT BETWEEN THE
AVAILABILITY OF SECTION EIGHT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING, YOU KNOW,
WHICH MAKES IT AFFORDABLE WITH
THIS RENT CONTROL? IT'S KIND OF
A BROAD QUESTION. IF THERE'S NO
ANSWER, THEN I'M FINE. BUT IT
JUST SORT OF STRUCK ME. IT HAS
TO DO WITH HOUSING. IT HAS TO DO
WITH POOR PEOPLE. IT HAS TO DO
WITH AVAILABLE, AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. IS THERE ANY CONNECTION
HERE? YEAH, I MEAN, THERE'S
DIFFERENT TYPES OF SECTION
EIGHT, BUT I'LL RESPOND
REGARDING PEOPLE WHO HAVE
VOUCHERS. SO IF YOU HAVE A
VOUCHER, THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WILL GIVE YOU A MAXIMUM AMOUNT
THAT YOU CAN PAY FOR RENT. AND
SO AS THESE RENTS GO UP, IF YOU
CAN'T GET A WAIVER, EVEN AS AN
INDIVIDUAL TENANT FROM THE
HOUSING AUTHORITY, THIS DOES
IMPACT WHERE YOU CAN GO TO GET
HOUSING. SO IT ABSOLUTELY DOES
AFFECT THIS. AS RENTS GO UP,
THERE'S ONLY GOING TO BE A
MAXIMUM AMOUNT THAT THAT VOUCHER
IS GOING TO PAY FOR. EVEN THOUGH
THE TENANT PAYS 30% OF THEIR
INCOME, THEY STILL HAVE TO STAY
WITHIN THE MAXIMUM RATE THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT GIVES TO
THEM. AND SO HOUSING AUTHORITIES
HAVE HAD TO SCRAMBLE IT ALSO. IT
ALSO LOWERS THE NUMBER OF
VOUCHERS THAT CAN BE GIVEN,
BECAUSE IF YOU GET THOSE
WAIVERS, THOSE VOUCHERS ARE
STILL ONLY WORTH SO MUCH. AND SO
YOU'RE GETTING THESE WAIVERS
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
INCREASE THAT AMOUNT. BUT IT'S
NOT LIKE THERE'S LIKE A BIGGER
POT IN THE FEDERAL BUDGET FOR
THAT. AND SO YEAH, SO I MEAN,
YOU KNOW, THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT YOU'VE HEARD OF WHO
ARE WHO HAVE SECTION EIGHT
VOUCHERS THAT CAN'T FIND A
LANDLORD TO TAKE THEM. AND PART
OF IT IS THAT THE LANDLORD MAY
NOT WANT TO TAKE LESS MONEY BY,
YOU KNOW, HAVING A SECTION EIGHT
TENANT COME IN, YOU KNOW, AND I
THINK THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
DEFINITELY UNDER THE
BIDEN-HARRIS ADMINISTRATION, HAS
DONE A GOOD JOB IN TERMS OF
MAKING SURE THAT THERE ARE
WAIVERS AND MAKING SURE THAT,
YOU KNOW, THEY THEY INCREASE
THAT. BUT IT'S COSTING TAXPAYERS
A LOT OF MONEY TO HAVE THESE
RENT INCREASES, BECAUSE A LOT OF
MONEY IS GOING TO SECTION EIGHT
VOUCHERS. YEAH, VERY, VERY, VERY
QUICKLY. I'LL JUST ADD TO THAT.
WHILE I BELIEVE IT'S SB 329
PASSED A FEW YEARS AGO, IT'S
NOMINALLY SECTION EIGHT
DISCRIMINATION IS NOMINALLY
BANNED THANKS TO THE WORK OF THE
STATE SENATE. BUT BUT WE'RE
STILL FINDING THAT ON THE GROUND
VERY DIFFICULT TO ENFORCE. SO
THERE ARE, IN FACT IMPACTS
RELATED TO THAT, TO THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, SENATOR
RUSSELL. SENATOR ROSS, YOU KNOW,
I THINK WE ALL WOULD AGREE THAT
THE RENTAL SITUATION, RENTAL
HOUSING SITUATION, WORKER
HOUSING IS AT A CRITICAL POINT
IN THE STATE FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS AS A STATE. AND ALL THIS
IS A BALANCING OF STATE POLICY.
AS A STATE. WE INCENTIVIZE
BUSINESS GROWTH AND EXPANSION IN
THE URBAN COASTAL AREAS OF THE
STATE WITHOUT REQUIRING THOSE
JURISDICTIONS TO CERTIFY THAT
THEY HAVE EITHER HAVE, OR WILL
BUILD WORKER HOUSING AND MAKE
WORKER HOUSING AVAILABLE TO THE
WORKERS THERE, WHICH THEN PUSHES
THE HOUSING SITUATION OUT TO THE
MORE AFFORDABLE AREAS, WHICH
DRIVES OUR HOUSING POLICY
THROUGH THE RENA ALLOCATION AND
SCAG AND WHATEVER ELSE IT'S
CALLED UP HERE, WHERE
JURISDICTIONS IN THE INLAND
PORTIONS OF THE STATE ARE
REQUIRED TO PLAN FOR ADDITIONAL
HOUSING. AND AS WE'VE RECENTLY
SEEN WITH THIS, GOVERNOR AND THE
ADMINISTRATION, SOME
JURISDICTIONS ARE SPANKED WHEN
THEY DON'T PLAN APPROPRIATELY OR
ANNOUNCE THE FACT THAT THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO PLAN APPROPRIATELY
FOR WORKER HOUSING. SO IT'S A
CRITICAL IT'S AT A CRITICAL
STATE. AND AREAS OF THE STATE
THAT WERE ONCE KNOWN AS THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CAPITALS OF
OUR STATE ARE NO LONGER SO
AFFORDABLE. SO WE'RE GOING TO
NEED TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT THAT.
SO THAT'S THE STATE POLICY. BUT
WE'RE ALSO SORT OF SETTING A
STATE POLICY HERE WITH WITH THIS
PROPOSITION, NOT THAT WE'VE
PASSED IT, BUT THAT THE VOTERS
MAY. AND MY CONCERN, OR AT LEAST
MY INQUIRY, BECAUSE I'M CURIOUS
AS TO THE IMPACT ON NEW
CONSTRUCTION. AND I KNOW YOU'VE
SAID IT HAS NO IMPACT. SO WITH
REGARD TO THOSE STUDIES WHERE
THE STUDIES OF STATES WHERE RENT
CONTROL APPLIED TO NEW
CONSTRUCTION AND THERE WAS NO
VACANCY DECONTROL. SO THESE
STUDIES FROM USC AND UC BERKELEY
WERE CONDUCTED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. WHERE THERE WERE
JURISDICTIONS, LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THAT APPLIED RENT
CONTROL FROM TOP TO BOTTOM, SOUP
TO NUTS, NEW CONSTRUCTION,
EXISTING RENTALS, NO VACANCY
DECONTROL YOU COULD. YOU WERE
RESTRICTED WHEN YOU HAD A
VACANCY, YOU WERE RESTRICTED
FROM THE FIRST DAY YOU OPENED
FOR BUSINESS AS AN APARTMENT
COMPLEX. I THINK THEY TOOK INTO
ACCOUNT ALL OF CALIFORNIA AND
NOT JUST WELL, I MEAN, I'M JUST
CURIOUS. YOU CITED THE STUDIES.
SO WERE THE STUDIES OF LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WHERE THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION, WHETHER IT WAS A
COUNTYWIDE OR WITHIN THE BOUNDS
OF A CITY, HAD IMPOSED RENT
CONTROL ON THE NEW CONSTRUCTION.
THE FIRST DAY YOU OPEN FOR
BUSINESSES, AN APARTMENT COMPLEX
AND EXISTING APARTMENT COMPLEXES
WHERE VACANCIES EXISTED. BUT
RENT CONTROL APPLIED AT THAT
POINT AS WELL. YEAH. SO I DID
KIND OF ADDRESS THAT JUST A
LITTLE BIT IN MY TESTIMONY THAT
IN THE 1980S CONSTRUCTION. OKAY.
SO LOS ANGELES PASSED RENT
CONTROL IN 1978. SO YOU NEED TO
LIVE IN A BUILDING THAT WAS
BUILT IN 1978 OR EARLIER IN
ORDER TO BE UNDER RENT CONTROL,
BUT THE 1980S WERE BOOMING IN
CONSTRUCTION. IT WAS IT WAS A
CONSTRUCTION BOOM ALL THROUGH
THE 1980S. THERE WAS NO
COSTA-HAWKINS. THERE WAS NO
RESTRICTION ON THE CITY COUNCIL
OF LOS ANGELES OR THE COUNTY
SUPERVISORS AND WE SAW BOOMING
CONSTRUCTION, BUT THERE WAS NO
RENT CONTROL ALL THE WAY UP TO
94. THERE WAS THERE WAS NO
CONTROL THERE, BUT RENT CONTROL
APPLIED TO 1978. AND BEFORE
RIGHT? YEAH. SO THERE WAS NO
RENT CONTROL. BUT IN 1978, GOING
FORWARD, DURING THE TIME THAT
CONSTRUCTION BOOMED, I MEAN, MY
QUESTION GOES TO, YOU KNOW, MOST
BUSINESSES NEED RETURN ON
INVESTMENT. AND SO THAT'S MY
QUESTION. AND IF THEY CAN FIGURE
IT OUT AND WE CAN PUT RENT
CONTROL ON FROM THE FIRST DAY,
THE APARTMENT COMPLEX OPENS,
THAT'S FINE WITH ME. IF IT WORKS
WELL, LET ME GET TO HOW IT
WORKS. SO HOW WOULD A DEVELOPER?
BECAUSE WE'RE FORCING CITIES TO
PLAN, AND WE'RE REALLY SORT OF
FORCING CITIES TO FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO PRESSURE DEVELOPERS TO
BUILD MORE HOUSING. BECAUSE I
DON'T CARE WHETHER YOU LIVE IN
RIVERSIDE, WHERE I, RIVERSIDE
COUNTY, WHERE I COME FROM, OR
URBAN COASTAL AREAS, EVERYBODY
NEEDS MORE HOUSING. AND THE
MARKET RATE STUFF THAT'S BEING
PUT UP TODAY IS $2,600, $3,200
FOR RELATIVELY SMALL APARTMENTS.
YOU NEED SOMETHING LESS. SO HOW
WOULD THIS PROPOSITION IN ITS
APPLICATION WORK FOR NEW
CONSTRUCTION? AND I'M A
DEVELOPER COMING IN WITH A
PROJECT WILL I KNOW. WELL, WHAT
MY RENTAL RATES ARE GOING TO BE.
SO I CAN FIGURE OUT IF THE LINES
CROSS AND I'M GOING TO BE ABLE
TO SERVICE THE DEBT THAT I'VE
TAKEN OUT OR HOWEVER ELSE I'M
FUNDING THE PROJECT. IN A WAY
YOU WILL, BECAUSE THE STATE
CONSTITUTION PROVIDES A FAIR
RATE OF RETURN ON RENTAL
PROPERTY FOR EVERY LANDLORD, BUT
THAT'S YES. AND THIS DOES NOT
SUPERSEDE THAT IN ANY WAY. AND
IT HASN'T IN ANY RENT CONTROLLED
CITY. BUT FAIR RATE RETURN, FAIR
RATE OF RETURN IS IN THE EYE OF
THE BEHOLDER, RIGHT? NO, I
BELIEVE THAT THERE'S ACTUALLY A
FORMULA WHICH, YOU KNOW, I'M NOT
ANY I DON'T WORK FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA, SO I CAN'T TELL
YOU WHAT THAT FORMULA IS. BUT
THERE IS A FAIR RATE OF RETURN
FOR EVERY LANDLORD. YES. SO IN
OTHER WORDS, A MUNICIPALITY
COULDN'T SAY THAT FOR NEW
CONSTRUCTION, RENTS COULD BE SET
AT $30. THAT WOULD BE AGAINST
THE LAW. SO IT HAS TO BE A FAIR
RATE OF RETURN. I ALSO, I THINK,
IS THERE A IS I MEAN I KNOW
THAT'S TRUE IN MOBILE AND
MANUFACTURED HOMES. IS THERE
SOME COMMISSION OR BOARD THAT
YOU GO TO AS A DEVELOPER IN
ADVANCE AS YOU'RE MOVING YOUR
PROJECT THROUGH THE PERMITTING
AND ENTITLEMENT PROCEDURE THAT
CAN YOU CAN DETERMINE IN ADVANCE
WHAT YOUR RENTAL RATE IS GOING
TO BE UNDER IN A PARTICULAR
JURISDICTION THAT ADOPTS THE
PROP 33 ARCHITECTURE. YEAH. SO
DIFFERENT CITIES OBVIOUSLY WOULD
HAVE DIFFERENT EITHER BOARD OR
COMMISSION THAT YOU COULD GO TO,
OR YOU COULD APPEAL TO THE CITY
COUNCIL. AND SO LANDLORDS ARE
DOING THIS NOW. LANDLORDS ARE
APPEALING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND THEY'RE NOT DOING IT ON NEW
CONSTRUCTION BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
APPLY TO NEW CONSTRUCTION. YET.
RIGHT. BUT BUT LANDLORDS WHO
HAVE RENT CONTROLLED BUILDINGS,
RIGHT, I UNDERSTAND CAN APPEAL.
YEAH. AND THAT WOULD BE THE CASE
IF RENT CONTROL WERE EXTENDED TO
MORE BUILDINGS. YOU KNOW, PAST
LIKE IN LÀ PAST 1978 AND PAST
1995 FOR OTHER CITIES THAT
ADOPTED IT AFTER 1995. AND THEN
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT YOU BROUGHT UP ARENA GOALS
BECAUSE THIS HAS NO IMPACT ON
THAT. EVERY CITY HAS ARENA
GOALS, AND THEY SHOULD BE
MEETING THOSE. NO, NO, NO, I
UNDERSTAND THAT THOSE ARE
PLANNING GOALS. WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS ACTUAL
CONSTRUCTION, RIGHT OF APARTMENT
AND MOSTLY APARTMENTS LESS THAN
SINGLE FAMILY. AND WHETHER THIS
PROPOSITION, WHETHER WE GUESS
WRONG AND IF WE GUESS WRONG ON
WHETHER IT IMPACTS THE
CONSTRUCTION OF NEW APARTMENT
BUILDINGS OR NOT, WHAT WE DO
ABOUT IT, BUT WE'RE NOT
GUESSING. WRONG. I WOULD SAY
THAT RIGHT NOW WE'RE GOING IN
THE WRONG DIRECTION. SO WE HAVE
RHNA GOALS FOR THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES, AND DEVELOPERS HAVE
OVERBUILT 72,000 UNITS IN THE
LAST SEVEN YEARS FROM OUR LAST
HOUSING ELEMENT STUDY. THE
PREVIOUS SEVEN YEARS, THEY
OVERBUILT 72,000 UNITS ABOVE THE
RENA GOAL IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES. BUT THEY UNDERBUILT FOR
MODERATE, LOW AND VERY LOW
INCOME UNITS BY 30, ALMOST
35,000 UNITS IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES. SO RIGHT NOW THE MARKET
IS NOT WORKING FOR VERY LOW, LOW
AND MODERATE INCOME FOLKS. AND
THAT'S WHY PEOPLE ARE, YOU KNOW,
LIVING FARTHER AWAY FROM WHERE
THEY WORK OR HAVING TO LEAVE
CALIFORNIA AND NOT BEING ABLE TO
AFFORD IT. BUT THIS DOESN'T
ADDRESS SOMETHING THAT WORKS
FOR. BUT WE NEED SOMETHING THAT
WORKS FOR THE WHOLE COMMUNITY.
AND THIS IS WHY FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING, BECAUSE I'M A BIG
ADVOCATE FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF NONPROFIT HOUSING
THAT REPRESENTS THOSE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BUILDERS IS SUPPORTING
PROPOSITION 30. BUT I MEAN, PROP
33 DOESN'T ADDRESS THE SITUATION
YOU'VE JUST SPOKEN TO, WHERE LOW
TO MODERATE IS BEING UNDERBUILT.
THERE'S BECAUSE THERE'S NO RENT
CONTROL RIGHT NOW. AND SO IT
ADDRESSES AFFORDABILITY AND
TENANTS BEING ABLE TO LIVE IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND NOT BE
FORCED OUT THROUGH
GENTRIFICATION AND HIGH RENTS.
THAT'S RIGHT. WELL, I MEAN, I
WANT IT TO BE CLEAR. I LISTEN,
WE'VE GOT TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THE COST OF HOUSING AND
PARTICULARLY THE COST OF RENTAL
HOUSING IN THE STATE. I JUST AM
WONDERING, I'M QUESTIONING THE
STUDIES AND WHAT WAS ACTUALLY
CONSIDERED IN THE STUDIES. WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT APPLYING RENT
CONTROL TO NEW CONSTRUCTION AND
EXACTLY HOW THAT WORKS AND HOW
WE AND WE INCENTIVIZE AS OPPOSED
TO DISINCENTIVIZE DEVELOPERS TO
PUT MONEY AT RISK AND BUILD
APARTMENT COMPLEXES, AND HOW
THOSE INITIAL RENTS ARE SET, WE
CAN PROBABLY FIGURE OUT HOW TO
DO DEAL WITH VACANCY DECONTROL
AND HOW YOU RECOVER INCREASES IN
OPERATING EXPENSES SUCH AS
INSURANCE AND UTILITIES, AND
THAT ARE NOT BUILT AND ALL THE
REST. BUT THE INITIAL COST
ELEMENT OF NEW CONSTRUCTION IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK WE
PROBABLY NEED A CLOSER LOOK. I
DON'T WANT TO MONOPOLIZE, AND I
WOULD SAY IF I COULD, THE
INVERSE IS TRUE, THAT
COSTA-HAWKINS HAS DONE NOTHING
TO INCREASE THE SUPPLY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING, WHICH IS WHY
WE DON'T HAVE IT NOW. WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH. WELL, I SHOULD HAVE
SAID, OBVIOUSLY THERE'S SOME
THINGS IN COSTA-HAWKINS.
CLEARLY, THE 1995 THRESHOLD THAT
NEED TO BE UPDATED AND SHOULD
HAVE BEEN UPDATED, BUT WE'LL SEE
HOW THIS ALL WORKS OUT. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU, SENATOR ROTH. OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS, SENATOR?
SENATOR WAHAB, THANK YOU.
APOLOGIES. I WAS ON ANOTHER
COMMITTEE HEARING. SO I KNOW
THAT THE LÀ SPOKE, BUT I JUST
KIND OF WANT TO GO OVER THIS IN
THEIR REPORT. YOU KNOW, THEY
THEY HAVE FISCAL EFFECTS STATING
SOME RENTERS WHO LIVE IN
PROPERTIES COVERED BY RENT
CONTROL WOULD SPEND LESS ON
RENT. SOME WHO LIVE IN
PROPERTIES NOT COVERED BY RENT
CONTROL WOULD SPEND MORE ON
RENT. SOME RENTERS WOULD MOVE
LESS OFTEN, FEWER HOMES WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO RENT. ONE REASON
FOR THIS WOULD BE LANDLORDS
WOULD SELL THEIR PROPERTIES TO
NEW OWNERS WHO LIVE THERE,
INSTEAD OF RENTING IT OUT. YOU
KNOW, ALL OF THE REASONS THAT
WE'RE GIVEN, ESPECIALLY EVEN IN
THE FIRST PARAGRAPH, I DO WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT THAT IT BASICALLY
ECHOES THE CONCEPT OF HOUSING
STABILITY WHEN PEOPLE MOVE LESS
AND LESS. AND I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THIS BECAUSE I THINK A
LOT OF PEOPLE TALK ABOUT RENT
CONTROL AND RENT ISSUES IN A WAY
THAT'S JUST ABOUT MONEY. AND THE
REALITY IS THAT WHEN FAMILIES
MOVE FROM HOME TO HOME TO HOME
TO HOME EVERY SINGLE YEAR,
TRYING TO FIND THE CHEAPEST
RENTAL SPOT THAT THEY CAN TO
STILL BE CLOSE TO WORK OR SO
FORTH, THEY MAY MOVE ONE CITY
OVER TWO CITIES, OVER THREE
CITIES OVER IN THE BAY AREA, FOR
EXAMPLE, WHERE I COME FROM. AND
THE HONEST TRUTH IS THAT IT
CREATES INSTABILITY IN SOCIETY
BECAUSE YOU'RE ALSO, IF THEY
HAVE A CHILD MOVING THE KID FROM
SCHOOL TO SCHOOL TO SCHOOL, YOU
KNOW, THEY ARE POTENTIALLY
IMPACTING FUTURE GENERATIONS IN
A NEGATIVE WAY WITHOUT ANY
COMMUNITY INVOLVEMENT OR EVEN
CLOSENESS, IF YOU WILL. SO I DO
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF
THINGS ON TOP OF THAT. FIRST
OFF, THERE'S ONLY SO MANY CITIES
THAT HAVE RENT CONTROL IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IT'S
ACTUALLY QUITE FEW RIGHT? RENT
CONTROL IS VERY LIMITED BECAUSE
OF COSTA-HAWKINS MANY CITIES.
RENT CONTROL IS FOR MULTI-FAMILY
UNITS. PRIOR TO 1979, 1978,
1980. ALL YEARS BEFORE I WAS
EVEN BORN. THESE PROPERTIES WERE
OLDER AND I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT RENT CONTROL DOES NOT COVER
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES, CONDOS,
TOWNHOMES, DUPLEXES, TRIPLEXES,
AND UP TO ABOUT FOURPLEXES. I
STATE THIS BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
THIS IS WHO WE TRY TO PROTECT
THE MOST IS THE SMALL MOM AND
POP LANDLORD THAT MADE AN
INVESTMENT FOR THEIR RETIREMENT,
OR THEIR FUTURE, OR THEIR KIDS,
OR WHATEVER THE CASE MAY BE.
HOWEVER, RENT CONTROL AND THE
CONCEPT OF PROP 33 AND MUCH MORE
IS FOR THE MULTIFAMILY. LARGE
COMPLEXES. THIS IS FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT LITERALLY WILL
NEVER, AND LET'S BE HONEST ABOUT
THIS, PURCHASE A HOME IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, RIGHT? IN
MY DISTRICT ALONE, A SINGLE
FAMILY HOME GOES FOR ABOUT $1.4
MILLION. TELL ME A TEACHER THAT
CAN PAY FOR THAT CARPENTER OR AN
AVERAGE WORKER THAT DOESN'T EVEN
HAVE THE BENEFIT OF BEING
UNIONIZED. RIGHT? SO I HIGHLIGHT
THAT BECAUSE THESE ARE THINGS AS
POLICYMAKERS THAT WE NEED TO
PUSH AND PROTECT FOLKS AND ALSO
PROTECT THE INDUSTRY IN THE BEST
BENEFIT OF THE AVERAGE PERSON,
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE ROUGHLY A
LITTLE UNDER 50%, I THINK EVEN
MORE THAN 50% OF THE POPULATION
AS RENTERS, BECAUSE THIS BALLOT
MEASURE, IN THIS FORM OR ANOTHER
FORM HAS COME IN PRETTY MUCH
EVERY ELECTION FOR THE LAST
THREE ELECTIONS. AND THE AMOUNT
OF MONEY THAT IS BEING SPENT TO
SUPPORT ONE ARGUMENT OVER THE
OTHER IS VERY SKEWED AS WELL. I
WILL ALSO HIGHLIGHT TO SOME OF
THE COMMENTARY. THIS DOES NOT
PREVENT NEW DEVELOPMENT, RIGHT?
THE TREND OF NEW DEVELOPMENT HAS
BEEN THE SINGLE FAMILY HOMES,
THE TOWNHOMES, THE CONDOS AND SO
FORTH. BECAUSE THEY ARE MORE
PROFITABLE, PERIOD. RIGHT. THOSE
THAT ARE CONSIDERED STARTER
HOMES ARE STILL UNAFFORDABLE TO
THE AVERAGE PERSON. THE CITIES
AND SERVING ON LOCAL CITY
COUNCIL DO NOT IMPLEMENT THE
PRICE OF ANY OF THESE
DEVELOPMENTS. IT IS THE
DEVELOPERS SOLE RESPONSIBILITY
TO SEE HOW MUCH MONEY THEY CAN
GET OUT OF EACH INDIVIDUAL UNIT,
HOW MUCH THEY'RE GOING TO SPEND
ON COST OF MATERIAL, ON LABOR,
ON MUCH MORE. SO IT IS
ABSOLUTELY INCORRECT TO SAY THAT
THIS WOULD IMPACT NEW
DEVELOPMENT. AND I WILL
HIGHLIGHT THIS BECAUSE THE
CITIES THAT HAVE RENT CONTROL
LIKE LÀ, HAS ENACTED RENT
CONTROL IN 1978, AND THEY HAVE
HAD NEW CONSTRUCTION ROUGHLY IN
2010 TO 2020. AND I'VE PULLED IT
ALL UP HERE FOR THIS HEARING.
ABOUT 50,000 NEW MULTIFAMILY
UNITS, ALL NOT UNDER RENT
CONTROL. RENT CONTROL ALSO, AND
I WANT TO BE VERY SPECIFIC, RENT
CONTROL, RENT STABILIZATION. AND
SO FORTH. THERE IS ALWAYS A
RIGHT OF RETURN ON INVESTMENT
FOR THAT PROPERTY OWNER, RIGHT?
IT COULD BE 3%, 5%. AND THE
STATE'S CAP OF ACROSS THE BOARD
10%. RIGHT? SAN FRANCISCO HAS
DEVELOPED A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
UNITS LITERALLY, YOU KNOW, OVER
25,000 IN THE LAST 20 YEARS.
BERKELEY, YOU KNOW, EVEN
HAYWARD, A SMALLER CITY THAT I
COME FROM HAS BEEN DEVELOPING
NONSTOP. SO I HIGHLIGHT ALL OF
THESE THINGS BECAUSE THE
RHETORIC AND THE NARRATIVE AND
THE DATA IS ALWAYS UTILIZED IN A
NEGATIVE WAY. SO I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT TO THE PANELISTS HERE.
AND IF YOU GUYS, IF ANY ONE OF
YOU GUYS CAN ANSWER THIS
QUESTION WITHOUT COSTA-HAWKINS
AND WITH COSTA-HAWKINS, CAN A
LANDLORD STILL RAISE RENTS? YEAH,
YEAH, A LANDLORD CAN STILL RAISE
RENTS. AND THEY ALSO ARE
GUARANTEED IN THE STATE
CONSTITUTION A FAIR RATE OF
RETURN. OKAY. AND WHEN A
PARTICULAR RENTER LEAVES A UNIT,
IS THE LANDLORD ABLE TO INCREASE
THE RENT TO MARKET RATE? YES.
THAT'S HAPPENING LITERALLY IN MY
BUILDING. SO OKAY. AND SO THE
ARGUMENT THAT WE CONSTANTLY HEAR
THAT IT RESTRICTS. SO
SIGNIFICANTLY AND YOU KNOW, MY
BIG QUESTION IS ALSO WHY WHY ARE
WE NOT FOCUSED ON JUST MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE SAFEGUARDS FOR
POOR PEOPLE, MORE SO THAN
FOCUSED ON THE PROFITS OF
LANDLORDS? DO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTARY ON THAT? YEAH, I
THINK IT'S A SHAME THAT THE
NARRATIVE IS SET ON PROFITS OVER
PEOPLE AGAIN AND AGAIN. AND
AGAIN. YOU KNOW, IN THE MEDIA,
IN THE STATE LEGISLATURE.
UNFORTUNATELY, WHEN YOU HAVE
CONSTITUENTS AND WE KNOW THAT
THE MARKET TYPICALLY DOESN'T
WORK FOR LOWER INCOME PEOPLE,
AND THEY RELY ON THEIR ELECTED
OFFICIALS TO HELP THEM, IT'S
REALLY DISTRESSING THAT WE ARE
CONSTANTLY TALKING ABOUT
PROFITS, AND WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT PEOPLE, ACTUAL PEOPLE. A
WAITRESS WITH TWO KIDS. SO WE
HAVE SEEN A RISE IN OUR HOMELESS
POPULATION, MORE SPECIFICALLY
AMONG SENIORS ON FIXED INCOMES.
DO YOU BELIEVE INCREASED UNITS
THAT HAVE SOME TYPE OF RENT
CONTROL, RENT STABILIZATION
WOULD HELP OUR SENIOR POPULATION?
ABSOLUTELY. 100%. AND CONTROL
GIVES PREDICTABILITY OF RENT. A
LOT OF HOMEOWNERS HAVE
PREDICTABILITY OF RENT. AND IF
YOU TOLD THE HOMEOWNER, HEY,
YOUR MORTGAGE IS GOING TO GO UP
10% EVERY SINGLE YEAR, I MEAN,
THEY WOULD COME AT YOU AND BE
LIKE, WE'RE NOT GOING TO, YOU
KNOW, PAY 10% MORE IN MORTGAGE.
BUT SOMEHOW THAT'S OKAY FOR
PEOPLE WHO I MEAN, YOU KNOW, THE
STATISTICS SHOW THAT RENTERS
MAKE HALF OF WHAT LANDLORDS MAKE
AND THEY REALLY CAN'T AFFORD IT.
I MEAN, THEY JUST CAN'T AFFORD
IT. IT'S REALLY THAT SIMPLE. AND
CURRENTLY RENTERS, DO THEY NOT
PAY FOR THEIR PARKING, THEIR
UTILITIES, EVEN A MONTHLY PET
FEE? YES. I HAVE A CLIENT THAT
ACTUALLY IS PAYING $25 PET RENT
AND SHE IS A SENIOR CITIZEN AND
SHE'S IN HER 80S AND HER RENT
GOES UP 8%, ABOUT 8% EVERY YEAR.
BECAUSE I KNOW BECAUSE EVERY
YEAR WHEN SHE GETS THAT RENT
INCREASE, I HEAR FROM HER. AND
THEN SHE ALWAYS TELLS ME ABOUT
THE PET RENT BECAUSE SHE HAS A
CAT. OKAY. AND, YOU KNOW, IN MY
DISTRICT, FOR THE MOST PART, IT
AVERAGES OVER $100. AND HERE
EVEN IN SACRAMENTO, I PAY OVER
$175 FOR A NON-GUARANTEED
PARKING SPACE. SO AS A RENTER, I
ALSO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT WHEN
CONSTRUCTION OR LET'S SAY, AN
IMPROVEMENT TO A UNIT OR SO
FORTH. IS DONE BY THE LANDLORD.
IS THAT COST TO SOME DEGREE
EXTENDED OVER TO THE RENTER?
YES. THAT'S THE THAT'S THE YEAH.
YOU CAN PASS THROUGH THAT COST.
AND THAT'S ACTUALLY A LOT OF
UPWARD ADJUSTMENTS BEYOND RENT
CONTROL THAT ARE APPROVED BY
RENT BOARDS ARE FOR IS THERE ANY
DATA AS TO THE DEVELOPER MAKING
THEIR RETURN ON INVESTMENT? IS
THERE A NUMBER OF YEARS AFTER
THAT DEVELOPMENT IS CREATED THAT
THE DEVELOPER GETS THEIR, LET'S
SAY, FAIR RATE OF RETURN? YOU
MEAN TO THEIR INVESTMENT? YEAH,
IT'S ABOUT 15 YEARS, WHICH IS
WHY FOR PROP 21, WE HAD A 15
YEAR ROLLING START DATE. BUT OUR
OPPOSITION NOW FOR PROP 33 ALSO
OPPOSE THAT AS WELL. SO WE'VE
CARVED OUT NEW DEVELOPMENT FOR
15 YEARS. AND THAT APPARENTLY
WASN'T GOOD ENOUGH. DEFINITELY.
AND I WAS A PART OF USC'S
PROGRAM FOR DEVELOPERS AND SO
FORTH. AND I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT DEVELOPMENTS ARE ACTUALLY
SOLD EVEN SOONER THAN THE 15
YEARS. SO THEY MAKE THEIR PROFIT
AND THEIR RETURN A LOT FASTER,
EVEN UNDER RENT CONTROLLED UNITS
IN THESE PARTICULAR CITIES,
BECAUSE RENT CONTROL DOES NOT
APPLY TO LITERALLY NOT A SINGLE
DEVELOPMENT AFTER 1995. RIGHT?
SO I APPRECIATE THAT. I JUST
REALLY WANT TO HIGHLIGHT IF YOU
GUYS HAVE ANY COMMENTARY IN
REGARDS TO WHO THIS, YOU KNOW,
WOULD HELP. PROP 33, WHAT IS THE
GOAL OVERALL? YEAH, REAL QUICK,
JUST ONE ADDITION TO REPEALING.
REPEALING COSTA-HAWKINS IS NOT
GOING TO STOP YOU FROM SETTING
WHAT THE BASE RENT IS WHEN YOU
ARE FIRST ISSUING YOUR SECURITY
OF OCCUPANCY, YOU CAN SET THAT
TO WHATEVER YOU WANT AS A
DEVELOPER. BUT NO, I MEAN, IN
TERMS OF WHO THIS IS GOING TO
HELP, THIS IS GOING TO THIS IS
GOING TO HELP PEOPLE WHOSE
INCOMES ARE NOT A LOT OF PEOPLE,
NOT JUST NOT JUST LOW INCOME
TENANTS, BUT ALSO MIDDLE INCOME
TENANTS AS WELL, WHO ARE ALSO
COMPLETELY SHUT OUT OF THE
HOMEOWNERSHIP MARKET AT THIS
POINT, AS YOU SAID. BUT ANYONE
WHOSE INCOME IS NOT MY INCOME IS
NOT GOING UP 10% YEAR OVER YEAR,
RIGHT? I IF ANYONE ELSE IS HERE
IS CONGRATULATIONS. I'M HAPPY
FOR YOU. BUT BUT YEAH, I MEAN
IT'S BECAUSE I THINK BECAUSE
RENT CONTROL ALSO DOESN'T YOU
DON'T YOU DON'T NEED A LOTTERY
TO GET IN THERE. YOU DON'T NEED
TO DO ALL THESE INCOME
VERIFICATIONS AND APPLICATIONS
AND WAIT LISTS, ETC. IT'S JUST
STABILIZING THE RATE OF INCREASE
ON YOUR RENT. SO YOU MOVE IN
THERE. YOU CAN PAY A CERTAIN
RENT, LIKE IF YOU'RE IF YOUR
SALARY GOES UP, YOU KNOW, A
LITTLE BIT OR IF, YOU KNOW, IF
YOU JUST HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF A
DOWNTURN IN YOUR LIFE OR YOU
NEED TO PAY FOR, YOU KNOW, YOUR
KIDS EDUCATION OR YOU NEED TO
PAY FOR YOUR HEALTH CARE COSTS,
ETC. MOST PEOPLE WE HAVE UPTURNS
AND DOWNTURNS IN OUR LIVES,
RIGHT? ESPECIALLY WORKING LOW
INCOME AND MIDDLE INCOME PEOPLE
AND RENT CONTROL IS FOR YOU,
RIGHT? AND RENT CONTROL. SO FOR
EXAMPLE, WHEN PEOPLE TALK ABOUT,
YOU KNOW, THE HOUSING MARKET AND
SO FORTH, WE DO HAVE HIGH
DEMAND. IT'S CALIFORNIA.
EVERYONE WANTS TO MOVE HERE. AND
OBVIOUSLY POPULATION GROWTH AS A
WHOLE. BUT AS FAR AS THE
RESTRICTIONS ON OKAY, WHY
DEVELOPMENT IS NOT HAPPENING,
DOES RENT CONTROL REALLY APPLY
TO THAT IN ANY CONCEPT, IF
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES, CONDOS,
TOWNHOMES, DUPLEXES AND ANY
PROPERTY AFTER 1995 IS CREATED
IS EXEMPTED FROM RENT CONTROL, I
MEAN, THAT WOULD BE UP TO THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY. SO IT WOULD BE
UP TO THE CITY COUNCIL AND THE
COUNTY SUPERVISORS. AND I THINK
THERE THERE'S ANOTHER ISSUE
WHICH YOU'VE KIND OF TOUCHED ON
TOO, WHICH IS THAT IF SOMEONE IS
RENT BURDENED, IT'S VERY HARD
FOR THEM TO SAVE UP FOR THAT
ELUSIVE DOWN PAYMENT TO BUY A
HOME. AND EVEN IF THEY DO SAVE
UP, IT'S THE SAME LANDLORDS WHO
ARE RAISING RENTS ON THESE
MULTIFAMILY BUILDINGS, WHO ARE
ALSO COMPETING AGAINST THOSE
FAMILIES A LOT OF TIMES TO
ACTUALLY PURCHASE A HOME BECAUSE
WE'RE SEEING CORPORATE LANDLORDS
AND WE HAVE SINCE 2008, BUYING
UP A LOT OF THE SINGLE FAMILY
HOME STOCK AS WELL. AND THE LÀ
REPORT STATES THAT RENTERS IN
CALIFORNIA TYPICALLY PAY ABOUT
50% MORE FOR HOUSING THAN
RENTERS IN OTHER STATES. THAT'S
RIGHT. WE HAVE MORE PEOPLE RENT
BURDENED IN CALIFORNIA THAN
ANYWHERE IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. SENATOR
ASHBY. FIRST OF ALL, IT DOES MY
HEART GOOD TO SEE AN ALL FEMALE
PANEL. SO THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. AND, YOU KNOW, FIGHTING
FOR MORE HOUSING. I, I
DEFINITELY THINK WE ALL AGREE ON
THAT. IT'S ALWAYS JUST ABOUT
HOW. RIGHT. AND I GUESS I JUST
WANTED TO CHIME IN BECAUSE EVERY
CHANCE I GET I WANT TO SAY THIS,
I, I PERSONALLY BELIEVE THAT
PART OF THE HOUSING CRISIS THAT
WE'RE EXPERIENCING NOW COMES
FROM THE LOSS OF REDEVELOPMENT
AT THE STATE LEVEL, AND TO DENY
THAT IS, I THINK, SHOWS A
CERTAIN LEVEL OF BEING
UNINFORMED ABOUT HOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS BUILD LOW AND VERY
LOW INCOME HOUSING, BECAUSE
LOSING THAT SOURCE IN 2011 AND
THEN FLASH FORWARD TO NOW AND WE
HAVE THIS CRISIS AND IT IT
REALLY IS ROOTED AT THE AT THE
VERY BEGINNING OF HOUSING. SO
PEOPLE WHO NEED WRAPAROUND
SERVICES OR ADDITIONAL CARE OR
SUPPORT THAT, THAT'S THE HOUSING
WE'RE LACKING. THE MOST OF ALL.
AND IT'S SO CLOGGED THAT IN THE
CONTINUUM OF HOUSING, WE CAN'T
TRANSFER PEOPLE OUT OF IT. AND
INTO THE NEXT. AND THEN ON TO
INDEPENDENCE, BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH SPACING AT THAT VERY
BEGINNING. AND WHILE I AM A BIG
PROPONENT OF HOUSING ANYWHERE ON
THE SPECTRUM HELPS HOUSING
EVERYWHERE ON THE SPECTRUM, WE
HAVE AN UNDENIABLE PROBLEM ON
THE FRONT END AND, YOU KNOW, I
HAVE MIXED FEELINGS ABOUT RENT
CONTROL. I DO I'VE SEEN IT. I'VE
SEEN SOME RENT SOLUTIONS WORK.
BUT I ALSO WORRY DEEPLY ABOUT
DEVELOPERS NOT BEING ABLE TO
BUILD BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE A
SURETY. I THINK SENATOR ROTH
WENT DOWN THIS LANE WITH YOU,
BUT IT'S HARD FOR DEVELOPERS.
THEY WILL TELL YOU IF I DON'T
KNOW HOW MUCH REVENUE I CAN
COUNT ON, I CAN'T ENTER INTO THE
PROJECT. AND SO IF WE CAN'T MAKE
IT VERY CLEAR AND VERY CERTAIN
FOR DEVELOPERS THAT THEIR MARGIN
IS GOING TO BE ENOUGH FOR THEM
TO FINANCE HOUSING, WE'RE GOING
TO SEE A DIFFERENT KIND OF
PROBLEM THAT WILL THEN HAVE TO
SOLVE FOR. SO I JUST LIKE TO
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY AND MAYBE
LET EACH OF YOU, IF YOU WANT TO
CHIME IN ON IT, BUT, YOU KNOW,
SENATOR WAHHAB AND I ARE FAIRLY
NEW HERE. WE'RE BOTH HYPER LOCAL
ELECTEDS WE SO UNDERSTAND THIS
FROM OUR CITY'S PERSPECTIVE.
WE'VE GOT A LITTLE TIME ON THE
CLOCK AND WE REALLY WANT TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT HOUSING. AND I
TEND TO FOCUS ON THE
REDEVELOPMENT PIECE. AND SHE
FOCUSES ON THAT OF OTHER AREAS
TOO. SO TELL US WHAT YOU WOULD
DO IF YOU WERE SENATORS. HOW
WOULD YOU BRING BACK SOME FORM
OF REDEVELOPMENT TO HELP OFFSET
THIS ISSUE SO THAT WE COULD DEAL
WITH THE FUNDING COMPONENT AND
ALSO THE PIECE WHERE OUR HOUSING
AND REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES OR
OUR NONPROFITS OUT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES DEPENDS ON WHICH
CITY YOU KNOW, WHOEVER'S DOING
THAT WORK, HOW THEY HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO THOSE FAMILIES. AND
LET ME CAVEAT THIS BY SAYING I
LIVED IN LOW INCOME HOUSING FOR
A BIG CHUNK OF MY LIFE AS A
YOUNG, SINGLE MOM IN THIS CITY
WHERE I AM NOW, THE SENATOR AND
I USED FOOD STAMPS AND I HAD TO
MOVE A LOT TO KEEP RENT AT AN
ATTAINABLE RATE FOR MYSELF AND
MY LITTLE BOY WHILE I WORKED
FULL TIME AND PUT MYSELF THROUGH
UC DAVIS, AND THEN MCGEORGE LAW
SCHOOL AT NIGHT. SO I AM NOT
UNFAMILIAR WITH NAVIGATING THOSE
RESOURCES. I AM NOT UNFAMILIAR
WITH WHAT STABILIZING SOMEBODY'S
LIFE CAN MEAN TO THEIR FUTURE. I
THINK I'M A PRETTY GOOD EXAMPLE
OF IT, ACTUALLY, BUT I LIVED IN
HOUSING SOMETIMES. THAT WAS
SUBSIDIZED, SOMETIMES IT WASN'T.
SOMETIMES IT WAS JUST A GOOD
DEAL OR A LAYOUT THAT SEEMED
LIKE A ONE BEDROOM, BUT HAD A
LOFT SO I COULD TURN IT INTO A
KID'S ROOM. BUT YOU GET CREATIVE
WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
MONEY, SO YOU TELL ME WHAT YOU
WOULD DO, HOW YOU WOULD BALANCE
THOSE TWO THINGS, AND HOW YOU
THINK REDEVELOPMENT PLAYS INTO
IT. BECAUSE I THINK THAT IS SUCH
A MISSING COMPONENT MOVING
FORWARD. SO, SENATOR ASHBY, ARE
YOU ASKING EACH PANEL MEMBER TO
RESPOND TO THAT? WHICHEVER ONE
WANTS TO, THEY DON'T ALL HAVE TO.
ALL RIGHT. SO WHY DON'T WE START
WITH MISS SINGH AND THEN WE CAN
PROCEED. THANK YOU. I CAN TRY TO
TAKE A STAB AT THAT. THAT'S A
THAT'S A VERY AMBITIOUS
QUESTION, SENATOR ASHBY. THERE'S
SO MANY THINGS THAT WERE, LIKE
CIRCULATING IN MY MIND. BUT, YOU
KNOW, I MEAN, ONE THING THAT
WE'RE THINKING OF, THAT
REDEVELOPMENT OR LET ME LET ME
PUT IT, THIS WAY. THE
LOCALITIES, WHEN WE'RE TALKING
TO LOCAL FOLKS WHO ARE TRYING TO
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING OR
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING OR
FUND THINGS LIKE COMMUNITY LAND
TRUSTS, I SIT ON THE BOARD OF A
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST OF SAN
FRANCISCO CLT. SO I ACTUALLY DO
HAVE TO LOOK AT LIKE FINANCING
SPREADSHEETS AND STUFF AND LIKE
KIND OF A LANDLORD MYSELF. NOT
REALLY, BUT BUT, BUT BUT TO THAT
POINT, YOU KNOW, THE LOSS OF
REDEVELOPMENT MEANS THAT THE
STATE, WHETHER YOU'RE BUILDING
TRADITIONAL LOW INCOME HOUSING
TAX CREDIT, HOUSING, WHETHER
YOU'RE EXPLORING FORMS OF SOCIAL
HOUSING, WHETHER YOU'RE TRYING
TO KEEP WHAT EXISTING PUBLIC
HOUSING EXISTS FUNDED OR WELL
MAINTAINED, YOU'RE TRYING TO GET
FUNDING FOR COMMUNITY LAND
TRUSTS OR WHATEVER TO TAKE
HOUSING OFF THE SPECULATIVE
MARKET AND ADD TO THE STOCK OF
PERMANENTLY AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
EVERYBODY IS REALLY, REALLY
STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
THEY DON'T FEEL NO OFFENSE TO
ANYBODY THAT THEY'RE BEING
ADEQUATELY RESOURCED BY THE
STATE. AND SINCE WHAT I THINK
29, I FORGET IT'S 2018 OR 2019,
BUT SINCE THEN, 1% OF OUR TOTAL
GENERAL FUND BUDGET HAS BEEN
ALLOCATED TO ALL HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS COMBINED,
WHICH MEANS THAT IT CREATES A
LOT OF UNFORTUNATELY, LIKE NOT
COMPETITION IN THE FUND SENSE.
COMPETITION, YOU KNOW, BETWEEN
SCARCE RESOURCES BECAUSE
EVERYBODY, EVERYBODY WHO'S
TRYING TO BUILD ANY FORM OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS OFTEN
BEING PITTED AGAINST EACH OTHER.
AND LOOKING TO THE STATE FOR
RESOURCES. AND ADDITIONALLY, I
MEAN, A GREAT EXAMPLE IS WE
PASSED THE WHAT WAS IT TWO,
THREE YEARS AGO, THE FORECLOSURE
INTERVENTION HOUSING
PRESERVATION PROGRAM. AND, YOU
KNOW THAT I WORK WITH
RECIPIENTS. I'M ON THE BOARD OF
ONE THAT COULD HAVE BEEN ONE.
RIGHT. AND LIKE THAT PROGRAM WAS
VERY CAREFULLY DESIGNED AND
IMPLEMENTED, AND PEOPLE FOUGHT
OVER THE MONEY AND THE MONEY WAS
GRANTED. AND THEN ALL OF A
SUDDEN, JUST AS IT WAS FIRED,
THE RUBBER WAS FINALLY ABOUT TO
HIT THE ROAD. THAT MONEY GOT
CLAWED BACK. SO I THINK THAT'S
ALSO THAT THAT'S AN EXAMPLE OF
LIKE, YOU KNOW, WE PUT ALL OF
THIS WORK INTO WE NGUYEN A
PROPOSAL, THE LEGISLATURE SIGNS
ON THE GOVERNOR SIGNS ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION IS UNDERWAY OR
IT'S ABOUT TO HAPPEN. THEN ALL
OF A SUDDEN IT'S GONE. SO THAT'S
AN EXAMPLE OF SOMETHING I WOULD
HOPE TO BE FIXED VIÆT THANK YOU,
SENATOR ROSSO, DID YOU WANT TO
MAKE A COMMENT? YES. THANK YOU.
JUST JUST BEFORE I LEAVE, I JUST
WANT TO BE CLEAR. THERE ARE SO
MANY ISSUES RELATED TO HOUSING,
BUT TODAY IS ABOUT PROP 33. AND
PROP 33 IS NOT ABOUT A
PARTICULAR VERSION OF RENT
CONTROL. IT IS STRICTLY ABOUT
PUTTING IT IN THE HANDS OF LOCAL
ENTITIES THAT THEY PUT IT IF
THEY WANT TO ON THE BALLOT, THEY
DON'T WANT TO, THEY DON'T HAVE
TO. WHAT IT'S GOING TO BE, WHAT
IT'S GOING TO COVER, WHAT IT'S
NOT BECAUSE BECAUSE OTHERWISE I
THINK WE COULD TRY TO. YEAH. SO
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU, THANK
YOU, THANK YOU, SENATOR RUSSO.
OKAY, BACK TO SENATOR ASHBY'S
QUESTION. SO ALL RIGHT, SO, SO
FOR ME, THE FIRST THING THAT I
WOULD DO IS STABILIZE RENTS FOR
EXISTING TENANTS BECAUSE I THINK
THAT THEY DESERVE SOME
PREDICTABILITY IN THEIR HOUSING
COSTS, WHICH IS VERY SIMILAR TO
WHAT A HOMEOWNER HAS. I ALSO
WENT TO UC DAVIS. I HAD NO
PROBLEM FINDING HOUSING THEN.
I'M NOT SURE THAT WOULD BE THE
CASE NOW THAT THAT WAS
AFFORDABLE. THE OTHER THING IS,
YOU KNOW, THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFIT HOUSING THAT
REPRESENTS THE BUILDERS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ACTUALLY
SUPPORT PROP 33. SO THEY DON'T
SEE THIS AS IN ANY WAY OF
STOPPING NEW CONSTRUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. BUT WE'RE
REALLY TALKING ABOUT IS
CONSTRUCTION OF MARKET RATE
HOUSING. AND IT DOESN'T STOP
THAT EITHER. SO YOU KNOW, THE
QUESTION IS, YOU KNOW, DO WE
BELIEVE THAT THE RENTS THAT ARE
SET RIGHT NOW ARE SOMETHING THAT
PEOPLE CAN AFFORD IN THE
COMMUNITY OR NOT? IS THE MARKET
ACTUALLY WORKING FOR MODERATE,
LOW AND VERY LOW INCOME FOLKS?
ARE WE BUILDING FOR THOSE PEOPLE
IN LOS ANGELES? WE'RE NOT. I
MEAN, WE HAVE OVER 70,000 VACANT
UNITS IN LOS ANGELES. WE HAVE
HOMELESS ENCAMPMENTS IN THE
SHADOWS OF VACANT BUILDINGS,
WHICH IS A STRONG INDICATION. IF
WE HEARD ABOUT THIS IN ANOTHER
COUNTRY, WE WOULD SAY SOMETHING
IS VERY, VERY WRONG. AND THAT'S
BECAUSE HOUSING IS BEING USED AS
A COMMODITY. HOUSING IS
SOMETHING THAT EXISTS ON A
BALANCE SHEET. HOUSING IS
SOMETHING THAT IS INCREASING IN
VALUE YEAR AFTER YEAR. EVEN IF
YOU HAVE A VACANT BUILDING, YOU
KNOW, ONE SAYS THAT SOMEONE WHO
OWNS A BUILDING OR BUILDS A
BUILDING OR WHATEVER HAS TO RENT
UP 100% OF THEIR UNITS. WE HAVE
NO CONTROL ON VACANCY RIGHT NOW.
ON VACANT UNITS, WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF SAN FRANCISCO,
THERE MAY BE A COUPLE OTHER
CITIES. I'M NOT SURE, BUT THE
LANDLORDS CAN DO WHATEVER THEY
WANT. THEY CAN HAVE. YOU KNOW, I
HAD A LANDLORD TELL ME THAT THEY
MAKE ENOUGH OF A PROFIT HAVING
THEIR BUILDING HALF FULL IN LOS
ANGELES, AND THEY WOULD RATHER
DO THAT THAN BRING IN A LOW
INCOME ELEMENT TO THEIR
BUILDING. SO WE'RE ACTING LIKE,
YOU KNOW, THIS MARKET IS THE
SAME AS TENNIS BALLS. IT'S NOT
TENNIS BALLS. THIS IS PROPERTY
THAT IS INCREASING IN VALUE YEAR
AFTER YEAR. IT'S BEING BOUGHT BY
HEDGE FUNDS, BY INVESTMENT
COMPANIES, AND THEY HAVE IT ON
THEIR BALANCE SHEETS. IT'S NOT
ALWAYS GOING TO BE RENTAL
HOUSING. I'LL THANK YOU. I'LL
JUST QUICKLY SAY THAT, YOU KNOW,
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO LEGISLATE.
I, I DON'T HAVE ANY INTENTIONS
OF WANTING TO BE A SENATOR. ALL
I KNOW THAT YOU KNOW WHAT I CAN
CONTRIBUTE IS FIGURING OUT HOW
TO HELP PASS THIS MEASURE. I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE RESPONSE IS.
I JUST KNOW THAT, FOR EXAMPLE,
MY SON, I'M A I HAVE A 25 YEAR
OLD SON WHO SITS ON THE COUNCIL
IN, IN STAUNTON, AND HE WOULD
LIKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO FIGURE
OUT IF STAUNTON CAN BE. HAVE YOU
KNOW, RENT CONTROL. ALL I KNOW
IS THAT HE GETS BLAMED FOR
PEOPLE NOT BEING ABLE TO, YOU
KNOW, LIVE IN THE PLACES WHERE
THEY THEY CAN. ALL I KNOW IS
THAT I HEAR THAT AS LEGISLATORS,
WHETHER YOU'RE IN THE CITY
COUNCIL LEVEL OR A SENATOR, THAT
WE'VE GOT SOME RESPONSIBILITY.
AND SO I, I NOW KNOW THAT WE
HAVE IN THE HANDS OF, YOU KNOW,
CALIFORNIA VOTERS, THE ABILITY
TO PASS RENT CONTROL. AND THAT'S
WHAT I CAN CONTRIBUTE. YOU KNOW,
AS, AS A CALIFORNIAN, JUST TO
GET THE WORD OUT. BUT I WOULD
LOVE TO HEAR I'M JUST FASCINATED
TO HEAR WHAT OTHERS HAVE TO SAY
ABOUT, YOU KNOW, HOW TO TRY TO
MOVE THAT FORWARD. SO AND MISS
PRESIDENT GUTIERREZ PHÐ ONE
SECOND, SENATOR ROSS NEEDS TO
LEAVE. SO HE. NO, NO, NO, NO, WE
HAVE ONE ONE MORE PERSON TO
COMMENT ON YOUR QUESTION. YEAH.
AND THEN AND THEN WE'LL TURN TO
SENATOR ROTH. ALL RIGHT. YEAH I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION. I'M A
NURSE. I AM CLEARLY NOT A
HOUSING EXPERT. I'M NOT AN
ECONOMIST. AND I WOULD NEVER BE
ON THAT SIDE TO WANT TO BE A
SENATOR. I LOVE TAKING CARE OF
PEOPLE. AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
HISTORY. BUT THIS I CAN TELL YOU
AS A PATIENT ADVOCATE AND AS A
MOTHER, IT IS DISTRESSING TO ME
TO HEAR THAT WHAT WE HAVE TO
CONTEND WITH IS ACTUALLY
LOGISTICS OF PROFIT GROWTH
VERSUS THE MENTAL HEALTH AND
WELFARE OF OUR CALIFORNIANS. I
AM A MOTHER OF A ALMOST 30 YEAR
OLD AND 35 YEARS OLD, AND I HAVE
A LOT OF NURSES WHO HAVE OLDER
KIDS, AND I CAN TELL YOU MOST OF
THEM, AND THEY HAVE GOOD JOBS.
THEY ARE LIVING WITH US BECAUSE
THEY CANNOT AFFORD THIS RENT.
AND SO BEYOND BEYOND THE TRAGIC
REALITIES OF WHAT I DESCRIBED
EARLIER OF PRIORITIZING PROFITS
OVER, YOU KNOW, THE PRESENT AND
THE FUTURE OF THIS COUNTRY. I
ALSO, YOU KNOW, WANT TO SAY NO
MATTER IN JUST LOGISTICS AND
COMMON SENSICAL TERMS, YOU CAN
YOU CAN YOU CAN INVEST IN
DEVELOPERS. ALL YOU WANT AND
THEY CAN BUILD AS MUCH AS THEY
WANT. BUT IF NOBODY CAN AFFORD
IT, THEN WHAT ARE WE DOING?
WE'RE JUST INVESTING IN THESE
DEVELOPERS. BUT WE ARE ACTUALLY
KILLING OUR FUTURE. THAT TO ME,
AS A CALIFORNIAN, AS A WOMAN, AS
A MOTHER, AND AS A NURSE, THIS
IS WHAT I WANT YOU GUYS TO COME
AWAY WITH TODAY. AND I AM
DEPENDING ON YOU AND SO ARE ALL
THE NURSES AND PATIENTS IN THIS
STATE TO TRULY FOCUS ON WHAT
REALLY MATTERS. OUR KIDS NEED
YOU TO MAKE THOSE GOOD
DECISIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PERSPECTIVE. WE'LL COME BACK TO
YOU, SENATOR ASHBY. BUT LET'S
SENATOR ROTH ASK HIS QUESTION. I
JUST WANT TO ASK ONE CLARIFYING
QUESTION FOR ME, BECAUSE I, I,
TOO AM NOT IN THE HOUSING
BUSINESS. I'M NOT A CONTRACTOR
AND I'M NOT A DEVELOPER. SO I'M
PRETTY SURE I DON'T KNOW WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT. BUT IF I
DECIDE TO DEVELOP AN APARTMENT
BUILDING AND I ACTUALLY
CONSTRUCT IT UNDER PROP 33 AND I
UNDERSTAND THIS IS LOCAL
CONTROL, SO WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO DO. BUT IS IT
YOUR INTENT THAT I WOULD THEN
SET THE INITIAL RATE FOR MY
MARKET RATE APARTMENTS AND THEN
THAT THAT INITIAL RATE WOULD BE
SUBJECT TO WHATEVER LOCAL
CONTROL, LOCAL RENT CONTROL THE
JURISDICTION ADOPTS. IS THAT
YOUR IS THAT THE INTENT YOU WILL
THE INTENT OF PROP 33. SO PROP
21, WE ACTUALLY HAD A 15 YEAR
ROLLING START DATE, RIGHT. AND
ALMOST EVERY CITY THAT I KNOW
THAT I KNOW OF HAS ADOPTED A 15
YEAR ROLLING START DATE. THE
INTENT REALLY IS JUST TO ALLOW
LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO PASS
SOMETHING THAT MAKES SENSE FOR
THEIR COMMUNITY. THIS WON'T BE A
STATEWIDE, YOU KNOW, ONE SIZE
FITS ALL. YOU KNOW WHAT'S GOOD
FOR LOS ANGELES ISN'T
NECESSARILY WHAT FRESNO WOULD
ADOPT AND WHAT'S GOOD FOR THEIR
CONSTITUENTS. AND THAT'S KIND OF
THE POINT OF IT, WHICH IS JUST
TO PUT THAT, YOU KNOW, ONE MORE
TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX. THERE ARE
SOME COMMUNITIES THAT WON'T
ADOPT ANYTHING. THERE ARE OTHERS
THAT, YOU KNOW, HAVE LOW INCOME
RENTERS OR MODERATE INCOME
RENTERS WHERE RENTS ARE SUPER,
SUPER HIGH, WHERE THEY'LL NEED
THAT. AND SO THE WHOLE POINT IS
TO ALLOW THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES
TO MAKE THOSE DECISIONS AS
OPPOSED TO SAYING THERE'S ANY
INTENT OR TRYING TO IMPOSE SOME
STATEWIDE BLUEPRINT ON EVERY
SINGLE COMMUNITY. BUT I'M JUST
SINCE YOU'RE THE ARCHITECT OF
PROP 33, I, I GATHER WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IS IF I BUILD THE
APARTMENT COMPLEX BASED ON COST
OF CONSTRUCTION, WHICH VARIES UP
UNTIL THE TIME YOU ACTUALLY, YOU
KNOW, GET THE OCCUPANCY AND OPEN
THE DOOR, I CAN SET THE MARKET
RATE FOR THE UNITS, BUT THEN ANY
RENT CONTROL THAT A LOCAL
JURISDICTION WOULD ADOPT WOULD
APPLY AT THAT POINT TO THE NEW
CONSTRUCTION. SO ANY INCREASE
WOULD BE GOVERNED BY WHATEVER
THE RENT CONTROL PARAMETERS ARE.
RIGHT? NO. SO FIRST OF ALL, IT
WOULD TAKE THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
ACTUALLY TAKING A VOTE THAT
LOCAL COMMUNITY COULD ENACT A 15
STARTING FOR PURPOSES OF LET'S
LET'S ASSUME A RENT CONTROL
ORDINANCE HAS BEEN PASSED. ALL
RIGHT. RIGHT. SO I GET TO SET
THE MARKET RATE AND THEN THE
RENT CONTROL ORDINANCE WOULD
APPLY TO THAT MARKET RATE FOR
ANY FUTURE INCREASES. RIGHT. IN
THE I CAN DO YOU WANT ME TO IN
THE SCENARIO THAT THAT IS
BASICALLY THE MECHANISM FOR WHAT
WE CALL SECOND GENERATION RENT
CONTROL, WHICH IS RENT CONTROL
IN THE UNITED STATES OVER THE
LAST 40 OR 50 YEARS, INCLUDING
CALIFORNIA, IF THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION DECIDED TO DO THAT,
THIS IS ALL ABOUT JUST LETTING
THEM DECIDE, OH, IT JUST WASN'T
CLEAR TO ME WHEN YOU SAY IT
APPLIES TO NEW CONSTRUCTION,
WHICH IS WHAT'S BEEN SAID,
RIGHT? THAT. NO, THAT HASN'T
BEEN SAID. I'M SORRY. THE IN
ORDER FOR IT TO APPLY TO NEW
CONSTRUCTION AND I DON'T KNOW
WHAT YOUR DEFINITION OF NEW
CONSTRUCTION IS. TYPICALLY IT'S
15 YEARS FOR MOST CITIES IT IT
ABSOLUTELY WOULD NOT NECESSARILY
APPLY TO NEW CONSTRUCTION
BECAUSE THE CITY COUNCIL COULD
HAVE A 15 YEAR RULING START
DATE. BECAUSE YES, IT'S TRUE.
WE'RE THE ARCHITECTS OF PROP 33.
WE'RE ALSO THE ARCHITECTS OF
PROP 21, WHICH HAD A 15 YEAR
RULING START DATE. BUT HERE'S
LET ME THIS MAY BE THE PROBLEM
WITH PROP 33. LET ME JUST ASK
THIS QUESTION BEFORE SENATOR
ROTH LEAVES. THE QUESTION IS
THAT IF A CITY ENACTS AN
ORDINANCE THAT SAYS YOU MAY ONLY
CHARGE $1,000 RENT FOR ANY
DEVELOPMENT, IS THAT DO YOU
BELIEVE THAT THAT IS WITHIN THE
PARAMETERS OF REVOKING,
REPEALING COSTA-HAWKINS THAT
THAT A CITY COULD DO THAT?
ACTUALLY, I BELIEVE THAT THE
STATE CONSTITUTION GIVING
LANDLORDS A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT
TO A FAIR RETURN IS WHAT WOULD
DECIDE OR HELP DECIDE WHAT THAT
STARTING RENT IS. $1,000. WHERE?
WHERE ARE WE TALKING ABOUT. BUT
BUT IT'S YEAH, IT'S GUIDED BY
THE YOUR STATE CONSTITUTION THAT
THAT APPLIES TO EVEN THE INITIAL
RATE. EVEN THE INITIAL RENTAL
RATE, SO LONG AS IT IS SOMEBODY
BELIEVES THAT IT PROVIDES FOR A
FAIR RETURN IS, IN YOUR VIEW,
WOULD BE LEGAL. IT'S ONLY LEGAL
IF IT'S CONSTITUTIONAL. OKAY.
ALL RIGHT. I DON'T KNOW IF
SENATOR ROTH IF THIS JUST
CONFUSES THINGS MORE OR NOT, BUT
GO AHEAD BEFORE YOU GO. NO, I'M.
I JUST THINK THAT WOULD BE GOOD
TO I MEAN, AS THE ARCHITECTS OF
THE PROPOSITION, I THINK IT
WOULD BE GOOD TO CLARIFY THAT
WITH SOME CERTAINTY. AND YOU ALL
WOULD BE ENTITLED. YOU ALL WOULD
BE IN THE DRIVER'S SEAT SINCE
YOU DRAFTED IT TO CLARIFY HOW
THAT APPLIES TO NEW
CONSTRUCTION, BECAUSE IT'S A
LITTLE BIT UNCLEAR TO ME. AND
WHILE I'M NOT A HOUSING PERSON
OR A DEVELOPER, I HAVE BEEN A
LAWYER FOR 50 YEARS AND WORDS
MATTER AND CLARITY IS IMPORTANT,
AND IT MIGHT BE CRITICAL TO SOME
PEOPLE AT THE BALLOT BOX. I
WOULD THINK THAT THE DEVELOPER,
IF THEY COULD SET, YOU KNOW, A
REASONABLE RATE FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION, THEY'D DO THE
CONSTRUCTION, THEY SET THE
MARKET RATE, AND THEN WHATEVER
THE LOCAL JURISDICTION HAS
ADOPTED APPLIES TO THAT RENT FOR
ANY FUTURE INCREASES WOULD MAKE
SENSE TO ME. VACANCY DECONTROL
OUT THE DOOR. SO I ASSUME SO. IF
THERE'S A VACANCY AND SOMEBODY
COMES IN THE RENTAL, THE RENT
RESTRICTION APPLIES AT THAT
POINT. BUT I THINK WE NEED SOME
CLARITY ON THAT. BUT YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT. WE DO NEED
SOME WORK ON WORKER HOUSING. AND
WE NEED TO CONTROL RENTS AND
PEOPLE. HOWEVER, WE TRY TO DRIVE
THE INCOMES UP IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. LIKE EVERYTHING
ELSE, THE INCOMES DON'T KEEP
PACE WITH THE COST OF HOUSING
AND WE HAVE TO WORK ON THAT. BUT
I DO NEED TO LEAVE. BUT I DO
COMMEND YOU ALL FOR THE EFFORT
AND I APOLOGIZE TO MY FOLKS IN
THE FOLKS IN THE SEATS THAT I
WON'T BE ABLE TO HEAR THEM, BUT
MAYBE I CAN LISTEN FROM UPSTAIRS
BEFORE I HAVE TO TAKE OFF. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR. SENATOR
WAHAB, THANK YOU. YOU KNOW, JUST
FROM A LOCAL CITY PERSPECTIVE.
AND I JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THIS FOR THE LARGER PUBLIC.
OBVIOUSLY, AS WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS PROPOSITION WOULD ALLOW FOR
LOCAL CONTROL. THAT IS THE
ULTIMATE GOAL OF THIS, RIGHT. IS
THAT LOCAL CITIES HAVE BEEN SO
RESTRICTED THAT THEY CANNOT EVEN
DO THEIR JOB IN REGARDS TO LAND
USE DECISIONS, RIGHT. AND THAT
IS A BIG FRUSTRATION FROM A
LOCAL CITY PERSPECTIVE. THE
OTHER PERSPECTIVE IS THAT THE
MAJORITY OF CITIES DO WANT
MARKET RATE HOUSING. THEY DO
ALSO WANT TO ENSURE THAT THE
DEVELOPER AND THE LANDLORD HAS
SOME FLEXIBILITY. SO OFTENTIMES
A PURE RENT CONTROL POLICY IS
NOT ENACTED. IT'S A RENT
STABILIZATION POLICY THAT GIVES
FAR MORE FLEXIBILITY TO
LANDLORDS. I STATE THIS BECAUSE
RENT CONTROL BASICALLY SAYS THAT
IF YOU WANT TO, THE QUESTIONS
EARLIER, IF YOU WANT TO CHARGE,
YOU KNOW, $1,000, $2,000, WHICH
LET'S BE HONEST, $1,000 IS NEVER
GOING TO HAPPEN IN THIS MARKET
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER YOU'RE IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA OR NOT. BUT RENT
STABILIZATION WOULD STATE AND
MOST CITIES ARE LEANING THIS
WAY. IS THAT, HEY, IF YOUR UNIT
RIGHT NOW IS $2,000 AND YOU
COULD SET IT, THE LANDLORD SETS
IT, IT WOULD JUST BE INCREASED
YEAR OVER YEAR THAT THAT
PARTICULAR RESIDENCE STAYS THERE
BY 5%, 7%, 3% CPI, WHATEVER THE
CASE MAY BE FAR MORE FLEXIBILITY
IN ALL OF THE CONVERSATIONS
OVERALL. FOR MOST CITIES IS THAT
THEY DO WANT TO BE FAIR TO THESE
CORPORATE LANDLORDS, AND I WANT
TO BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT THAT, AND
THAT THEY ALSO GET A FAIR RATE
OF RETURN TO NOT ONLY UPKEEP THE
UNITS, BUT THEN ALSO, LET'S BE
HONEST, THEY WILL BENEFIT IN ANY
TYPE OF TAX THAT'S THERE, THE
INCREASE THERE. SO IT WOULD BE
COUNTERINTUITIVE FOR A CITY TO
BE SO RESTRICTIVE. SO THIS
FANTASY THAT IT WOULD HAPPEN IS
NONEXISTENT. RIGHT. WHEREAS
CITIES WANT TO BE FAIR. AND TO
THE COMMENT THAT YOU MADE
EARLIER, MOST CITIES KNOW WHAT'S
BEST FOR THEIR OWN COMMUNITY.
MOST CITIES KNOW IF THEIR
DEMOGRAPHIC IS LOWER INCOME
STRUGGLING, LET'S SAY IN THE
RURAL COMMUNITIES OF A BIG
BUSINESS TANKED AND FAILED AND
IS LEAVING THE CITY. YOU KNOW,
WHAT ARE WE DOING FOR RESIDENTS?
AND THIS IS WHAT THIS
PROPOSITION REALLY HIGHLIGHTS
AND HOPEFULLY EMPOWERS LOCAL
CITIES AND LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
TO MAKE THE DECISION BEST FOR
THEIR CONSTITUENTS. SO THANK
YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. LET'S BRING FORTH THE
NEXT PANEL. MISS CARLTON, MR.
CURTIN, MR. JUANITO AND SANJAY
WAGLE. ALL RIGHT. WHOEVER SITS
DOWN FIRST GETS TO GO FIRST.
LOOKS LIKE MISS CARLTON. SO.
OKAY, I GUESS I. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBER. MY NAME IS
DEBORAH CARLTON. I'M THE
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT OF
STATE GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION. WE REPRESENT OVER
60,000 RENTAL PROPERTY OWNERS
AND MANAGERS WHO COLLECTIVELY
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR MORE THAN 2
MILLION RENTAL UNITS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
LARGEST PERCENTAGE OF OUR
MEMBERSHIP ARE SMALL OWNERS.
THEY OWN LESS THAN FIVE UNITS,
AND MOST OF THOSE ARE SINGLE
FAMILY HOME OWNERS. OF COURSE,
I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO PROPOSITION 33. CALIFORNIANS
ARE NOW FACING THE THIRD ATTEMPT
BY MICHAEL WEINSTEIN AND THE
AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION TO
DISMANTLE CALIFORNIA'S LAW ON
RENT CONTROL. PROPOSITIONS TEN
AND 21 WERE SOUNDLY DEFEATED BY
20 POINTS. THE VOTERS HAVE
ALREADY SPOKEN, AND YET HERE WE
ARE AGAIN WITH A THIRD ATTEMPT
PROPOSITION 33. COSTA-HAWKINS
DOESN'T PREVENT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FROM PASSING RENT
CONTROL. INSTEAD, IT PROVIDES
GUARDRAILS. AS YOU HEARD FROM
THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS, STRICT,
STRICT RENT CONTROL IS A BLUNT
INSTRUMENT THAT FAILS TO TARGET
THE INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
MOST IN NEED. RESEARCH HAS SHOWN
THAT THE WEALTHIER TENANTS
BENEFIT FROM RENT CONTROL, WHILE
LOWER INCOME TENANTS FACE
CHALLENGES FINDING HOUSING AT
ALL. A TARGETED APPROACH, SUCH
AS BUILDING MORE HOUSING AND
REDUCING REGULATORY BARRIERS TO
NEW CONSTRUCTION, IS FAR MORE
EFFECTIVE THAN RENT CONTROL.
STUDIES HAVE DEMONSTRATED THAT
RENT CONTROL DOES NOT ACHIEVE
ITS INTENDED GOALS. THE IMPACTS
OF RENT CONTROL HAVE BEEN
EXTENSIVELY STUDIED BY URBAN AND
REAL ESTATE ECONOMISTS. FOR
DECADES. ACROSS POLITICAL LINES.
THE CONCLUSION IS OVERWHELMING
RENT CONTROL POLICIES ARE
ULTIMATELY NOT EFFECTIVE AT
ACHIEVING ITS STATED GOALS. IT
DOES MORE HARM THAN GOOD IN
FACT, IN MARCH 2024, THE JOURNAL
OF HOUSING ECONOMICS PUBLISHED
THE LARGEST META STUDY ON RENT
CONTROL. RENT CONTROL IS CALLED
RENT CONTROL EFFECTS. THROUGH
THE LENS OF EMPIRICAL RESEARCH,
THE STUDY REVIEWED 206 DIFFERENT
ACADEMIC ARTICLES ON RENT
CONTROL IN THE US AND AROUND THE
GLOBE, AND WAS PUBLISHED BETWEEN
1967 AND 2023. OF THESE, 112
WERE EMPIRICAL STUDIES AND 96
WERE QUALITATIVE STUDIES ON THE
IMPACTS OF RENT CONTROL. THE
REVIEW FOUND THAT RENT CONTROL
RESULTS IN A DETERIORATION OF
THE QUALITY OF HOUSING, AND AS A
WHOLE, RENT CONTROL GENERATES
HIGHER RENTS FOR NEIGHBORING
MARKET RATE RENTAL UNITS, AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY, IT CREATES A
SIGNIFICANT DECREASE IN THE
SUPPLY AND QUALITY OF RENTAL
HOUSING BY DISINCENTIVIZING, NEW
CONSTRUCTION AND ENCOURAGING
PROPERTY OWNERS TO REMOVE UNITS
FROM THE MARKET. PROPOSITION 33
WILL WORSEN CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
CRISIS. IN FACT, THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES DID NOT AGREE
TO SUPPORT PROPOSITION 33
BECAUSE THEY KNOW IT'S NOT.
ULTIMATELY, THEIR DECISION.
WHILE THEY HAVE BEEN HAS BEEN
ARGUED THAT IT'S ABOUT LOCAL
CONTROL OUT OF TOWNERS LIKE
MICHAEL WEINSTEIN AND THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION CAN COME
TO YOUR CITY AND IMPOSE RENT
CONTROL, RENT CONTROL THROUGH
THE BALLOT. AS WE SAW IN CITIES
LIKE BERKELEY AND SANTA MONICA
PRIOR TO COSTA-HAWKINS, STRICT
RENT CONTROL LED TO A DECREASE
IN RENTAL UNITS AND HARM THE
VERY PEOPLE IT WAS INTENDED TO
PROTECT. THIS IS THE VERY REASON
THAT THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
PASSED COSTA-HAWKINS STUDIES AT
THE TIME DEMONSTRATED THAT
STRICT RENT CONTROL CITIES LIKE
BERKELEY AND SANTA MONICA HAD
LOST CERTAIN TYPES OF
POPULATIONS. BOTH THE YOUNG AND
ELDERLY POPULATIONS HAD DECLINED
IN THOSE CITIES. THE POPULATION
FOR WHICH RENT CONTROL WAS
DESIGNED TO ADDRESS WAS
RECEIVING MINIMAL BENEFITS FROM
THE POLICY, AND THE POPULATIONS
APPEARED TO HAVE MIGRATED OUT OF
THE CITIES TO NEIGHBORING CITIES
WITHOUT RENT CONTROL, AND IN
FACT, IGNORING THESE STUDIES,
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OF SAN
FRANCISCO RECENTLY ANNOUNCED
THAT IF PROPOSITION 33 PASSES,
IT WILL OPPOSE IMPOSE RENT
CONTROL ON ALL PROPERTIES. NEW
CONSTRUCTION UP TO NOVEMBER
2024. THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT
HOUSING CONSTRUCTION WILL COME
TO A HALT IN SAN FRANCISCO. AND
IF PROPOSITION 33 PASSES
NUMEROUS LOCAL ORDINANCES ARE
CURRENTLY WRITTEN IN SUCH A WAY
THAT THEY WILL AUTOMATICALLY
EXPAND THEIR LOCAL RENT CONTROL
TO INCLUDE SINGLE FAMILY HOMES
AND NEWER CONSTRUCTION,
INCLUDING VACANCY CONTROL. I
WOULD SAY THAT CALIFORNIA IS
UNIQUE FROM OTHER STATES. OVER
60% OF OUR RENTAL HOUSING ARE
SMALL, MEANING LESS THAN TEN
UNITS AND HALF OF THOSE RENTAL
UNITS ARE IN SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES. THESE ARE THE EASIEST TO
TAKE OFF THE MARKET.
UNFORTUNATELY, THIS HAPPENED
PRIOR TO COSTA-HAWKINS IN THE
CITIES OF SANTA MONICA AND
BERKELEY UNDER BERKELEY'S RENT
CONTROL, THE CITY HAD LOST OVER
3500 UNITS IN THE FIRST YEAR OF
ITS RENT. FIRST YEARS OF ITS
LOCAL RENT CONTROL, AND IT WAS
ONLY AFTER COSTA-HAWKINS THAT
THE RENTAL UNITS CAME BACK
ONLINE AND BUILDING PERMITS
INCREASED. CALIFORNIA'S
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS IS
COMES FROM A LACK OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING, NOT A LACK OF RENT
CONTROL, AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT WE ALREADY HAVE RENT
CAPS WITH AB 1482, WHICH IMPOSE
RENT CAPS ON NEWER CONSTRUCTION,
AS WELL AS SINGLE FAMILY HOMES
OWNED BY LARGER OWNERS. IT
INCLUDES JUST CAUSE EVICTION AS
WELL AND ALLOWS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO CONTINUE TO
IMPOSE JUST CAUSE EVICTION AT A
MORE STRINGENT LEVEL. WE DON'T
NEED MORE STRINGENT RENT CONTROL
IN CALIFORNIA. THE ANSWER TO OUR
HOUSING CRISIS IS NOT PUNITIVE
REGULATORY ACTIONS ON RENTAL
PROPERTY OWNERS, BUT POLICIES
THAT INCENTIVIZE CONSTRUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. PROPOSITION
33 DOES NOTHING TO BUILD NEW
HOUSING OR ENCOURAGE IT. IT DOES
NOT PROTECT LOW INCOME RENTERS
OR ADDRESS OUR HOMELESSNESS
POPULATION. INSTEAD, IT WOULD
EXACERBATE THE VERY PROBLEMS IT
CLAIMS TO SOLVE. THAT'S THE
REASON WHY WE OPPOSE PROPOSITION
33. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT. NEXT WE'LL GO
TO MR. CURTIN. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN. SENATOR WAHAB,
PLEASURE. I'LL SPEAK TO THE
VIEWING PUBLIC AS WELL, IF YOU
DON'T MIND. MY NAME IS DANNY
CURTIN. I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONFERENCE OF CARPENTERS AND
LITERALLY EVERY CONVERSATION,
HEARING TESTIMONY, I'VE STARTED
WITH THE SAME SORT OF PHRASE,
AND I'M GOING TO READ IT TO YOU.
BASICALLY, LACK OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND THE CRISIS OF
HOMELESSNESS IS THE SINGLE MOST
DESTABILIZING ECONOMIC, SOCIAL,
AND POLITICAL ISSUE IN
CALIFORNIA. THERE'S NO QUESTION
ABOUT THE ANGER THAT WE'RE
SEEING. I'M GOING TO GET INTO A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT. BUT WHAT
I REALIZED TODAY LISTENING TO
THIS DEBATE, THIS IS WHY YOU'RE
GETTING PAID THE BIG BUCKS TO
TRY TO SORT THIS OUT. JUST A
LITTLE MINOR PROBLEM AMONG MANY
YOU FACE. CALIFORNIANS SPEND THE
SECOND HIGHEST PERCENTAGE OF
THEIR INCOME ON RENT, SECOND
ONLY TO HAWAII. I CAN RECALL
DRIVING HOME FROM WORK ONE DAY
FOUR BLOCKS AWAY. I WAS A LITTLE
CONFUSED. I SAW A SINGLE WOMAN
WITH A PILE OF CLOTHES IN THE
BACK OF HER CAR PARK, UNTIL THE
TWO KIDS RAN. LITTLE KIDS RAN
INTO HER CAR. I REALIZED SHE WAS
LIVING IN HER CAR WITH THE
LITTLE CHILDREN. ON TOP OF THAT
WORKING CLASS FAMILIES EVEN
UNIONIZED CARPENTERS, THEY'RE IN
FEAR THAT THEY ARE ONE PAYCHECK
AWAY FROM LOSING THEIR HOME.
THEY ARE AFRAID FOR THEIR KIDS.
I HAVE TWO ADULT CHILDREN, 35
YEARS OLD. ABOUT I DON'T KNOW
HOW THEY'RE GOING TO SURVIVE IN
THIS HOUSING MARKET. IT IS
REALLY COMPLICATED MAKING PEOPLE
ANGRY. HOMES ARE OUT OF THE
REACH FOR ALL BUT THE
WEALTHIEST. POVERTY IS NO LONGER
INVISIBLE. IT'S IN OUR FACE AND
THE HOUSING CRISIS IS WHAT MAKES
IT THAT WAY. IN THE RICHEST
STATE IN THE RICHEST COUNTRY IN
THE WORLD, IT CAN NO LONGER BE
IGNORED. IT HASN'T BEEN IGNORED.
BY THE WAY, IT'S TRAGIC AND IT'S
SHAMEFUL. AND IN MY HEART, I
WOULD HAVE PREFERRED TO BE ON
THE FIRST PANEL IF I THOUGHT IT
WOULD WORK. I WOULD HAVE BEEN ON
THE FIRST PANEL, BUT I DON'T
BELIEVE IT WILL. THIS PROFOUND
HUMAN CRISIS HAS BEEN A MAJOR
FOCUS OF THE LEGISLATURE, SO THE
IMPLICATIONS WERE THAT YOU ALL
WEREN'T TRYING TO DO YOUR JOB
AND I'VE WATCHED IT OVER THE
YEARS. YOU ARE DOING MORE THAN
YOU POSSIBLY CAN. I MEAN, YOU'RE
TRYING EVERYTHING YOU CAN
BECAUSE YOU GOT TO GO HOME TO
YOUR CONSTITUENTS, NOT JUST IN
THE LAST FEW YEARS, BUT FOR
DECADES. COSTA-HAWKINS HAS BEEN
REFERENCED NUMEROUS TIMES,
HUNDREDS OF BILLS JUST IN THIS
SESSION, PROBABLY 70, 50 BILLS,
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF
HEARINGS, STAKEHOLDERS
CONVERSATIONS. THAT'S NOT WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN PROPOSITION 33.
IT'S NOT TO FIX IT. AS I THINK
SENATOR ASHBY WAS INDICATING OR
SENATOR ROTH, THAT IT COULD BE
FIXED. NO, IT'S ON THE BALLOT
THE WAY IT IS. THE BILLS, SUCH
AS THE ONE YOU MENTIONED,
ASSEMBLYMAN CHIU, NOW CITY
ATTORNEY AB 2011, SENATOR HUESO,
WHICH WE CO-SPONSORED 2243 THIS
YEAR, WHICH WE CO-SPONSORED.
SENATOR WIENER'S SB 35 AND IS
FOR 23 THIS YEAR, WHICH WE
CO-SPONSORED. SENATOR ATKINS, I
THINK IT WAS SB NINE. THIS HAS
BEEN A STRUGGLE AND A
COMPLICATED CONVERSATION AROUND
ALL THESE BILLS TO SOLVE THE
ISSUES THAT YOU'VE BEEN. SO I
THINK, ELOQUENTLY OUTLINING,
AFTER ALL, THAT ONE ENTITY, THE
CALIFORNIA AIDS FOUNDATION, HAS
FOUND THE MAGIC FORMULA, THE 23
WORDS THAT WERE READ EARLIER
TODAY. IT'S SO SIMPLE. THE REAL
QUESTION IS, HOW DID WE ALL MISS
THIS? HOW DID YOU ALL MISS THIS?
IN THE HUNDREDS OF HEARINGS
YOU'VE HAD, THE BILLS YOU'VE
DEALT WITH? I WANT TO
PERSONALIZE IT FOR A MINUTE
BECAUSE A CLOSE FRIEND OF MINE
WHO I CONSIDER VERY SMART AND
POLITICALLY A VERY STRATEGIC
PERSON, TOLD ME HE SUPPORTS PROP
33 BECAUSE IT SENDS A STRONG
MESSAGE AND STICKS IT TO THE
GREEDY DEVELOPERS BECAUSE
HOUSING COSTS ARE OUT OF
CONTROL. DON'T LISTEN FOR A
SECOND. I TRULY SYMPATHIZE WITH
THAT COMPLETELY. THAT SENTIMENT.
SO WHY AM I HERE? WHY AM I AT
THIS TABLE? AND WHY ARE THE
CARPENTERS IN THIS COALITION? BY
THE WAY, SENATOR HOLMBERG, IF
YOU HAVE A CELL PHONE, COULD YOU
TAKE A SNAP OF THIS? BECAUSE IT
REALLY IS AN INTERESTING THING
TO BE SEEN AT A HEARING. FORGIVE
ME. I'M. MR. CURTIN, YOU'VE BEEN
AT THIS TOO LONG ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. BUT THIS PARTICULAR
TESTIMONY. NO, NO, JUST THANK
YOU. SO BECAUSE PROP 30. PROP
33, IN SPITE OF HOW APPEALING IT
SOUNDS, IT CAN BE USED TO
UNDERMINE VIRTUALLY ALL THE WORK
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE AND THIS
GOVERNOR HAVE DONE, PARTICULARLY
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS, TO
CAJOLE, TO CONVINCE, TO DEMAND
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BUILD
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IF
PEOPLE COULD MAKE MONEY BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING, WE WOULDN'T
BE HERE TALKING ABOUT IT. THEY
CAN MAKE MONEY ON MARKET
HOUSING. GO HAVE IT. IF YOU WANT
TO TALK ABOUT WELL, ANYWAY, I'M
GOING TO QUOTE A FEW THINGS. THE
PROMISE OF AGGRESSIVE RENT
CONTROL, ALLEVIATING THE
PRESSURE OF CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
CRISIS IS SEDUCTIVE. I LOVE THAT
PROP 33 PROMISES A SOLUTION TO
THE HOUSING CRISIS. IT WOULD
ALMOST CERTAINLY MAKE THINGS
WORSE. SAN FRANCISCO CHRONICLE
AND I HAVE YOUNG ADULTS LIVING
AT HOME, AND IT REALLY IS
SEDUCTIVE. WHAT'S WRONG WITH
THIS QUOTE? AGAIN, RENT CONTROL
DISCOURAGES INVESTMENT IN NEW
HOUSING, CONSTRAINING SUPPLY AND
DRIVING UP OVERALL HOUSING
COSTS. MERCURY NEWS QUOTE
STUDIES SHOW THAT ROBUST HOUSING
SUPPLY, NOT RENT CONTROL, IS THE
MOST ESSENTIAL FACTOR IN KEEPING
HOUSING PRICES DOWN. AND THEN
EXAMPLES OF CITIES AND DIFFERENT
PLACES WHERE IT ACTUALLY HAS
SUCCEEDED. I'M NOT SAYING IT'S
COMPLETELY THE ANSWER. THAT'S A
CHRONICLE EDITORIAL Tê AS MUCH
AS I WANT TO BELIEVE THAT PROP
3323 WORD PRESCRIPTION, IT'S
OBVIOUS TO ME. UNFORTUNATELY,
EITHER BY DESIGN OR A SINCERE
CARELESSNESS, IT'S A CLASSIC
BAIT AND SWITCH LOCAL. AND NOW
THAT WAS A THAT WAS A QUOTE.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS COULD MORE
LIKELY WILL EXPLOIT THAT SIMPLE
PROP 33 LANGUAGE TO MAKE IT
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO BUILD NEW
HOUSING. NOT ALL SELECT QUOTE
HUNTINGTON BEACH HAS ALREADY
ANNOUNCED ITS INTENTIONS TO USE
THE LANGUAGE IN PROP 33 TO
IMPOSE STEEP AFFORDABILITY
REQUIREMENTS ON PROJECTS
AFFECTING EFFECTIVELY, MAKING IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR THEM TO PENCIL
OUT AND HALTING NEW DEVELOPMENT.
ANOTHER QUOTE STATEWIDE RENT
CONTROL IS A LUDICROUS IDEA, BUT
THE MEASURE'S LANGUAGE GOES
FURTHER. TONY STRICKLAND,
HUNTINGTON BEACH COUNCIL MEMBER,
SAID AT A COUNCIL MEETING IN
MARCH I'M SURE YOU ALL REMEMBER
TONY QUOTE. IT GIVES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IRONCLAD PROTECTIONS
FROM THE STATE'S HOUSING POLICY.
STRICKLAND SAID WEINSTEIN'S RENT
CONTROL MEASURE WOULD BLOCK THE
STATE'S ABILITY TO SUE OUR CITY
BECAUSE HUNTINGTON BEACH COULD
SLAP STEEP AFFORDABILITY
REQUIREMENTS ON NEW MULTI-UNIT
APARTMENT PROJECTS THAT ARE NOW
EXEMPT FROM RENT CONTROL, SUCH
REQUIREMENTS, HE ARGUED, COULD
STOP DEVELOPMENT THAT WOULD
DESTROY THE FABRIC OF THE TOWNS.
QUOTE QUAINT SURF CITY VIBE.
ASSUMING WHAT EVERYBODY WANTS
THESE HOUSING UNITS IN THE LOW
INCOME AREA. YEAH, THAT MIGHT
WORK, BUT THEY DON'T. THAT'S
BEEN THE PROBLEM FOR DECADES AND
DECADES AND DECADES. ON PAPER,
THIS IS ANOTHER QUOTE. IT WOULD
BE LEGAL TO BUILD NEW HOMES,
WOULD IT WOULD BE ILLEGAL,
LARGELY SPEAKING, TO MAKE MONEY
DOING SO, SAID LUIS MORANTE,
VICE PRESIDENT OF PUBLIC POLICY
AT THE BAY AREA COUNCIL, A
PRO-BUSINESS ADVOCACY GROUP THAT
OPPOSES THE MEASURE. THAT WAS
FROM POLITICO. IT'S NOT HARD TO
IMAGINE THAT PROPOSITION 33 WILL
BE USED IN THE MOST CYNICAL
FASHION BY COMMUNITIES THAT WANT
TO STOP AFFORDABLE AND LOW
INCOME HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
PROPOSITION 33 WILL GIVE THEM
THE TOOL TO DO IT IN SPITE OF
ALL THE GOOD INTENTIONS THAT I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH, THAT WE
HEARD ABOUT THE CARPENTERS UNION
IS ESSENTIALLY A JOBS
ORGANIZATION THAT'S WHY WE ARE
AT THIS TABLE IN THIS UNUSUAL
ALLIANCE. WE BELIEVE WE CAN
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE, THIS ISSUE,
BY BUILDING MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. BUT WE ARE ALSO AWARE
THAT WAGES AND WORKING
CONDITIONS FOR CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY WORKERS IN THE HOUSING
INDUSTRY ARE THE WORST IN THE
INDUSTRY. BEAR WITH ME. MY
PARTNERS. CALIFORNIA'S MEDIAN
CONSTRUCTION PAY RANKS 46TH IN
THE UNITED STATES, THE RESULT OF
A DECADES LONG FREEFALL IN THE
HOUSING CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY.
SOUNDS A LITTLE ODD CONSIDERING
WE HAVE A HEALTHY, UNIONIZED
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY AS WELL,
BUT WE RANK 46TH IN WAGES. THAT
SOUNDS INCREDIBLY LOW. HERE'S
WHY. ABOUT HALF OF CALIFORNIA'S
CONSTRUCTION WORKFORCE ALMOST
400,000 WORKERS, IS CLASSIFIED
AS LOW. VERY LOW OR EXTREMELY
LOW INCOME. THAT'S THE CENSUS
BUREAU IN 2017, 400,000 WORKERS
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA ARE
ENROLLED IN SAFETY PROGRAMS.
SAFETY SUPPORT PROGRAMS COSTING
OVER $3 BILLION. THIS ANNUAL
PUBLIC SUBSIDY IS DUE TO THE LOW
WAGE, OFTEN EXPLOITATIVE
RESIDENTIAL CONSTRUCTION SECTOR.
UC BERKELEY 2021 1 IN 6
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE IN THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY. EITHER
UNDERREPORTED OR MISCLASSIFIED.
SINKING UNDERGROUND REPORT 2014.
THAT'S TEN YEARS AGO. WAGE THEFT
IN THE HOUSING CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY WAS REPORTED AS
RAMPANT. CALIFORNIA BUREAU OF
FIELD ENFORCEMENT 2018 ONE THIRD
OF THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S
POSITIONS ARE VACANT. 900 MORE
ARE NEEDED. A DIR DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS AUDIT
REPORTED IN THE L.A. TIMES IN LA
TIMES, JUNE 24TH. IT IS A MAJOR
CRISIS. IT IS COMPLICATED. I
PERSONALLY WANT TO THANK THIS
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR FOR
UNDERSTANDING THE CONNECTION
THAT THE HOUSING CRISIS AND THE
LOW WAGE CONDITIONS, NOT JUST IN
THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY, BUT
DEFINITELY IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY, ARE THE FLIP SIDE OF
THE SAME COIN. LOW WAGE WORKERS
IN THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
CANNOT AFFORD THE LOW WAGE UNITS
THEY'RE ACTUALLY BUILDING. WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT STABILITY, IS
WHAT'S REALLY NEEDED. THAT'S
ANOTHER WAY OF SAYING
AFFORDABILITY. IF YOU HAVE
MONEY, YOU ARE STABLE. YOU CAN
AFFORD TO LIVE PLACES IF YOU
DON'T HAVE MONEY. THANK YOU, MR.
CURTIN. ONE MINUTE. LET ME WRAP
UP ONE. WE'LL GIVE YOU ONE
SENTENCE, OKAY. ALL RIGHT. WITH
THIS COALITION, WITH THE
LEGISLATURE, WE CAN BUILD OUR
WAY OUT OF THE HOUSING CRISIS.
IF WE WORK TOGETHER. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GOVERNOR SUPPORTS IT.
TONY ATKINS SUPPORTS IT. I MEAN,
OPPOSE IT. SENATOR WIENER
OPPOSES IT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS OPPOSES PROP 33. THESE ARE
ALL THE PEOPLE WHO ARE PRO
HOUSING AND HAVE PUSHED THE
AGENDA. ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. CURTIN. ALL RIGHT. MR.
WAGLE. SO THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR, AND MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS SANJAY WAGLEY. I'M
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS. I COME HERE TODAY TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
PROPOSITION 33, WHICH BY
ALLOWING FOR PERMITTING FOR THE
ENACTMENT OF EXTREME FORMS OF
RENT CONTROL WITHOUT
RESTRICTION, WOULD HAVE A
DEVASTATING EFFECT ON OUR
HOUSING MARKET AND ON BOTH
HOUSING PROVIDERS AND TENANTS.
AS A RESULT, THERE HAS
CONSISTENTLY BEEN SUPPORTING
STATE LEGISLATION WHICH WOULD
ALLEVIATE OUR HOUSING CRISIS BY
MAKING IT EASIER TO BUILD MORE
HOUSING, BOTH RENTAL AND
HOMEOWNERSHIP. HOUSING. WE NEED
HOUSING OF EVERY KIND AT EVERY
LEVEL. STATE LEGISLATION BEING
NECESSARY, IN PART BECAUSE IT'S
A RECOGNITION OF THE FACT THAT
MANY LOCAL JURISDICTIONS,
UNFORTUNATELY, RESIST THE
DEVELOPMENT OF NEW HOUSING OF
ALL KINDS. AGAIN, MARKET RATE OR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. LOCAL AREAS
RESIST HOUSING, EXTREME RENT
CONTROL OF THE KIND THAT COULD
AND WOULD LIKELY GO FORWARD IF
COSTA-HAWKINS WAS REPEALED WOULD
BE DEVASTATING TO THE
CONSTRUCTION OF NEW HOUSING.
RENT CONTROL UNDER COSTA-HAWKINS
CANNOT CURRENTLY APPLY TO NEW
CONSTRUCTION. RECENT STUDIES A
RECENT EXAMPLE OUT OF THE SAINT
PAUL AREA IN 2021, IT PASSED ONE
OF THE STRICTEST RENT CONTROL
ORDINANCES IN THE NATION, WITH
NO EXEMPTION FOR NEW
CONSTRUCTION AS WELL AS OTHER
FORMS OF EXTREME RENT CONTROL,
WHICH WOULD BE PERMISSIBLE UNDER
THE UNDER IF COSTA-HAWKINS WAS
REPEALED. DEVELOPMENT PERMITS
FELL BY 48% IN SAINT PAUL,
CONTRASTING BY ITS TWIN CITY,
MINNEAPOLIS SAW AN INCREASE IN
BUILDING PERMITS AROUND THE SAME
TIME. SAINT PAUL SUBSEQUENTLY
NEEDED TO THEN AMEND THEIR RENT
CONTROL LAW. THIS EXTREME RENT
CONTROL POWER THAT WOULD BE NOW
AVAILABLE TO CITIES IF
COSTA-HAWKINS WAS REPEALED,
COULD ALSO BE USED EASILY BY
THOSE WHO WISH TO THWART
DEVELOPMENT. MY CO-PRESENTER
FROM THE CARPENTERS MENTIONED
THE CITY OF HUNTINGTON,
HUNTINGTON BEACH, WHERE CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER EXPRESSLY
MENTIONED INITIALLY HIS SUPPORT
FOR THIS MEASURE BECAUSE OF THE
WAY IT COULD BE USED TO THWART
DEVELOPMENT. STRAIGHT REPEAL
WILL ALSO LIKELY FURTHER LIMIT
THE SUPPLY OF HOMES FOR RENT. AS
HAS BEEN POINTED OUT, CALIFORNIA
HAS A SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGE OF
SMALL OWNERS OF PROPERTY AND
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES AS RENTALS
PROP 33 WOULD NOW PERMIT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO IMPOSE RENT
CONTROL ON ALL SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES, NOT JUST CORPORATE OWNED,
BUT ALL SINGLE FAMILY HOMES, AS
WELL AS IMPOSING VACANCY
DECONTROL. THIS WILL RESULT IN
MANY OWNERS OPTING NOT TO RENT
THEIR PROPERTIES, AS THEY DO NOT
HAVE A LARGE PORTFOLIO OF
PROPERTIES TO SPREAD RISKS OR
COSTS AROUND, RESULTING IN THEM
SELLING THEM TO EITHER PERSONS
WHO WOULD OCCUPY THOSE PROPERTY
OR POSSIBLY TO LARGE CORPORATE
OWNERS AND REGARDING THE ISSUE
OF THE RATE OF RETURN, THE
CONSTITUTION DOES HAVE A
REQUIREMENT THAT DOES MANDATE A
RATE OF RETURN. BUT IT DOES NOT
MANDATE A SPECIFIC FORMULA. THAT
IS A FORMULA WHICH HAS BEEN
LITIGATED IN THE PAST BY A LARGE
CORPORATE ENTITIES MIGHT BE ABLE
TO MAKE THAT LITIGATION DECISION.
IF A IF A RENT CONTROL BOARD
OPTED TO INSTITUTE A RATE OF
RETURN THAT WAS NOT FAVORABLE,
THE PROCESS OF LITIGATION AND
THE TIME FRAME THAT THAT COULD
INVOLVE IN CONTESTING THAT WOULD
REQUIRE WOULD FOR A SMALL
LANDLORD, BE ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE
AND WOULD LIKELY RESULT IN THE
SALE OF THEIR PROPERTY. THERE
HAVE BEEN STUDIES OUT OF SAN
FRANCISCO, SAN FRANCISCO WITH
SAN FRANCISCO'S RENT CONTROL
THAT WAS PUBLISHED BY THE
AMERICAN ECONOMIC REVIEW IN
2019, WHICH WHICH DID STATE THAT
RENT CONTROL DOES APPEAR TO HELP
THE AFFORDABILITY IN THE SHORT
RUN FOR THE CURRENT TENANTS.
HOWEVER, OVER TIME IT RESULTED
IN A DECREASE IN OVERALL
AFFORDABILITY AND FUELED
GENTRIFICATION. AND ANYONE WHO'S
FAMILIAR WITH OUR RENT CONTROL
CITIES HAS SEEN CONSISTENTLY
INCREASING RENTS AS WELL AS
DECREASING AFFORDABILITY AND
CHANGES IN THE COMPOSITION OF
NEIGHBORHOODS, REGARDLESS OF
EXISTING RENT CONTROL. THE
RESULTS BASED ON THIS STUDY
SUGGEST THAT THESE TYPES OF
MEASURES, THESE TYPES OF RENT
CONTROL MEASURES, ARE
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE IN THE LONG
RUN, AND THAT THERE MIGHT BE
BETTER WAYS OF GOVERNMENT WISHES
TO HELP PROTECT TENANTS SUCH AS
VOUCHERS. OTHER TYPES OF
SUBSIDIES. SUBSIDIES DIRECTLY TO
TENANTS RATHER THAN USING THE
RENT CONTROL AS A MEASURE THAT
WOULD ALSO ENSURE THAT RENT
CONTROL MEASURES THAT HAVE
ECONOMIC EFFECTS, WHICH ARE
BROADER THAN PROTECTING THOSE
TENANTS WHO ARE VULNERABLE,
WOULD BE TARGETED TOWARD THOSE
VULNERABLE TENANTS, AS OPPOSED
TO THE ONE THIRD OF CALIFORNIA
RENTERS WHO DO IN FACT EARN OVER
$100,000, WHILE GROUPS SUCH AS
OURS DO OPPOSE RENT CONTROL. WE
AND CIA BACK IN 1995 DID SUPPORT
COSTA-HAWKINS, WHICH ALLOWS
WHICH ALLOWS LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
TO ACTUALLY ENACT RENT CONTROL
ORDINANCES, BUT TRIES TO PREVENT
LOCAL RENT CONTROL OR RENT
CONTROLS FROM HAVING THE TYPES
OF DEVASTATING EFFECTS WHICH
COULD HAPPEN FROM MORE EXTREME
FORMS OF RENT CONTROL. PROP 33
IS THE OPPOSITE OF A CONSIDERED
MEASURE. IT OPENS THE FLOODGATES
TO EXTREME MEASURES THAT COULD
DEVASTATE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT IN
CALIFORNIA, AND FOR THIS REASON,
WE OPPOSE IT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT, MR. CAÑADA. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS KURT NETTO
AND I'M A BOARD MEMBER OF AND
COUNSEL TO THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE, THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HAS MORE THAN 13,000 MEMBERS,
BOTH INDIVIDUAL AND CORPORATE,
REPRESENTING 25% OF THE STATE'S
PRIVATE WORKFORCE IN VIRTUALLY
EVERY ECONOMIC INTEREST IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WHILE CAL
CHAMBER REPRESENTS SEVERAL OF
THE LARGEST CORPORATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA, 70% OF ITS MEMBERS
HAVE FEWER THAN 100 EMPLOYEES.
CAL CHAMBER BELIEVES THAT A
BALANCE BETWEEN JOBS AND HOUSING
IS VITAL TO CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY. CAL CHAMBER OPPOSES
PROPOSITION 33 DUE TO THE
DEVASTATING EFFECTS IT WOULD
HAVE ON HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA
AND OUR STATE ECONOMY. AS A
WHOLE. THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF
RENT CONTROL ARE WELL KNOWN, ARE
WELL KNOWN, AS OTHER WITNESSES
HERE HAVE ABLY EXPLAINED, RENT
CONTROL MEASURES ACCELERATE
ATTRITION OF THE EXISTING
HOUSING STOCK OF RENTAL UNITS IN
THE MARKETPLACE, AND NUMEROUS
STUDIES HAVE FOUND THAT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WITH STRINGENT
RENT CONTROL POLICIES HAVE LOST
LARGE NUMBERS OF RENTAL UNITS.
THAT'S THE LAST THING WE NEED
FOR CALIFORNIA. HOWEVER, THE
DAMAGE THAT PROP 33 WOULD CAUSE
WOULD GO MUCH DEEPER THAN THAT.
I THINK WE'VE HAD A LOT OF
DISCUSSION TODAY ABOUT THE
REPEAL OF COSTA-HAWKINS. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT IN
THOSE 23 WORDS THAT OTHERS HAVE
REFERENCED, THERE'S ACTUALLY AN
AFFIRMATIVE NEW SECTION ENACTED
BY PROPOSITION 33. IT'S SECTION
1954 .40 OF THE CIVIL CODE, AND
IT SAYS THAT THE STATE MAY NOT
LIMIT THE RIGHT OF ANY CITY,
COUNTY OR CITY AND COUNTY TO
MAINTAIN, ENACT, OR EXPAND
RESIDENTIAL RENT CONTROL. SO NOT
ONLY DOES PROP 33 REPEAL
COSTA-HAWKINS, IT ALSO REPEALS
THE RIGHT OF THIS LEGISLATURE TO
LIMIT RENT CONTROL POLICIES IN
THE FUTURE IN PERPETUITY.
THERE'S NO ABILITY TO AMEND THIS
MEASURE. WITHOUT GOING BACK TO
THE VOTERS. I'D LIKE TO FOCUS ON
THAT AND EXPAND UPON A FEW OF
THE POINTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
HERE, AND ALSO RESPOND TO SOME
OF SENATOR ROTH'S COMMENTS AND
SOME OF THE EXCHANGE ABOUT THE
FAIR RATE OF RETURN. IN RECENT
YEARS, THE LEGISLATURE HAS TAKEN
MAJOR STEPS TO ADDRESS OUR
HOUSING SUPPLY CRISIS THROUGH
THE ENACTMENT OF A NUMBER OF
STATUTES WHICH HAVE BEEN
MENTIONED HERE THOSE INCLUDING
SB NINE, THE ADI, THE ADU BILL,
SB 423 BY WIENER, SB 91 BY THE
CHAIRMAN, UMBERG AB, 2011 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS. WE'VE
ALSO TALKED ABOUT HOW AB 1485
AND AB 434 GIVE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
THE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT,
DEPARTMENT MORE AUTHORITY TO
ENFORCE THOSE NEW STATE LAWS,
THOSE HOUSING LAWS ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND MAKE SURE
THEY'RE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
UNFORTUNATELY, PROP 33 WOULD
UNRAVEL ALL OF THOSE EFFORTS.
THIS IS DUE TO THE FACT THAT, AT
ITS CORE, FROM A LEGAL
PERSPECTIVE, PROPOSITION 33 IS
REALLY A SNEAK ATTACK ON THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO
DICTATE HOUSING POLICIES TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. AND AS I
MENTIONED, BECAUSE PROP 33
GRANTS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AN
UNQUALIFIED RIGHT TO IMPOSE ANY
AND EVERY TYPE OF RENT CONTROL
POLICY THROUGH THE REPEAL OF THE
COSTA-HAWKINS LAW, AND THEN
EXPRESSLY PROHIBITS THE STATE
FROM EVEN IMPOSING A LIMIT ON
THE TYPES OF RENT CONTROL
POLICIES THAT LOCALS CAN ENACT,
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN SIMPLY
IMPOSE RENT CONTROL LIMITS ON
UNWANTED PROJECTS THAT ARE SO
SEVERE IT BECOMES FINANCIALLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO COMPLETE THE
PROJECT. THIS WILL WORSEN
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CRISIS AND
EFFECTIVELY PUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, ITS EXECUTIVE
BRANCH, AND ITS LEGISLATIVE
BRANCH OUT OF THE BUSINESS OF
REGULATING HOUSING AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. EVEN IF STATE LAW
MANDATES THAT A CERTAIN TYPE OF
DEVELOPMENT IS LEGALLY
PERMISSIBLE. BECAUSE PROP 33
ALLOWS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO MAKE
THE REALIZATION OF THAT
DEVELOPMENT ECONOMICALLY
IMPOSSIBLE. AND THIS IS NOT JUST
A THEORETICAL THREAT. WE'VE
HEARD ABOUT HUNTING THE CITY OF
HUNTINGTON BEACH AND THEIR
INTENTIONS GOING FORWARD. THIS
IS ACTUALLY ALREADY HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW. THE CITIES OF
CAMARILLO, DANA POINT AND TEMPLE
CITY ALL IMPOSE RENT CONTROL
POLICIES. AFTER THE ENACTMENT OF
SB NINE, JUST ON ADUS IN THOSE
JURISDICTIONS. AND LUCKILY, THE
HCD CURRENTLY HAS AUTHORITY TO
REGULATE LOCAL RENT CONTROL
POLICIES TO MAKE SURE THEY DON'T
INTERFERE WITH THE LAWS AND
POLICIES ENACTED BY THIS BODY.
TO EXPAND THE AMOUNT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA. AND HERE'S A LETTER
FROM HCD TO THE CITY OF DANA
POINT, AND IT TELLS THEM THAT
UNDER STATE LAW, THEY ARE
INTERFERING WITH SB NINE AND THE
ADU LAW BECAUSE THEIR RENT
CONTROL POLICY, WHICH THEY ONLY
IMPOSED ON SB NINE ADUS, MAKES
THE CONSTRUCTION OF THOSE UNITS.
AND THE IMPLEMENTATION OF SB
NINE. I QUOTE ECONOMICALLY
INFEASIBLE. SO WHAT THE CITY DID
WAS THEY IMPOSE A RENT CONTROL
LAW SO ONEROUS ON THOSE ADUS
THAT IT MADE IT ECONOMICALLY
UNVIABLE TO BUILD THOSE UNITS,
MAKING SURE THAT THE SB NINE
POLICY IN THEIR JURISDICTIONS
ESSENTIALLY WOULDN'T APPLY. IT
APPLIES LEGALLY. THEY CAN MAKE
SURE THAT IT WOULDN'T APPLY
ECONOMICALLY, THAT THAT ABILITY
TO DO THAT WILL SPREAD TO EVERY
CITY AND COUNTY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA UNDER PROP 33, AND
HCD WILL NO LONGER BE ABLE TO
SEND OUT THESE LETTERS BECAUSE
THESE LIMIT THE AUTHORITY OF A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO IMPOSE RENT
CONTROL, IT EXPRESSLY LIMITED
DANA POINT, CAMARILLO AND TEMPLE
CITY. THIS WILL NO LONGER HAPPEN
IF PROP 33 PASSES, NOR CAN IT BE
CREDIBLY CLAIMED THAT THIS
CONSEQUENCE OF PROP 33 IS
ACCIDENTAL OR UNINTENTIONAL. THE
CHIEF FINANCIAL BACKER OF PROP
33, THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION, HAS A LONG HISTORY
OF SUPPORTING NIMBY, NIMBY
POLICIES AND ATTACKING PRO
HOUSING LAWS. I'LL HIT A COUPLE
OF THE HIGHLIGHTS IN 2022, RF
FILED A LAWSUIT SEEKING TO
PROHIBIT THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
FROM AMENDING ITS ZONING LAWS TO
ALLOW FOR MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN 2021, RF FILED A
LAWSUIT AGAINST SENATOR WIENER'S
SB TEN, WHICH ALSO ALLOWED FOR
MORE SINGLE FAMILY HOUSING TO BE
BUILT NEAR TRANSIT AND JOBS IN
URBAN INFILL AREAS. IN 2021, RF
SUPPORTED A CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT THAT WAS THAT DID NOT
MAKE THE BALLOT, BUT WHICH
SOUGHT TO TAKE AWAY THIS
LEGISLATURE'S ABILITY TO SET TO
OVERRIDE LOCAL ZONING LAWS. IN
2019, RF LED THE EFFORT TO KILL
SENATOR WIENER'S SB 50, WHICH
WOULD LEGALIZE MORE HOUSING NEAR
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION. OKAY,
LET'S LET'S FOCUS ON PROP 33.
SURE. OKAY. I'LL CLOSE BY BY
WITH A QUOTE FROM SENATOR WIENER
THAT THAT RF IS CALIFORNIA'S
NIMBY IN CHIEF. OKAY, WAIT A
MINUTE. LET'S LET'S FOCUS ON
PROP 30. SO WHAT PROP 33 DOES,
IS IT IT ALLOWS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO STRANGLE THE
ECONOMIC VIABILITY OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THAT THEY DON'T WANT ON
A PROJECT BY PROJECT BASIS? HOW
CAN THEY DO THAT? AND HOW DOES
THAT HOW DOES THAT INTERPLAY
WITH THE RIGHT OF FAIR RETURN,
THE RIGHT OF FAIR RETURN DOES
NOT GUARANTEE THE RIGHT TO MAKE
MONEY FROM ANY PARTICULAR USE OF
THE PROPERTY. IT'S PART OF THE
TAKINGS DOCTRINE. AND YOU JUST
THE, THE STATE, THE GOVERNMENT
HAS TO ALLOW PROPERTY OWNERS TO
MAKE A REASONABLE RATE OF
RETURN, BUT IT DOES NOT
GUARANTEE ANY SPECIFIC USE. SO
LET'S LET'S THINK ABOUT AB 2011
THAT ALLOWS FOR CONVERSION OF
COMMERCIAL PROPERTIES INTO
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES. SO IF
YOU HAVE A STRIP MALL AND YOU
WANT TO CONVERT IT INTO A
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT, A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CAN IMPOSE A SEVERE
RENT CONTROL POLICY ON ANY
RESIDENTIAL UNITS BUILT ON THAT.
THAT PLOT, THERE'S NO RECOURSE
UNDER THE TAKINGS DOCTRINE OR
THE RIGHT OF FAIR RETURN,
BECAUSE THE OWNER CAN STILL USE
THE PROPERTY PRODUCTIVELY AS A
COMMERCIAL PROPERTY, AS A, AS A,
AS A STRIP MALL OR AS AN OFFICE
BUILDING. SO THERE IS NO WAY OUT
LEGALLY, THE IDEA THAT THERE IS
SOMEHOW GOING TO BE PROTECTION
FROM THESE OUTCOMES TO THE FAIR
RATE OF RETURN IS JUST LEGALLY,
PURELY FALSE. IF YOU WANT TO
BUILD AN ADU ON YOUR PROPERTY
AND THERE'S EXTREME RENT CONTROL
IMPOSED ON IT LIKE THEY DID IN
DANA POINT, THAT DOESN'T DESTROY
ALL VIABLE USE OF THE PROPERTY.
YOU STILL HAVE A HOUSE ON THE
PROPERTY. THAT'S THAT'S KIND OF
THE PRECURSOR TO BUILDING AN
ADU. THAT'S STILL A VIABLE
ECONOMIC USE OF THE PROPERTY. SO
THERE'S NO THERE'S NO ABILITY TO
OBJECT ON THAT GROUND, THAT
THERE'S NOT AN ABILITY TO GET A
FAIR RATE OF RETURN. AND TO
SENATOR ROTH'S POINT FOR A
DEVELOPER, IF THERE'S NO
BUILDING CONSTRUCTED, YOU DON'T
HAVE A RIGHT TO FAIR RETURN FROM
THAT APARTMENT BUILDING. THERE
CAN BE THAT'S WHAT ZONING DOES.
IT CAN ALLOW FOR OTHER USES OF
THE PROPERTY. IT DOESN'T HAVE TO
ALLOW FOR ALL USES OF THE
PROPERTY. SO IF A CITY IMPOSES
SEVERE RENT CONTROL, HARSH RENT
CONTROL ON A PARTICULAR USE OF
THE PROPERTY TO DISCOURAGE THAT
USE, SO LONG AS THERE'S OTHER
USES OF THE PROPERTY, THERE'S NO
LEGAL CLAIM THAT YOU'VE BEEN
DENIED A RIGHT OF FAIR RETURN.
THE LAST THING AND I CAN TWO
QUICK POINTS. THERE WILL ALSO BE
NO ABILITY OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
PUNISH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHO
FLOUT STATE HOUSING LAWS BY BY
MANIPULATING RENT CONTROL. AND
THIS IS BECAUSE JUST LAST YEAR,
IN 2023, THE CALIFORNIA COURT OF
APPEAL HELD THAT WHEN A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HAS A LEGAL RIGHT TO
ENACT A LAW, THIS LEGISLATURE
CANNOT IMPOSE PUNISHMENTS ON IT
FOR EXERCISING THAT RIGHT. AND
THE THIRD DISTRICT SAID THAT AN
INTENTIONAL PENALTY ON A CITY'S
LAWFUL EXERCISE OF ITS POWERS,
QUOTE, CANNOT STAND. SO UNDER
PROP 33, EVERY CITY AND COUNTY
WILL HAVE THE LEGAL RIGHT TO
ENACT RENT CONTROL POLICY FREE
FROM OVERSIGHT BY THE
LEGISLATURE OR THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH ONCE IT ACQUIRES THAT
POWER. ARTICLE 11 OF THE
CONSTITUTION, WHICH WAS AT PLAY
IN THIS CASE, WILL PROTECT IT
FROM ANY FINANCIAL PENALTIES
THAT THE LEGISLATURE SEEKS TO
IMPOSE FOR TRYING TO SIDESTEP
STATE LAWS. SO THERE'S REALLY NO
WAY OUT OF THE NIMBY TRAP FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THAT
PROPOSITION 33 WOULD SET AND ONE
ONE FINAL POINT ABOUT PROP 33
THAT I THINK IS FAIR TO MENTION.
THE PROPONENTS MENTIONED THAT
THIS IS A RENT CONTROL IS
SOMETHING THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
AND VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS
SUPPORT. THE THEY'VE THEY'VE
USED THAT IN THEIR CAMPAIGN
MATERIALS. VICE PRESIDENT
HARRIS'S PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN
ACTUALLY SENT A CEASE AND DESIST
LETTER, WHICH WE CAN SHARE WITH
THE COMMITTEE TO THE YES ON 33
CAMPAIGN, STATING CLEARLY THAT
THE VICE PRESIDENT HAS NOT
ENDORSED PROP 33 AND THAT THE
YES, ON 33 CAMPAIGN IS VIOLATING
THE VICE PRESIDENT'S PUBLICITY
RIGHTS AND ASKS THEM TO
IMMEDIATELY STOP CIRCULATING
THAT THAT MISLEADING NOTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. LET'S NOW TURN TO MEMBERS
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS, QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. SENATOR WAHAB, THANK
YOU. SO I APPRECIATE YOU GUYS
PRESENTING. AND I KNOW THAT ON A
FOUNDATIONAL AND FUNDAMENTAL
BASIS, WE'RE PROBABLY GOING TO
DISAGREE. SO I JUST WANT TO
PREFACE THAT I KNOW I'VE WORKED
WITH SOME OF YOU GUYS, AND I
KNOW THAT YOU GUYS ARE TRYING TO
DO WHAT'S IN THE BEST INTEREST
FOR YOUR MEMBERS. I DO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT A LOT OF WHAT HAS
BEEN SAID ABOUT PROP 33, AND I
WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR TO THE
PUBLIC, IS THAT THIS BALLOT
MEASURE ALLOWS FOR LOCAL CONTROL
AT THE END OF THE DAY, YOU KNOW,
WE CAN ARGUE AND DO LONG
MONOLOGUES ABOUT FEAR MONGERING
AND, YOU KNOW, YOU KNOW, THE
DETRIMENT OF BUILDING MORE
BUILDINGS AND SO FORTH. AND, AND
IT'S LARGELY INACCURATE. AND THE
REASON WHY I SAY THAT IS BECAUSE
EVEN THE LETTER THAT WAS
REFERENCED REGARDING DANA POINT,
THE DEED RESTRICTION THAT THEY
FOUND INCORRECT, WAS THE FACT
THAT THE CITY WAS TRYING TO
PROHIBIT THE SALE OF THE ADU
SEPARATE TO THE ACTUAL THING. SO
I HAVE NOT SEEN THAT EVERYTHING
ELSE AND POINT BY POINT, I DON'T
NEED TO GO THROUGH IT BECAUSE I
READ IT TALKS ABOUT FIRE
RESTRICTION, TALK ABOUT SOLAR,
TALK ABOUT EVERYTHING ELSE. AND
AGAIN, FIRST AND FOREMOST, JUST
BASED ON THE LAST PANEL THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT, IS THAT LOCAL
CITIES KNOW WHAT IS IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THEIR CONSTITUENCY
NUMBER ONE, AND WE SHOULD
EMPOWER THEM. WE CONSTANTLY TALK
ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL ON EVERY
OTHER ISSUE, INCLUDING OTHER
BALLOT MEASURES REGARDING PUBLIC
SAFETY AND MUCH MORE. AND THIS
PARTICULAR LAW HAS BEEN ENACTED
FOR MORE THAN TWO DECADES AT
THIS POINT. RIGHT. AND CLEARLY,
WE HAVE GONE FROM, YOU KNOW, THE
90S AND SO FORTH, AND EVEN, YOU
KNOW, UNITS THAT WERE AFFORDABLE
PRIOR TO THE 90S AND STUFF LIKE
THAT, BASED ON RENT CONTROL. AND
SO FORTH, IT IS TIME TO, NUMBER
ONE, UPDATE LAWS THAT ARE OUT OF
DATE AND OUT OF TOUCH WITH
SOCIETY TODAY. THE MERE FACT
THAT MORE THAN 50% OF
CALIFORNIANS THAT ARE RENTERS
CANNOT AFFORD RENTS OR
OVERBURDENED BY HOUSING COSTS.
THE MERE FACT THAT EVEN IF YOU
BELONG TO A UNION, YOU WILL NOT
GET A 5% INCREASE YEAR OVER YEAR
IN YOUR PAY. YET YOU CAN GET A 5
TO 10% INCREASE IN RENTAL UNITS.
THOSE RENTAL UNITS IN PARTICULAR
BEING THE MOST EASILY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THAT A PERSON WHO CANNOT
AFFORD TO BUY A HOME HAS TO
COMPETE IN RIGHT? AS FAR AS WHAT
I SAID ABOUT LOCAL CITIES AND I
SPEAK FROM A CITY PERSPECTIVE AS
A LOCAL COUNCIL MEMBER, IS THAT
MOST CITIES WILL DO A BALANCED
ACT IN REGARDS TO ENSURING THAT
THE LANDLORD IS PROTECTED,
ESPECIALLY THE SINGLE FAMILY
LANDLORDS. BUT THOSE THAT ARE
CORPORATE LANDLORDS WITH
MULTIFAMILY UNITS SHOULD HAVE
SAFEGUARDS THAT PROTECT THE
RESIDENTS THAT ARE LARGELY
IMMIGRANT, LARGELY LOWER INCOME,
LARGELY STRUGGLING AND CANNOT
AFFORD LEGAL REPRESENTATION.
RIGHT. THERE'S STILL PLENTY OF
REASONS TO EVICT PEOPLE. THERE'S
STILL PLENTY OF REASONS,
INCLUDING FAILURE TO PAY. THERE
ARE STILL PLENTY OF OTHER
BENEFITS TO LOCAL RENT
STABILIZATION AND RENT CONTROL.
WE KEEP TALKING ABOUT IT, BUT
MOST CITIES ARE MOVING TO RENT
STABILIZATION, GIVING SOME
AUTONOMY TO THE LANDLORD. SO I
REALLY WANT TO STRESS THAT. AND
RIGHT NOW, YOU KNOW, WE TALK
ABOUT MULTIPLE PANELISTS HAVE
STATED THAT THEIR 30 SOMETHING
YEAR OLD CHILDREN LIVE WITH
THEM, RIGHT, 100%. AND THE
REALITY IS THAT EVEN WITH GOOD
JOBS, AS OUR LAST PANELIST
STATED, THEY CANNOT EVEN AFFORD
TO RENT BECAUSE MOST PEOPLE,
MOST LANDLORDS HAVE BEEN
UTILIZING THIS AS A TAX SCHEME
TO KEEP THEIR VACANT UNIT TAKE A
LOSS IF THEY NEED TO, RIGHT?
RATHER THAN LOWERING THE RENTS.
WE TALKED ABOUT MANIPULATION. I
HEARD THAT RENT MANIPULATION,
AND LET'S BE HONEST, THAT IF A
LANDLORD OWNS, YOU KNOW, 100
UNITS, 60 PLUS UNITS, MULTIPLE
PROPERTIES IN A SINGLE CITY,
WHICH IN MY CITY THERE ARE
LANDLORDS THAT OWN MULTIPLE
PROPERTIES, THEY MANIPULATE THE
RENTS. IF THEY JUST INCREASE THE
PRICE ON JUST THEIR UNITS ALONE.
RIGHT. I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
THE WHOLE POINT OF THIS
PROPOSITION IS TO GIVE LOCAL
CITIES THE AUTHORITY TO DO WHAT
THEY SEE IS GOING ON IN THEIR
CITIES. EVERY SINGLE CITY IS
DIFFERENT. YOU REFERENCED
HUNTINGTON BEACH, AND I'M GONNA
BE HONEST, THERE'S PLENTY OF
POLICIES THAT THEY'VE TRIED TO
ENACT THAT IS ANTI-POOR AND
RESTRICTS AND PUNISHES PEOPLE
FOR BEING POOR. SO TAKE THAT
CITY AND THEN TAKE A CITY LIKE
HAYWARD THAT HAS BEEN PRODUCING
100% BRAND NEW AFFORDABLE UNITS
EVERY SINGLE STATE POLICY IS
MORE FOCUSED ON DEVELOPMENT THAN
IT IS ON THE, YOU KNOW,
SAFEGUARDS FOR RENTERS
CURRENTLY. AND SO FOR ME, THERE
IS A DISCONNECT BETWEEN THE
STATE LEGISLATURE AND LOCAL CITY
COUNCILS. AND I THINK LOCAL CITY
COUNCILS, THE FACT THAT AVERAGE
PEOPLE CAN GO TO THEIR LOCAL
CITY COUNCIL EVERY TUESDAY NIGHT
OR WEDNESDAY NIGHT OR MONDAY
NIGHT OR WHENEVER THEY HAVE CITY
COUNCIL AND COMPLAIN DIRECTLY TO
THEIR STAKEHOLDERS AND THEIR
REPRESENTATIVES IS FAR MORE
INFLUENTIAL THAN, YOU KNOW.
HAVING A NUMBER OF LOBBYISTS
THAT REALLY, YOU KNOW, DOMINATE
THIS BUILDING. AND THAT'S MY
FRUSTRATION. THE MEASURE THAT
WAS MENTIONED ABOUT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAVID CHU'S BILL
1482 THAT HAS A RENT CEILING OF
ABOUT 10%, RIGHT, 5% PLUS CPI,
BUT NO MORE THAN 10%. WE ALL
KNOW THE DETAILS. I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT WE RECEIVED.
OBVIOUSLY, THERE WAS A LETTER
AND I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT IT
BECAUSE THE LETTER SPECIFICALLY
FROM THE APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
AT THE TIME IN SUPPORT OF THIS,
WAS HOUSING THAT HAS BEEN ISSUED
A CERTIFICATE OF OCCUPANCY
WITHIN THE PREVIOUS 20 YEARS, IS
EXEMPT FROM THE PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL. MAKE CLEAR THAT THE
PROVISIONS WITHIN THE BILL
OCCUPY THE FIELD FOR THE HOUSING
SPECIFIED WITHIN THE BILL, AND
CLARIFY THAT THE VACANCY
DECONTROL PROVISIONS AND PROVIDE
CLARIFYING LANGUAGE RELATING TO
CAUSE RENT AND LEASE PROVISIONS
RIGHT AND IN ITS FINAL FORM,
WITH THE SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
ASSOCIATION, IT WAS ONLY
EXEMPTED TO NEW CONSTRUCTION
WITHIN THE PAST 15 YEARS. RIGHT.
MOST CITIES WOULD SUPPORT
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
SUPPORTED SOMETHING LIKE THAT. I
HAD A BILL LAST YEAR THAT
ADJUSTED COSTA-HAWKINS RIGHT.
JUST DID A REFORM THAT SAYS THE
LAST 15 TO 20 YEARS, THE
BUILDINGS, IF THEY'RE OLDER THAN
15 OR 20 YEARS OLD, SHOULD BE
UNDER SOME TYPE OF RENT CONTROL
OR RENT STABILIZATION BASED ON
WHATEVER THE LOCAL COUNCIL DEEMS
NECESSARY FOR THEIR CITY. THE
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION WAS
OPPOSED. I SOMETIMES WONDER WHY
THEY'RE OPPOSED SOMETIMES AND
NOT OPPOSE OTHER TIMES, RIGHT?
WHEN THE CONTEXT AND THE MERIT
OF THE DISCUSSION IS THE SAME
AND WE ARE IN A MORE DIRE
SITUATION DAY AFTER DAY, WE SEE
THE COST OF EVERYTHING GO UP.
MOST LANDLORDS TRANSFER OVER
THOSE COSTS TO THEIR TENANTS.
UTILITIES. WE AS TENANTS PAY
PARKING. WE AS TENANTS PAY
WATER, WE AS TENANTS PAY
SECURITY DEPOSIT. WE AS TENANTS
PAY LITERALLY. WE PAY FOR
EVERYTHING. THERE IS NO WAY THAT
AN AVERAGE RESIDENT IN
CALIFORNIA CAN AFFORD TO COMPETE
IN MY DISTRICT AND BUY A HOME
FOR $1.4 MILLION, UNION WORKER
OR NOT, LET ALONE SENIORS ON
FIXED INCOME, ON SOCIAL SECURITY
THAT ARE NOT GOING TO GET AN
INCREASE. SO I SEE THIS, BUT I
WANT TO ALSO HIGHLIGHT THAT THE
STATE LAW GENUINELY RESTRICTS
CITIES SO MUCH THAT IT HAS
STRANGLED WHAT CITIES CAN DO TO
PROVIDE FOR THEIR RESIDENTS ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND THIS
PROPOSITION, I UNDERSTAND YOUR
VIEWPOINT, BUT I WILL SAY WOULD
ALLOW CITIES TO HAVE A LITTLE
BIT MORE CLARITY AND AUTONOMY ON
WHAT THEY ARE ELECTED TO DO, AND
I THINK THAT'S FAIR. THANK YOU.
ALRIGHTY. WHO WOULD LIKE TO
RESPOND? WE'RE ALL AWAKE. WE'LL
START WITH MR. CURT, AND THEN
WE'LL TURN TO MISS CARLTON AND I
ASSUME YOU'LL PROBABLY COVER ALL
THE GROUND THAT HAS BEEN
COVERED. SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE
A COUPLE OF COMMENTS BECAUSE
CLEARLY I DON'T WANT TO GET INTO
A DEBATE WITH YOU. YOU'LL SLICE
AND DICE ME AND SEND ME OUT THE
DOOR. BUT THE LOCAL CONTROL
QUESTION, WHICH IS WHAT SB 33 IS
ALL ABOUT, IT'S A VERY IT HAS A
CHARM, VERY SEDUCTIVE. AS IT
SAID IN ONE OF THOSE EDITORIALS.
BUT LOCAL CONTROL IS NOT THE
ANSWER TO THE SOCIETY AS A
WHOLE. PROBLEMS. AND IN HOUSING,
IT'S CLEAR THAT LOCAL CONTROL
WAS THE CAUSE OVER THE 40 OR 50
YEARS THAT WE'VE BEEN WATCHING
CALIFORNIA GROW. SO I REALLY
CAUTION YOU TO SAY THAT EVERY
CITY HAS ITS OWN. IT DOES. IT
HAS ITS OWN PEOPLE, THEIR
WELFARE IN MIND, BUT THEY DON'T
CARE NECESSARILY ABOUT THE REST
OF THE PEOPLE. AND THAT'S WHY
THE STATE HAS TO COME IN AND
SAY, WELL, THAT'S FINE FOR YOUR
PEOPLE, BUT YOU ARE
DISCRIMINATING AGAINST A
DISADVANTAGED GROUP OF ONE SORT
OR ANOTHER. YOU CANNOT DO THAT
WITH PROP 33. I THINK IT'S BEEN
MADE CLEAR THAT THE CITY NOW HAS
AUTHORITY TO ACTUALLY
DISCRIMINATE IN A VERY CLEVER
WAY. SO I WOULD LEAVE YOU WITH
THAT. BUT ONE, JERRY BROWN
QUOTE, IF YOU'LL FORGIVE ME, HE
SAID. AND I THINK HE QUOTED
SOMEBODY ELSE. CONSISTENCY IS
THE HOBGOBLIN, HOBGOBLIN OF
SMALL MINDS. I THINK HE SAID
THAT. BUT NO, REALLY, IT'S THE
LOCAL CONTROL ISSUE. I AM NOT
SAYING THAT THE LAWS WE HAVE NOW
ARE REALLY ADEQUATE. WE WOULDN'T
BE HERE. BUT YOU CAN CONTINUE TO
POKE THEM, PUSH THEM, PROD THEM.
THE WHOLE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ISSUE OF YOU HAVE A CARROT AND A
STICK AND YOU CAN BUILD A MARKET
RATE HOUSING AND YOU'LL GET
BREAKS ON SEQUA AND ZONING. IF
YOU BRING IN INCLUSIONARY
HOUSING TO A DEGREE OF 20%, 30%,
WHICH YOU ALL TALK ABOUT AND
ARGUE OVER. BUT IF YOU DO THIS,
YOU DON'T HAVE THAT ABILITY.
THAT AND FOR THE REST OF IT, I
DEFER TO YOU. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU, MISS CARLTON. YES, I WOULD
ADD IN MY PRESENTATION TO THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES,
THEY VOTED NOT TO TAKE A
POSITION ON 33. IN THE COMMENTS
OF LEAGUE MEMBERS, THEY SAID
THIS IS NOT ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL,
EVEN THOUGH THEY LOVE LOCAL
CONTROL. RIGHT. THAT'S WHAT
LOCAL CITIES LOVE. BUT IT ALLOWS
FOR OUT-OF-TOWNERS TO COME TO
OUR CITY AND PUT SOMETHING ON
THE BALLOT, PAY FOR SOMETHING ON
THE BALLOT TO IMPOSE RENT
CONTROL. IN A MORE EXTREME WAY
THAN THEY WOULD EVER AGREE TO.
SO THEY DIDN'T BELIEVE. AND
THAT'S WHY THEY VOTED NOT TO
TAKE A POSITION ON 33. THEY
DIDN'T BELIEVE IT WAS ABOUT
LOCAL CONTROL. I AGREE WITH YOU
ABOUT KIDS. MY KIDS WON'T BE
ABLE TO FIND A PLACE TO LIVE,
AND IT'S NOT ABOUT RENT CONTROL.
IT'S ABOUT THE INABILITY TO FIND
A PLACE TO LIVE. IF YOU WANT TO
OUTSMART THE MARKET, I ALWAYS
SAY, THEN BUILD MORE HOUSING,
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING GOING
FORWARD. AND 1482 VERSUS
COSTA-HAWKINS IS VERY DIFFERENT.
AS YOU KNOW, 1482 DOES HAVE A
ROLLING DATE, AND THE CAPS ARE
DIFFERENT RIGHT UNDER
COSTA-HAWKINS SOME CITIES ARE
60% OF THE CONSUMER PRICE INDEX
IN THOSE CITIES, CONSTRUCTION IS
HAMPERED BY THAT KIND AND WOULD
BE HAMPERED BY THAT KIND OF RENT
CAP. SAN FRANCISCO ALREADY SAID
THAT IF 33 PASSES, THEY WILL
IMPOSE RENT CAPS ON NEW
CONSTRUCTION THROUGH NOVEMBER
2024 AND BEYOND. SO TO SAY THAT
CITIES WOULD BE REASONABLE, I
DISAGREE AND DEVELOPERS
DISAGREE. THEY DON'T TRUST THAT.
AND SOME LOCAL ORDINANCES
ALREADY HAVE BUILT IN. IF
COSTA-HAWKINS GOES AWAY, THEY
WILL IMPOSE RENT CONTROL ON
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES ON ADUS AND
OTHER HOUSING. THAT'S NOT
CURRENTLY ALLOWED. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND I WOULD
LIKE TO RESPOND TO THAT ONE. I
THINK AGAIN, TAKING ONE CITY
LIKE SAN FRANCISCO OR HUNTINGTON
BEACH IS THE EXTREMES OF BOTH
ENDS OF THE SPECTRUM. I'M JUST
GOING TO SAY THAT RIGHT? I'M IN
THE BAY AREA, AND SAN FRANCISCO
DOES NOT NECESSARILY REPRESENT
ME. RIGHT. WITH THAT SAID, AB
1482 IS REFERENCED. BUT WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS BALLOT
MEASURE, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT,
YOU KNOW, WHAT I'M HEARING FROM
YOU ALL IS EXTREME CASES, RIGHT?
AND THAT'S NOT AT ALL ACCURATE
THAT THE MAJORITY OF CITIES ARE
DOING, NUMBER ONE, MOST OF THE
STATE LAWS THAT HAVE BEEN
ENACTED WAS PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON
DEVELOPMENT. LET'S STREAMLINE
DEVELOPMENT. WE HAD A COLLEAGUE
HERE THAT REFERENCED
REDEVELOPMENT FUNDS. WE HAVE
HEARD MYSELF INCLUDED IN MY OWN
CITY, THE MAYOR REFERENCED, WE
NEED MORE REDEVELOPMENT FUNDS.
RIGHT. AND I AGREE, WE SHOULD BE
FUNDING DEVELOPMENT. BUT THE
ENTIRE ARGUMENT FROM THIS PANEL
AS WELL AS IN GENERAL REGARDING
HOUSING IS BUILD, BUILD, BUILD,
BUILD, BUILD, BUILD, BUILD. AND
THAT IS NOT GOING TO SAVE
ANYBODY, ESPECIALLY THOSE
STRUGGLING TODAY. OUR JOB AS A
STATE LEGISLATURE, AS WELL AS IN
GENERAL, WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT REPRESENTING THE
COMMUNITY, IS ALSO PUTTING IN
SAFEGUARDS TO PROTECT RESIDENTS
AGAINST GREED AT THE END OF THE
DAY, THAT IS WHAT IT IS. I FIND
IT FASCINATING THAT PEOPLE HAVE
A 100% RIGHT TO GET A RETURN ON
THEIR INVESTMENT. WHEN YOU
INVEST IN THE STOCK, YOU
POTENTIALLY COULD LOSE. WHEN YOU
INVEST IN ANYTHING ELSE YOU
COULD POTENTIALLY LOSE. YET ON
HOUSING, WHICH PEOPLE DESERVE,
RIGHT? PEOPLE ARE STRUGGLING,
FAMILIES ARE STRUGGLING. THEY
ARE WILLING TO PAY THEIR FAIR
SHARE, BUT THEY LITERALLY CANNOT
STAY IN THE CITY THAT THEY GREW
UP IN. WE HAVE SENIORS THAT
CANNOT AFFORD TO LIVE WHERE THEY
ARE. WE HAVE YOUNG STUDENTS THAT
CAN'T COME BACK TO THEIR CITY.
WE HAVE GROWN ADULTS STILL
LIVING WITH THEIR PARENTS. NOT
BY CHOICE, I'M SURE OF THAT.
RIGHT. AND THE REALITY IS THAT
LOCAL CITIES DESERVE THE RIGHT
TO BE ABLE TO SAY, HEY, THE 1995
LANGUAGE OF COSTA-HAWKINS IS
VERY OUT OF TOUCH AND OUT OF
DATE. THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
UPDATED ON A ROLLING BASIS. AND
I'VE SAID THAT I TRIED THAT
AGAIN WITH OPPOSITION FROM MANY
MEMBERS HERE. RIGHT. AND SO I
SAY THAT THERE DOESN'T SEEM TO
BE ANOTHER SOLUTION. THERE
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE A SOLUTION
THAT CAN COME THROUGH THIS
LEGISLATURE AND I'M VERY HONEST
ABOUT THIS BECAUSE I'VE
EXPERIENCED THIS. LITERALLY
EVERY BILL THAT IS ABOUT RENTERS
DIES, RIGHT? UNLESS IT BENEFITS
SOMEHOW LANDLORDS IN SOME
CAPACITY. AND I'M GOING TO SAY
THAT THAT, AGAIN, IS THE REASON
WHY SO MANY COMMUNITY MEMBERS
WHO CAN'T AFFORD TO COME TO
SACRAMENTO AND LOBBY SENATORS
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS, STILL
STRUGGLE AND STILL NEED HELP. WE
ARE BEING BIASED AS AS THE
DISCRIMINATION COMMENT THAT WAS
MADE EARLIER. WE'RE
DISCRIMINATING AGAINST THE
LOWEST INCOME RESIDENTS THAT
CANNOT AFFORD TO PAY A LOBBYIST
TO COME TO THIS BUILDING AND
ENACT STATE LAW TO ACTUALLY HELP
THEM. SO THERE ARE LOCAL CITY
COUNCILS, IN MY OPINION. HAS THE
MOST BENEFIT TO BEING ABLE TO
REPRESENT PROPERLY. ALRIGHTY.
THANK YOU. SENATOR RUSSELL, DO
YOU HAVE A QUESTION? I DON'T
WANT TO TAKE A MINUTE. SURE.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND THANK
YOU TO MY COLLEAGUE. I THINK SHE
WRAPPED IT UP IN THE BEST WAY,
BUT WE CAN'T JUST PEOPLE HAVE
ENTRUSTED IN GOVERNMENT TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE
THEY'RE FACING IN THEIR
LIVELIHOODS, WHAT THEY'RE
FACING. AND THEIR FAMILIES. AND
WE HAVEN'T DONE IT. SO IT'S UP
TO PUTTING SOMETHING ON THE
BALLOT IN ORDER TO ADDRESS IT.
IT'S SO SHAMEFUL THAT IN THIS
STATE, IT'S OKAY TO MAKE TONS OF
MONEY AND PROFITS AND NOT WORRY
ABOUT WHAT THE IMPACT IS ON THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE GETTING EVICTED,
NOT WORRY ABOUT WHAT IT TAKES
FOR 2 OR 3 FAMILIES TO LIVE
TOGETHER. IT'S LIKE, WHY ARE WE
PUTTING THAT KIND OF. THAT KIND
OF A POWER IN THE HANDS OF
PEOPLE AGAINST THE POWER, THE
POWERLESSNESS, POWERLESS PEOPLE
WHO CAN'T AFFORD IT? IT'S IT
JUST THAT'S WHY THAT'S WHERE
WE'RE FACING THIS. BECAUSE
PEOPLE OWNERS, LANDLORDS,
CORPORATIONS ARE GETTING FAR
MORE THAN WHAT THEY SHOULD. THE
FACT THAT THERE'S SO NOT ENOUGH
HOUSING FOR EVERYBODY DOES NOT,
SHOULD NOT GIVE SOMEBODY THE
RIGHT, THE OWNER, THE RIGHT TO
CHARGE THE MAXIMUM TO CHARGE
FIVE TIMES MORE THAN WHAT THEY
NEED. WHY WOULD WE DEFEND THAT?
YOU KNOW, SO I'M JUST I JUST
THINK THESE, THESE ARGUMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN PRESENTED DON'T,
DON'T TAKE INTO ACCOUNT WHAT
PEOPLE NEED. AND POOR PEOPLE AND
WORKING PEOPLE. IT'S REALLY
SHAMEFUL ON THE STATE. ALL
RIGHT. DOES ANYBODY CARE TO
RESPOND. WE'RE GOING TO WRAP IT
UP HERE IN JUST A SECOND. ALL
RIGHT. CAN I JUST SURE. GO AHEAD
QUICKLY. I DON'T THINK THAT THAT
HUNTINGTON BEACH AND DANA POINT
WOULD PROBABLY AGREE WITH
SENATOR WAHAB THAT THEY THINK
LOCALS KNOW BEST TO. THE PROBLEM
IS THAT THEY HAVE A MUCH
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE THAN
WHAT'S PROBABLY BEST FOR THE
STATE OVERALL. WHAT WE GET UNDER
PROP 33 IS RIGHT NOW. WE CAN
THIS LEGISLATURE AND HERE IN
STATE GOVERNMENT, WE CAN ENACT A
STATEWIDE HOUSING POLICY UNDER
PROP 33. THAT'S NO LONGER
POSSIBLE. WE'LL HAVE 482 LOCAL
HOUSING POLICY AT THE CITY
LEVEL. WE'LL HAVE 58 HOUSING
POLICIES AT THE COUNTY LEVEL.
AND THE LEGISLATURE'S ABILITY TO
SORT OF MANAGE THIS STATEWIDE
CRISIS ON A STATEWIDE LEVEL IS
PERMANENTLY REVOKED. AND THAT'S
THE REAL CONCERN THAT CALCHAMBER
HAS ABOUT THIS MEASURE. THERE
ARE A LOT OF LEGITIMATE, YOU
KNOW, PROBLEMS WITH HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA. I DON'T THINK WE
NEED TO DEBATE THAT. THIS
SOLUTION IS ABSOLUTELY THE WRONG
WAY TO GO, BECAUSE IT EMPOWERS
NIMBYS TO BASICALLY EXCLUDE
TYPES OF HOUSING THAT THEY DON'T
WANT, TO THE DETRIMENT OF THE
STATE AS A WHOLE. ALRIGHTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
ONE SECOND. I'M SORRY. ONE
SECOND. WE'LL GIVE YOU ONE
SECOND TO GET INTO THE ECONOMIC
ARGUMENTS, BUT AS A CHILD OF THE
60S, ESSENTIALLY THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT WAS A BASICALLY
A LOCAL CONTROL DEBATE. STATES
RIGHTS. AND I CAN REMEMBER
TALKING TO PEOPLE AND ARGUING
WITH PEOPLE 20 YEARS LATER THAT
IT WAS STATES RIGHTS TO BE
DISCRIMINATORY, BOTH IN THOSE
CASES WAS RACIAL. BUT
FUNDAMENTALLY IT'S ECONOMIC.
AND, YOU KNOW, WHERE I'M COMING
FROM ON THIS THIS IS CLASS. AND
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION BY THE
MANIPULATION OF THE MARKET. AND
I AGREE WITH EVERYTHING YOU'VE
SAID, EXCEPT THE FACT THAT YOU
GIVE IT TO LOCAL CONTROL AND
ANGRY VOTERS. YOU DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S GOING TO COME OUT AND YOU
SEE WHAT'S GOING ON POLITICALLY.
NOW, ANY OUTCOME, WE COULD
CONTINUE THIS DEBATE. BUT ALL
RIGHT. WELL THANK YOU. SO LET'S
TURN NOW TO PUBLIC COMMENT. OH,
SO I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I
APPRECIATE THAT. AND I HOPE THAT
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION, AS WELL AS
EVERYBODY ON THIS PANEL, WOULD
ACTUALLY, LET'S SAY IN THE NEW
YEAR, BRING IN A BILL THAT
ACTUALLY HELPS RENTERS IN
PARTICULAR WITH THESE EXTREME
INCREASES OF PRICES. SO I AGREE,
I WILL SAY ALSO FROM THE PROP
33, THAT LANGUAGE THAT IS
CONCERNING TO YOU IS IN SEVERAL
OF THE BALLOT MEASURES THIS
YEAR. AND I DON'T THINK THAT THE
CHAMBER TOOK THE SAME POSITION
ON THOSE BALLOT MEASURES BASED
ON THAT LANGUAGE. SO THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. LET'S TURN TO PUBLIC
COMMENT NOW IF YOU'D LIKE TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. YES. THE
PANEL YOU MAY STAY OR YOU MAY BE
EXCUSED WHATEVER YOU CHOOSE. ALL
RIGHT. IF YOU WISH TO PROVIDE
COMMENT, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. GIVE US YOUR NAME,
YOUR AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION. EVOLUCIONA. OH, GOOD
AFTERNOON, MARINA ESPINOSA WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM IN OPPOSITION TO PROP
33. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE? ANYONE ELSE WISH TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT? GOING
ONCE, GOING TWICE. ALL RIGHT.
WELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO THE
PANELISTS. BOTH PANELS I
APPRECIATE IT. QUITE AN ANIMATED
VIGOROUS DISCUSSION. THANK YOU
TO MEMBERS OF THE SENATE THAT
WERE HERE TODAY. AND WITH THAT,
WE'RE ADJOURNED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.